We heard and or took action on the following cases.
CPEEM versus the state and options for youth.
Burbank versus education audits panel, audits appeal panel of the California Department of Ed, State Board of Education and State of California.
So we're now ready to resume with item 10.
which is an overview of our career and technical education programs.
We've not had a comprehensive look at this in a while.
There is an awful lot going on.
And so we will begin with that.
It's an information item.
And so Donna Wyatt, are you going to lead this?
Please come up and get us started.
Good morning, Deputy Chief Price and we can't hear you.
Speak up.
No.
Yeah, now we're on.
Okay.
Good morning, Deputy Chief Price, President Kirst, board members.
My name is Donna Wyatt.
I'm the Director of the Career and College Transition Division here at the CDE.
I'm going to be joined in our presentation today by Vantan Quinlivan, our Executive Vice Chancellor of Workforce and Digital Futures with the Community College Chancellor's Office.
And also you'll be hearing from our
California Pathways Joint Advisory Committee members, state board member Ting Sun, and also our co-chair of the advisory committee, Pamela Haynes.
And I'm sorry, I'm a little nervous.
This is the first time I'm in front of you guys.
So, bear with me today.
Okay.
That's good to know.
I'm not so sure after what I saw with Cindy yesterday, but...
Okay, then I'll talk directly to you, Member Rucker.
So, let's see.
I'm sorry.
Again, I'm... Do you want to make it a slideshow?
Oh, yeah.
There we go.
Okay.
Today, our presentation will be an update on both the K-12 Strong Workforce Program and the new Career Technical Education Incentive Grant.
We're referring to it as CTIG-2.
We'll also provide an overview of the work of the California Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory Committee.
And then finally, we'll end our presentation today with an update on the new Perkins V or also known as the Strengthening Career and Technical Education for the 21st Century.
Before we go into the updates on the new CTE programs, I wanted to give a little bit of information on CTE and what career technical education is.
Career Tech Ed is a sequence of courses that build students' knowledge and skills in a given industry.
While integrating and reinforcing academic skills, the development of literacy and computational skills, collaboration, critical thinking, and project-based learning have long been the hallmarks of high-quality CTE.
High-quality CTE is also informed by industry.
Our industry partners are essential to the support of our CTE programs.
They provide information on emerging trends in both technology and labor market.
They inform our CTE standards and our curriculum, as well as provide work-based learning experiences for our students and our teachers.
Work-based learning has recently become synonymous with internship, but work-based learning does not start and end with internship.
It's only through a series of experiences that our students prepare for worksite internships.
Classroom guest speakers, real-world learning projects, worksite visits, and job shadows are all necessary to prepare our students for successful worksite internships.
Industry credentials and certifications provide the proof to employers that students have met a certain level of skill and knowledge necessary for entry-level employment.
Early college credit through articulation and dual enrollment courses provide our students with a vision for their future and instill in our students the confidence and the belief that college can be an option for them.
It brings together CTE teachers across the K through 12 and community college systems in order to support students as they transition across those systems.
We require our teachers to be credentialed as proof of professional preparation.
And the importance of industry experience as part of that credential cannot be discounted.
CTE teachers are required to not only know their CTE model curriculum standards, but how those standards are applied in the industry.
And it's that industry experience that allows them to speak knowledgeably about industry to industry.
It's that essential knowledge of industry and the fact that our CTE teachers come to the classroom with industry experience that allows them to develop the relationships with our industry partners for the benefit of our CTE students.
Our latest enrollment data shows that close to a million students are currently enrolled in K-12 CTE programs and K-12 CTE enrollment has increased by almost 22% since 2012.
This increase is due in part to the investment in CTE through the California Careers Pathway Trust and the CTE Incentive Grant.
The CTE incentive grant, the first grant was a one-time investment across three years of $900 million.
In 2018-19, the Budget Act legislators demonstrated their continued support for CTE through the approval of a new CTE incentive grant.
CTIC II allocates $150 million in ongoing funds for CTE.
This allocation of ongoing funds recognizes not only the importance of high quality CTE, but also the fact that CTE programs are expensive programs for our LEAs to operate.
Michelle McIntosh, our administrator of our CTE leadership office, is leading the work of developing a timeline and application process for the rollout of CTIG 2.
We currently expect applications to go out in early January and division staff will be doing presentations around the state at various CTE conferences, as well as we'll be conducting webinars around CTIG.
We're also working very closely with our community college partners on the second part of the CTE funds, and that's the strong workforce.
And at this point, I'm going to turn it over to Vaughn to talk to you about the K-12 strong workforce program.
Thank you, Donna.
President Kurz, Chief Deputy Price, members of the Board, I know that my Board of Governors, including the Vice President Pam Haynes, whom you'll meet shortly, as well as Chancellor Oakley, would like to
extend their appreciation for our ability to continually work with your agency and your board in order to promote career technical education that is aligned with the needs of the workforce so that our students can stair-step into future economies.
So, we look forward to administering the K-12 Strong Workforce Program, which is extending the strong workforce framework that was developed by the Strong Workforce Task Force that had been commissioned by the Board of Governors.
At the community college level, there was
$248 million distributed across regions of California in order to bring together conversation in coordination because there was a recognition that no one institution could solve all the skill gaps and the workforce issues alone.
And it took the efforts and assets of a region to come together and really think through how do we successfully
equip students with the skills and experience so that they could be successful in the workforce and land and be ready.
And so with the K-12 Strong Workforce Program, this is extending that regional infrastructure to the K-12 partners in order to ensure that you have the ability to sustain many of the investments that had been seeded with, for example, the California Career Pathway Trust.
So the Budget Act allows for $150 million in ongoing funds where the distribution of funds will be done at a regional level in competitive proposals.
And the intent is that those proposals go out in ways that are aligned with the labor market need
but also reflect a lot of the practices that the joint boards have been studying and believe are helpful to students.
So, for example, early career exploration, work-based learning.
These are examples of practices that help students understand the context of why their academic program is so important.
In addition, there's a $14 million in funds where we're going to be putting out a technical assistance provider because, as you know, without the capacity in the field to really do this work, it's difficult to get the work done.
So we look forward to working with the CDE in order to move this forward, and we look forward to many more other collaborations.
Thank you.
At this point, we didn't know if you would want to ask us questions around the two initiative funds or if we should continue with the presentation and I can turn it over to Member Sun and Member Haynes to talk to you about the advisory work.
Yeah, are there questions on this?
This is really a paradigm change, if you will, in terms of what CTE was like many years ago.
And it really...
We've made enormous progress in having regional workforce needs.
There's a large program that the governor has put billions of dollars in for workforce investment.
Workforce investment boards are regional agencies.
The Bay Area has three areas within it.
And so that is a very strong employer component.
And then from the employer component, you get the idea of what the pathways are in that region that are really crucial.
And then what we've been doing is linking the community college endpoint of the career pathway to the pathway begin point.
in the K-12 system.
So it flows from what the regional businesses need, which vary enormously across California, and then starts with the K-12 pathway, which is interlinked with credit and courses to the community college pathway.
So this is really an important shift.
It has a lot of promise.
The history of these have been somewhat unsettling in that in the past, as soon as the money goes away, the collaboration among levels goes away.
So there's not any
tradition or really ways to keep the two sectors together.
And I think that's the challenge.
So maybe you could address, is this going to be, I've lived through tech prep in the Clinton administration.
I lived through things in the Johnson administration.
It all looked very good.
Money went away, everybody went back to his respective corners and did their old thing.
So what's your hope and how are you trying to overcome that?
I think what we've seen in presentations that have been given to the Joint Advisory Committee is that those consortiums or those regional partnerships that were strong before, say, the CPT, remain strong through the CPT.
For those that use the money to fund
administrative positions or things like that, we are hearing that there is a struggle around that.
But those partnerships that were strong before the funds remain strong.
We heard from the Orange County Consortium.
We heard from Tulare County.
We also heard from Sacramento.
So the advisory committee has heard from some very, very strong partnerships that were strong before and remain strong and continue strong.
not based on the funding.
So I think it's a mix across the state and I think that is our work to continue those consortiums with the strong workforce dollars and with the CTIG dollars because we do want to continue on with services for our students.
We don't want to go back to 30-40 years of voc ed.
There's no doubt that it's easier to work in a silo than in a collaborative effort.
And so the governor has been smart in staying the course.
The monies, especially the regional dollars, flow in order to incentivize the coordination and the collaboration.
And so we need to stay the course in terms of that policy focus.
We're beginning to see
Colleges and their partners collaborate in ways and innovate in ways that we hadn't seen before as a result of thinking through region as an organizing unit.
As a matter of fact, last week, thanks to Bill Allen and the Los Angeles Economic Development Corporation, so really the employer entity that's aggregating about 600 to 900 employers together in the LA area,
for every single industry sector, they sat with the community colleges, all 19 community college presidents.
So this is regional scale deployment and laid out the case that cloud computing was such a shortage that it was important for the community colleges and the partners to step in.
And so the announcement was made last week where the community colleges will now do degrees in cloud computing
And all 19 have pledged to work with their K-12 partners to begin stair-stepping students into that industry-recognized credential.
If you are interested in getting into anything digital, and then if you're interested in doing anything that personalizes digital, your data needs to go into the cloud.
And that's why that skill set is so important from a regional economy.
So I think keeping players together in an authentic way allows them to begin to have continued creativity regardless of where the pots of money are coming from.
Yeah, there are other board member questions on this.
I have another one then.
I have two of them actually.
So we spent a half a billion dollars on the Career Pathways Trust Program.
That the Career Pathways Trust Program is linked conceptually to this program.
It's essentially just what I outlined and what our presenters outlined.
So that money is now in its last year, I think.
Yeah.
And so what I've heard is that the ones that had a strong base, yeah, they're fine.
That was before the money came.
Okay.
Then there's some that are
Making progress but need more than three years of money to pull it off.
I mean, that's not a lot of years for this kind of complex thing.
So how will this new money work into the Career Pathways Trust grantees we've made that are sort of in that group that, you know, with more years they could make it, but if you cut them at three years, they're going to die.
Well, I think what we're trying to do is make sure that these two funding sources are complementary to one another, where CTIG will operate pretty much like the first one did, where the first CTIG was really about creating new CTE programs.
Now what we're looking at is you've created those programs.
Now let's improve and expand those programs, where the strong workforce is more of a project-based funding source that goes over 30 months, I think.
Correct?
Yes, and both sources have the same metrics.
Right.
Exactly.
And those metrics also will align with the new metrics under Perkins as well.
So, and that's been a lot of the work that staff have been doing is aligning those metrics and looking at metrics that are going to not just be data for data's sake, but will tell us how to improve our CTE programs.
Do you have any report, my third question, on how
I guess it's $950 million which has been put into the regional occupation centers and programs.
How that has changed the regional occupation programs and centers, I go back to when we authorized those programs in the 1970s.
This board used to approve them one by one.
So they have been around a long time.
And some of them got rather ossified out there.
So I'm wondering, you know, it was an incentive grant, but it was not a competitive grant.
So they had to pledge to do things.
Do you have any report on how that's gone?
Because there again, you're dealing with long-standing dug-in institutions that may be hard to maneuver into new things.
Well, I have to admit to a bias.
I am a product of the Regional Occupational Program.
I started as a teacher in 1990 with Colton Redlands Yucaipa, ROP in Redlands, California.
Also worked for Riverside County, so I have a bias.
We did, through the transition to local control, we did lose some ROPs.
But I think the strength of the Regional Occupational Programs is demonstrated by the fact that the districts, particularly around the joint powers,
authority districts that are JPA ROPs that exist because districts choose to have them continue to exist to deliver their quality career technical education.
I think that is key around those ROPs that did survive through local control.
We started, I believe the numbers were 74 and now we have 52 regional occupational programs.
under the strong workforce program, their match is a one-to-one and I think that's in recognition of the fact that ROPs have always had a regional approach to labor markets.
So, you're not replicating programs within a region.
So, I think they continue to be strong because they have the support of their districts and their districts want them and recognize their expertise around career technical education.
Okay, board member.
Rucker.
Okay, so now I do have a question.
Concerning the different types of funding that you've laid out in front of us and knowing that under the umbrella that is CTE, there are all these programs such as ROP that have been in existence for quite some time.
In what ways has the funding changed the organization of the field so that a lot of the silos that Vaughn has already talked about that do exist
while they're still going to be there because there's this need to continue to label CTE programs and the mounds of work that goes into supporting the infrastructure, in what ways though has the funding required the field to be more collaborative so that ROP programs and districts and even higher ed programs in the community colleges
are being more collaborative in the seamless ways they do the workforce preparation for the students, so that the programs exist not to perpetuate the existence of the programs, but create seamless ways for students to move through those programs in the pathways or the preparation pathways that they've chosen.
I think the fact that the legislation speaks to the need for high-demand, high-skill, high-wage programs.
I think the fact that the legislation speaks to the creation of a pathway, not a standalone CTE course.
And the fact that we're not talking just about CTE programs, but programs of study that integrate and reinforce those academics, include the work-based learning, student support services.
I believe the legislation
takes the idea of, as Vaughn said, operating in a silo or operating just a standalone CTE program to moving it to bridge those gaps across the systems.
Also, with our labor market and our workforce development organizations, industry has always been a part of CTE, so that remains the same.
But I think it's the requirements of these two funding sources and the prior funding sources that said you can't be a standalone CTE course.
You have to build bridges and have a handoff for students.
Okay, so the reason I'm asking that question is I haven't, I'm not seeing that actually happening yet.
So, is it still in the building blocks or the foundational stages of figuring this out?
Because the programs are going forward and students are showing up and enrolling in these programs.
But the linkages among those programs, I'm not, I haven't seen those actually form yet.
So I want to understand, again, how is the funding?
I realize there's requirements in the funding to do it, but you can give lip service to that in your application and get the funding.
Where is the accountability or the evaluation to see how this is happening and the level or quality of that collaboration?
I think that's addressing one of the things that we want to look at in this new CTIG is we want to move away from an application that is a narrative and we want it to be an assessment of CTE programs.
And I think also with the new Perkins authorization, there's a requirement with new Perkins that there be a two-year overall assessment or evaluative assessment of CTE programs as part of that local application.
So I think it's a process that we have to do in changing the application process to say,
No more narratives, as you said, paying lip service, but evaluate your programs, tell us where you need to improve, and then show us how you're going to use the funds to improve that.
And I think it's also important to recognize, too, that during the recession, we lost a lot of CTE programs.
And there has been, while we're developing these bridges and extending these programs, there's also been a build back that has had to happen as well.
And you know what my last question is going to be because I ask you this question every time there's two or three people together.
So we lost during the recession a lot of CTE programs.
But just as a factor of the aging of our workforce, we're losing a lot of certificated CTE teachers.
How can this funding or how can the work that's being done, not only with Perkins too, but with the work that's being done to broaden the field and to define this collaboration
among these elements, what can be done to pay attention to what needs to be a development and build up of the workforce?
So glad you asked me that because we are working with the Teaching Commission on a new study on CTE addressing the teacher shortage.
So similar to the study that came out from on special education, we have just started working on a study on that.
So we're going to address the CTE shortage.
And the idea of the report is not going to be just a report on what's happening, but make some really solid recommendations on how we address the CTE shortage.
How do we get industry folks into the classroom for our students?
So we are addressing that with this study.
Okay, so in doing the work with the commission, you're saying that the primary issue of the CTE shortage is a certification issue?
I think that's part of it.
I think part of it also is the fact that in those industry sectors where we have the most demand, information, communication, technologies, health science, it's difficult to get industry to come into the classroom because of teaching salaries.
What about the fact about the government pension offset, something we can't do anything about in this room?
Yes.
But that can't be ignored because that's a principal obstacle as well.
No, and we have been talking about that as well.
Okay.
Thank you.
Okay, well then maybe we're ready to move on to the board members.
We formed a joint advisory board.
Ting Sun will describe it for us.
And Vice Chair Hayes from Community Colleges is welcome to see you here and your hard work with us together.
Hi.
Good morning.
So you guys look a little intimidating from this side.
Reminds me I have to smile a little bit more when people present.
So I'm really pleased to be presenting to you with my colleague Pamela Haynes from the Community College Board of Governors.
So I want to talk a little bit about the Joint Advisory Committee.
So I want to talk to you a little bit about the work of the Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory Committee.
So first I want to point out that this advisory committee of the State Board of Education and the Community College Board of Governors is not new.
It was actually established under Ed Code
Gosh, I think in the 70s or something.
I did a Google search and I saw something in the 70s.
So, and the original idea was to aid in the support of planning and coordinating vocational education and training programs.
I used to chair this.
Oh, you did?
In the 70s.
So, its original charge was to review and comment on proposals, policies, procedures, and the allocation of funds to voc ed.
In response to the changing times and current workforce needs, this new and improved
advisory committee has embraced a mission that is broader than what was originally outlined in Ed Code.
I see our work as more than promoting high quality CDE programs.
In fact, what we are doing is shaping the preparation of youth to participate in an evolving and competitive world economy and to achieve to their highest potential.
Consequently, you will hear from my colleague,
Pamela Haynes, our guiding principles focus on the educational and employment equity access and attainment.
In fact, the joint advisory committee has a role in both the CTE incentive grant as well as the K-12.
This is where my next slide goes.
as well as the K-12 Strong Workforce Program.
Most recently, the 2018 Budget Act has charged the committee with making annual recommendations to the legislature and the Department of Finance on appropriate metrics to measure and evaluate applicants of both of these programs.
So some of the questions, President Hirsh, that you brought up and Member Rucker, you had brought up around concerns, the partnerships, the coherence, cohesiveness.
Is that going to continue?
That is part of the work of this committee through our principles and through the establishment of these metrics.
So the committee is made up of three state board members, Feliza Ortiz-Lacon and Patricia Rucker, who are my colleagues.
And then on the board of governors, we have a new member, Joe Alinda Grande, Pamela Haynes, who serves as our vice chair, and Valerie Shaw.
Prior to this, Joseph Belansky has worked with us over the last couple years.
And we also have two ex-officio members, Gustavo Herrera from Young Invincibles and David Rathbree from the Los Angeles Area Chamber of Commerce.
We've met seven times now, and we hope to have two, well, we will have two more meetings before the end of this year.
And so we'll have nine meetings.
In that time, we have done a recognizance of the different kinds of CTE programs throughout the state.
We've heard from various stakeholders at all different levels so that we can glean an idea of what is currently out there in the landscape of CTE programs in California, and then what we need to do to help support and bring the work forward, the high-quality work that they have been doing forward.
So the guiding principles we have been working on and my colleague Pamela Haynes will be going through some of the details of those principles.
So thank you for having us.
The nuts and bolts of the work that we are doing or have done is really in formulating and developing the guiding principles.
From December 2017 to May
2018, the committee sensitized information that had been presented to create the guiding policy principles to support K-14 and pathways.
and a document emerged out of that work.
During these meetings, committee members also reviewed, discussed, and provided clarity on specific elements of what it needed to be within that document.
During the March and May 2018 meetings, the committee approved the document and requested feedback from the public.
The guiding principles are critical to the overarching values that we present through those principles.
A focus on student-centered delivery of services, the promotion of equity and access,
with the goal of achieving system alignment, that's really where the rubber hits the road relative to collaboration.
If we cannot figure out how to share our data and align our systems, then we're not going to be successful.
And it means that at some level, our students are not going to be successful as well.
The guiding principles also include support for continuous improvement and capacity building.
and to also ensure that the state priorities and the direction lead us to a state plan.
It also needs to be, we've said this, but the clear elements of this is really student-centeredness.
We say that, but we really, in every one of our decisions, we have to say those words.
Is this in service to students?
If we don't, if that falls behind, then we'll end up doing, in many cases, what we think is important, but may not be important on behalf of students.
Equity, and we talked a lot about this, equity is a word, but it has to permeate every one of our values and every one of our principles.
We cannot afford, in this day and age, to leave anyone behind.
And given the demographics in this state, it's essential that we bring everyone along.
We have to also ensure that we are building leadership at all levels and that there is high quality integrated curriculum and instruction.
And I wanna pause here.
We have to make certain that the curriculum and the instruction is relevant.
We are living in,
an economic time and an economy that is continually changing and therefore we cannot just create instruction and curriculum and just think that that's going to last us for five years or four years.
It has to be ever evolving.
And we have to make certain that we're listening to those folks that are creating those jobs in industries that are relevant to make certain that our curriculum matches their particular needs.
And the industry is meeting a broader need, and that is the consumer need.
And we are indeed a consumer economy.
We also will need to have skilled instruction and educational leadership informed by professional learning.
And I say this, and I want to also stop to say that if we are not making certain that those in the field are not getting the political
development that they need in order to make certain that they are delivering for our students the high quality of instruction and curriculum, then we all feel.
So all of these are working in tandem with each other.
The essential elements of this high quality college and career pathway also will include career exploration and student supports.
I have an aside.
I have granddaughters in Los Angeles.
My daughter is an LA Unified District school teacher.
She's third generation teachers in LA Unified School District.
My granddaughters go to LA Unified
school district.
And what I have seen, and I have families, what I have seen are in some cases students not getting that career exploration where they need it.
And they come to us, rightly so, but they come to us with not a lot of knowledge about what it is they want to do.
And we've got to change that.
We both together need to change that piece of it.
That exploration needs to happen.
And it's not that they're going to make that decision.
It's going to be the only decision they make relative to their education.
But they need to know what's available out there.
It needs to be relevant.
They need to have a feeling about what that feels like.
relative to the expiration.
I have my granddaughters in middle school and so she's telling me of the pathways that she's learning.
Now she doesn't call them pathways.
She calls it a rotation every, I don't know, four or five weeks in something different.
That's expiration for her and that's absolutely what's needed across both of our systems.
There has to be also appropriate use of data and continuous improvement.
Cross-system alignment.
For me, that's critical.
We cannot make good decisions unless we can align our systems and we use data in that decision-making process.
Somebody mentioned collaboration.
That's where collaboration has to happen.
It has to happen in the field.
These are wonderful principles, but unless we push this down, unless they are embraced in the field and incorporated in the workings of what folks do every day on our campuses,
and within the K-12 system at the school level, then we're not going to be as successful as we should be.
We also have to have intentional recruitment
and marketing.
That means promotion.
It means outreach.
It means communication.
And it needs to be the communication that's relevant not just to some of the external folks.
It needs to be relevant to our high school students and our middle school students.
What they see, what they do, isn't how we gather information.
We have to use their methods of communication, and we have to do it well.
And we have to use their vocabulary and their language in order to communicate so that they understand all of the possibilities that are in front of them.
And we have to also find sustained investments in funding through mutual agreements.
We have to have partnerships.
We have to have collaboration, or all of these principles are for naught.
So the working norms for fostering a mutual, beneficial, intersegmental relationship, it's got to be frequent.
It's got to be open.
It's got to be intentional communication.
And the openness is critical.
We have to be willing to share not only our successes, but our awards.
it doesn't work.
And so that means building trust and it means breaking down barriers.
And it also means frequency.
It means that we talk to each other and we feel comfortable in doing that.
And when I say talk, I mean every method of talking, email, webinars, whatever those communications are that we can continue our conversations and we can work together collaboratively.
We also have to have, and I think this was somewhat mentioned, a mindset shift to coordinate and plan and to enter dependent and implementation of systems.
This is, as someone said, a complete shift on how we have done and how we've worked in the past.
So, roll up your sleeves, put on your boots, put on your skates, because that's what we're going to need.
And we've got to leverage and build upon and or replicate effective models and practices.
There are models out there.
We got chance, we had an opportunity to see them working.
I was extremely impressed on what I saw.
We just now need, this is a big state.
We got a lot of students.
We now need to replicate that and do best practices across the state.
I believe that if there's a will, as my daddy said, there's a way.
And then finally, thank you.
And then finally, we need to build a new culture for our institutions and incentivize behaviors and relationships.
We do have to incentivize.
And we'll have to figure out how we're going to do that.
This is not just about money, but we really do have to repurpose our dollars.
We will need to put dollars where they absolutely need to be, because we do need to incentivize different practices.
And then the ongoing relationships through sustained funding and mutual agreements.
I think I've already said that.
And there needs to be, finally, a commitment to the work to create stability and sustainability.
And I think as you build it, those are the two things that are part of the building blocks.
We have to figure out how to sustain this.
And so that means not just in good times, but it also means in preparation for the bad times.
Because if we really do care about it, we need to figure out how to keep it.
Thank you.
So to close this section, so to also help maybe address President Kurtz's question about what happened to the $900 million investment that we've made in California, we have these shining lights of programs that have evolved.
But also what has resulted from that is what I feel a new constitution through these principles about how the state should move forward collaboratively in developing stronger workforce pathways programs throughout the state.
And so I encourage anyone
to go to the website, provide any comments on our principles, take a look at that.
I think that this is how we will move forward together.
What's been wonderful about this committee is that we didn't just get together so that we can figure out how we split the money or how we're going to use money.
It was not a transactional relationship.
It was actually, it was building relationships actually through these principles so that we have a common understanding moving forward.
And so with that, we're gonna close with how we are going to move forward from here.
Donna.
So before we move forward, I want to update you on the Strengthening Career and Technical Education Act in the 21st century.
Our federal legislators surprised us with an authorization of this on July 31st, 2018 of this year.
So we are referring to it as Perkins 5 because it's much easier to refer to it as Perkins 5.
Perkins V funding is split between the community college and the CDE.
Last year, the funding was $120 million.
And the funding split that you see on the screen is mandated by the Act.
New elements to Perkins 5, there is still a hold harmless clause, but it has been updated to 2017-18 levels, which is up from 1998 levels.
Eligible agencies remain essentially the same, but they have expanded the definition of tribal agencies as eligible agencies.
Special populations has been revised and also expanded to include children of active duty military.
There's also an increase in funding for the recruitment of special populations into CTE as well as additional funding for our state institutions.
The new act, this is very exciting and it speaks to what Member Haynes talked about, about the need for career exploration.
The new act uses the definition of ESSA for middle grades.
So that means Perkins will now be able to be used all the way down into fifth grade for career exploration and career guidance activities.
So we're going to get the kids even younger, which is great.
The new state plan will go from a six-year plan to a four-year plan.
For the first time, Perkins V defines the definition or gives a definition for a concentrator.
A secondary concentrator will be defined as a student who completes at least two CTE courses in a single CTE program or program of study.
And then post-secondary will use the definition of a student who has earned at least 12 credits in a CTE program or has completed a program even if it's less than 12 units.
Perkins V also is going to expand the reporting requirements around our core indicators to subgroup and subpopulations, as well as they're going to require us to identify gaps in performance.
With this requirement they are increasing the amount of reserve that we can hold back.
Currently under Perkins 4 it's a 10% reserve.
Perkins 5 increases that to 15% so that we can use those funds to address those disparities or also fund those districts that have higher concentrations or higher numbers of CTE students or are rural districts that need a little bit more help.
Perkins V, as I mentioned earlier, also requires a comprehensive assessment of CTE programs every two years.
And then while the act has to be approved by the feds, we have a lot more autonomy around determining our performance levels as well as our core indicators.
Currently, we're awaiting guidance from the Office of Career, Technical and Adult Education.
They have been corresponding with us, but basically to say we understand you have lots of questions and we have guidance coming.
We have a tentative timeline that shows that 19-20 will be a transition year to the new Perkins with the new act becoming effective on July 1st, 2020.
Our view and the work as we move forward is to work basically under the same idea that our ESSA plan was put together.
And that is that we want the California way to lead the work of Perkins.
We want our state priorities to lead that work.
And at this point, that concludes our presentation and I'm happy to take any questions.
Remember questions, our team's at home.
Still be nice now.
Donna, you did an amazing job.
Congratulations.
Great job.
And I sit on this committee and I just want to thank Vaughn and Pamela for joining us.
And of course, team, you did a great job with the presentation.
This has been
a whole new way of looking at education because we get to work with our family members from community college and understand that we're so different, yet we share the same students.
So there's been a lot of learning between the two systems.
There's been a lot of
let's see, sort of discovery of where we're not aligned and learning each other's language because we speak different languages, even though we're both in education.
So I've really enjoyed this liaison assignment.
We get to work on another state plan.
That is amazing.
And so I think that moving forward, we are having a meeting next week.
It would just we have to continue this conversation and translating for each other because the California way in K-12 may be different than the California way in community college.
if they even call it the California way, right?
So it's going to be an interesting time going through the state plan for Perkins.
And I just want to say that I look forward to it.
I know we have a lot of conversations ahead, but this has been a very collaborative effort.
And I've appreciated learning from the community college and understanding that we are one system at the end of the day, because we're essentially growing the students from K-12 and sharing them with community college.
Thank you.
Okay, Emma is next.
Thank you for your presentation.
I actually attend a career technical high school for health and bioscience, so I really enjoy this work because we have high schoolers graduating with medical assisting certificates, so I see the benefit.
And you had mentioned something about an assessment and you also talked about equity.
So, how are you able to measure equity in districts?
Because what's happening in a lot of places is that the classrooms where the career technical education is happening is not reflecting the population.
And so, how are you going to measure that?
And another part of it is really addressing the difference of equality and equity, because a lot of people are confusing the two, which are very different.
So, how are you able to, like, really clarify that to different communities?
I need to be transparent.
I worked in your district for eight years so I know those pathways that you're speaking of.
I think our principles in the sense that our principles separate equity and access.
I think one of the things that we need to do is to make sure that
we understand that access doesn't just mean a statement of we're open to everybody.
I think access means ensuring that our pathways are welcoming places for all of our students, that our students know that they are welcome in those pathways, that they can achieve in those pathways, that there is a place for them.
I think with regards to equity, one of the things that
I know occurred in Oakland Unified was we didn't always put first choice as most important for students.
We looked at or Oakland looked at the idea that
you wanted pathways to look like the school looked.
And sometimes that meant saying to students, you're not going to get your first choice because it's more important that that pathway look like the school.
So I think that's one thing that locals can do.
I think
It's one of the things that the advisory committee and the larger group that's going to put together the plan that we're going to have to look at, at putting really concrete principles around what do we mean and what does it actually look like on the ground to say equity.
State Board Member Rucker next.
I also want to thank all of you who planned and did the presentation for the board today.
I know that I was very excited knowing that this was on the agenda as an opportunity to share the work that we are doing on this particular subject.
I also want to make sure we recognize all of the staff both from the Department of Ed as well as from the State Board who are supporting us in doing this.
We're very fortunate to have some very talented
knowledgeable and really passionate experts supporting the work that we're doing on this workforce.
So Patricia is one of them.
And so I want to make sure Patricia DeCos was also included and recognized for the work she's doing in supporting this panel.
One of the things in addition to all the items that were outlined by you and as well by board member Lincoln Ortiz,
I learned so much about data.
And not only do we have some differences in how we look at and think about the students that we share, but we have different ideas and different approaches about and even of different levels of granularity about the kind of data that's collected from among our segments.
And I have learned a lot about that.
For example, the higher ed actually has a data system where they track high school students with a definition and collect information with a definition about college readiness.
They have information about how they track course taking for students.
That has to be informed in this plan we're writing anyway.
And that's one of the areas we're struggling with in our data system to understand how to quantify and record
course taking among the students for career technical education.
I think that the conversations we're learning about the differences, not only in what kind of data is collected, but how that data is used is something that can inform our work, not only for our college and career indicator, but in understanding what we're looking for in quantifying
what the activities are that are at our school.
I'm hoping at some point there's a conversation that we can share from the work that's coming out of this work group with the board that can also inform some of the work on the board, particularly on looking at and defining elements in our college career indicator and also looking at the kind of levels of granular information
that the higher ed, the other segments do collect about students in this area that we currently do not.
I think there's an opportunity for us to figure out how to do some data sharing that can inform and better inform the work we're doing here.
Thank you.
Okay.
Board member Valdez.
I think this is a beautiful concerted effort, and I really thank everyone involved.
I think this is the right work to do.
I feel like the guiding principles are timeless, and so they're going to give you that goal of having the stability and the consistency of the program over time, because that's always the concern with CTE.
It seems funding goes up and down, and right now is a really, really good time.
So I think you're really putting in the infrastructure to be able to weather any future concerns.
I really am excited about the early exploration.
And I think that that is something that has a lot of growth potential, if you will.
And I think that that is a wonderful opportunity to get students to wonder about the possibilities.
And then when you actually get them onto a pathway, you build them for success.
And I think that the data coordination is really important.
It's no longer a black hole when they go on and leave our K-12 system, if you will.
And so the light is now on.
And I think that the coordination is incredibly important.
So I thank you for the synergy and the effort.
And this is very, very exciting.
So thank you.
I'd like to mention, too, last year we spent some of our Perkins leadership dollars and established some middle school grants so that we are already reaching out into middle school.
It was a competitive process.
The schools had to align to one of our California partnership academies, which also then had to feed into community college.
So we've already started the work under Perkins IV down to the seventh grade.
So with the new Perkins, we'll be able to go even further.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
You know, I gave a lot of my honeymoon comments.
But I do want to go back to board member Cardenas question because we have addressed that question of do we have hierarchies within schools based on academies where we have the high ranking or best perceived academies that are not reflective of the student population or you see diversification in some of the academies that are
seen as less rigorous, right?
And so we have been very open about those conversations.
What students are eligible for what academies?
Do we put extra requirements for engineering versus humanities or whatever it may be?
So those conversations have taken place.
We want to monitor that.
We want to make sure that there is representation, racial representation, linguistic representation of our students.
We also know that there's a lot of work with that.
I run a national college career readiness program.
And we do place students with internships.
Our affiliates do.
That's a lot of work.
When you're looking at students, you need to have them ready for that.
We teach everything from office etiquette to internships to soft skill development.
And then career exploration, right?
And so you have to do a lot of work before you put them out and place them.
And placing them is a lot of work.
You have to look at transportation.
These are minors.
Are there laws that require certain things?
Liability.
It's a lot of work.
This is not to be understated.
And it has to really be streamlined, because in my case, we're doing this nationally.
So every state has different laws about internships.
But you also have students that are part of your K-12 system that are DACA recipients, undocumented.
How does that place into internships?
So there's a lot of things to consider.
If we really want to be equitable, we can't forget those students that may not have the legal means
to be placed in internships and receive payment for that or receive a stipend.
So a lot of things to consider.
I wanted you to know that we are considering those things, at least we're discussing those things during our joint commission meetings.
Board Member Williams.
Yes, I want to thank you for the presentation as well and ask a question.
My longtime colleague, Patrick Perry, who used to be a vice chancellor at the community college system and is now CIO at the California State University system, told me a long time ago, I remembered this just yesterday in a conversation we were having about how do we know
what kinds of salaries or what kind of wages students make based upon where they go to school or what their major is.
And so I sent him a quick email saying, don't I remember that there's actually databases that do this now?
And he sent me back and sent the link back for all three of them.
The community college system, the CSU system, and the UC system all have
open access databases that have tracked the majors and specialties of the programs their students are in and what the average salaries are after they get out.
So I'm curious whether or not the work you're doing will connect to that and utilize that.
I can tell you that part of the work that we're doing is the development of an MOU for data sharing across the two systems.
But it does remain difficult because of the need for social security numbers, FERPA rules, things like that.
But the work continues and the conversation continues with our colleagues in accountability and legal as well as our community college partners as well.
Yes.
So Patrick Perry joined us in one of the data briefings to share his data needs as well as how it overlaps with the needs of this agency as well as the community colleges.
And as Member Rutger mentioned, really we're at a new frontier in terms of data.
Data used to be for the purpose of looking backwards and reporting.
And I think we're all very much more interested in data for the purpose of continuous improvement and informing performance.
And so there's much interest in terms of easing the ability to have this type of data exchange between the agencies so that we would know questions.
Are these programs successful in terms of their intended outcomes?
And one of the things I thought was fascinating about the data, I'm looking right now at the website Salary Surfer, and that's available to students.
That was one of the things that fascinated me about it, is that if a student, and in the context of maybe 10, 15 minutes ago when you were talking about
early exploration, middle school and trying to figure out what kids, allowing kids the opportunity to figure out what they're interested in and good at and might be thinking about going into a career.
They also have access or could be given access to going to these websites and looking, oh, I'm thinking about an English major versus I'm thinking about a computer science major.
I know from personal experience, that's a big difference because I was an English major.
And it took quite a bit more education to get somewhere from that point.
So the fact that this is available for students to go look and see what kind of difference does it make in future earnings, I think could be an important part of the early learning, early exploration of middle and high school.
I also should mention, too, there's CalCRN, which is the California Career Resource Network, which is the website that's sponsored by the CDE and funded, again, with Perkins leadership dollars that is available for that very same thing and resume building and all of that.
It's a wonderful tool for our students.
Thank you.
OK.
No further questions.
This is an information item.
Thank you very much for this really enlightening and important question.
And we have public comment next.
Yes.
Would the Angela Reed, Cheryl Ryder, and William McGee please come to the podium.
Good morning.
Thank you for allowing me to speak.
My name is William McGee.
I'm a school board member in Hayward Unified School District.
I also sat on the ROP board, so I appreciate this conversation you all are having this morning.
So also as was stated, NSBA passing the Career Tech Education Act is something that our district looked into.
Some of the questions that you all were asking, we also entertained as well.
So some things that our district is looking at is really having human resources understand what career tech education credentials look like.
That is one of the downfalls since we're traditionally looking at traditional credentials.
So that's something that the State Board of Education can help educate people on too.
And then as well as looking at the question of why don't we have CTE teachers, we understand that sometimes or not sometimes, a lot of times it's more lucrative to be in the field that you're working in versus being a teacher.
So looking at incentives and if you all can assist with that and giving local districts more power to do something, that would be great.
Thank you for the conversation.
Good morning President Kirst, Chief Deputy Price, and board members.
Leangela Reed on behalf of KROP, the California Association of Career and College Readiness Organizations.
We want to thank you for the incredible work that's going on and the work of the Workforce Pathways Committee and CDE together, state boards.
I want to thank the Governor for his continued support of CareerTech funding and the integration of funds.
It's an exciting time and we're very pleased to be part of that.
I do want to ring to your attention one, what we truly believe is an unintended consequence.
There's been a great conversation about data today, but there's a little bit of a glitch going on.
Any grant recipient, it has to upload data into CalPASS+.
But to do that, you have to put data into CALPADS.
Since transitioning from CALPASS to CALPASS+, JPAs, ROPs, and county offices have had problems.
They're blocked from logging into the system because they're deemed not eligible to apply.
We know that you want our MSGPs to be part of the problem, but they're not able to do that.
We hope that you will direct staff to work with the organizations and the data system so that they can participate and participate in the grant funds.
They are currently part of CTIG and we think this is important to do.
And we also want to make, we'd like to be part of a larger group putting together a planning plan.
Thanks.
Maybe you can look into this, Deputy Superintendent Price.
Okay.
Thank you.
Good morning.
I'm Cheryl Ryder, Executive Director for Career Development with the Placer County Office of Education.
And I wanted to speak to a couple of questions that President Kirst had and a comment that Mrs. Rucker had.
49 ROP was formed in 1974 and by 2008 we had 71
capstone courses for Pathways.
So we had Pathways with 71 capstone courses that included work-based learning and this was 2008 before the shift in funding.
We know that there's been a loss of funding over the years and CTE ROP programs have closed.
I can attest to that.
Our programs
have gone down to about 14% of what we were in 2008.
And the biggest challenge is that those programs, some of them are shifting to the districts and we celebrate that.
The districts are standing up CTE pathways, but they're really struggling with the work-based learning component, specifically internships and insurance and all those types of things.
So, although ROPs have decreased,
The quality pathways have not necessarily met that level that we want.
Thank you.
And just the shortage of CTE teachers also includes the fact that LEA contracts don't often consider industry folks.
They want secondary subject credentials.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center, only partially with my charter hat on today.
I wanted to tie this back to your discussion yesterday about career and college or career or college.
Most of the big issues like funding, credentialing, data access, etc.
are out of your hands.
But the one issue that's in your hands is this, are we as a state valuing career and college or career or college?
And I got to tell you, when people come to us and say we want to start a CTE charter school, I say you probably don't want to do it until such time as the state has signaled to you that they value career preparation.
And so I would urge you before particularly some of you start terming out, take this issue up, resolve it,
and signal to the field.
Which do you value?
And or or?
Thank you.
All right.
We're now on to the waiver issue.
And we have all the waivers on consent.
W1 through W17.
Board member Son must recuse from this entire vote.
So we will
Let her go.
Are there any public comments on these items?
Yes.
For waiver 15, would Michael Flores-Castaneda please line up?
And then for waiver 16, Terry Novak, Kathy Jansen, Linda Barr, Ramel Antone and Michael Flores-Castaneda.
Tracy Lokman and Leticia Garcia.
Please come forward.
Somebody come forward.
For Waiver 15, Michael Flores-Castaneda.
Waiver 16.
Good morning.
My name is Terry Novacek.
I'm the executive director with Element Education, which manages Dehesa Charter School.
I just want to share that W-16 is not a new waiver, or it is, excuse me, a new waiver, not an extension of a former waiver.
It is a different section of Ed Code as well as different addresses.
When we brought our San Diego centers into compliance by acquiring a countywide benefit, our adjacent county centers were no longer compliant.
We took immediate and continual action by submitting our petition to an adjacent county and are continuing to work with potential authorizers in that county.
Our goal is to form a partnership rather than creating a strained relationship that results when a charter has to appeal.
However, if we must, we will follow the appeal process.
In any case, we are certain we will have this sorted out by next spring.
We have been serving students in these counties for 17 years and have a centrally located administrative team as well as a local staff to serve the students.
We have more than 450 students remaining in the school and more than $4 million in reserves.
We appreciate your consideration.
Good morning, I'm Kathy Jansen and I'm a regional manager in Riverside County.
And I want to talk to you about the community that we are able to provide through these learning centers that we have.
A lot of our students come to us because they're not successful on the five day a week program.
and they come, but they're isolated if they're doing independent study at home.
By us providing two powerful days of education, they can come and meet their credentialed teachers twice a week.
They can work in small groups of 10 to 15 students where they're able to feel successful.
And then we also work with the parents in providing workshops on how to address learning styles of their children, how to integrate the common core standards, and what is a growth mindset and things like that.
So we're working with parents and students to provide a positive community.
Hello, I'm Linda Barr, Orange County Regional Manager.
Our centers are very important for many reasons, but one in particular is that we meet our students' social and emotional needs.
Our at-risk students suffering with anxiety due to bullying, peer pressure, testing, or disconnectedness flourish in our safe space.
The culture that we've created is known throughout the community.
as our enrollment wait list will support.
Our centers in each county allow our students a place to collaborate as they build robots and apply engineering skills in preparation for tournaments.
Our award-winning teams competed at VEX IQ Worlds the past two years.
And finally, we rely on using our centers to meet face-to-face with our special needs students and serve them in an effective and adequate manner.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Tracy Lockman, and I am the AVID district director for our school as well as regional manager for South Riverside County.
The South Riverside County region has our largest UC-bound students.
It is imperative that we continue to offer support to these students through our two days a week program, where we offer AVID for four hours a week, our CTE program, wet labs, and tutoring time with our highly qualified teachers.
These students need our support as they work through their A to G requirements that they need to attend a four-year university.
It is at these very resource centers that helped our school receive a six-year WASC accreditation this past spring.
Thank you for your consideration of the waiver.
Good morning Board.
Ramel Antoine with the California Charter Schools Association speaking in support of the waiver.
I think there's some misunderstanding about the nature of the waiver.
They were trying to come into compliance with Shasta and ultimately have run into some complications in terms of working with local authorizers and they're continuing to do that, putting forward a good faith effort.
They've been serving students for a long time.
It's clear that they're doing really strong work so we ask that you support.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter School Center.
In the interest of time, I'll say me too to those comments.
What I'll also note is we definitely heard you guys when you granted some of the waivers on this topic a little over a year ago that we shouldn't be bringing any back.
And I think for the most part, we've gotten the message out to the field on that.
And Ms.
Novacek and her school clearly understood that as well.
That's why they've been moving very aggressively at the local level.
This is, I think, a unique circumstance that's separable.
And I hope you will give it some consideration.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Michael Flores-Castaneda with the California Teachers Association.
My apologies.
It's a little rowdy in the other room and I ran over here.
So first on item W16.
Sorry.
On behalf of CTA, we agree with the recommendation to deny the waiver for the following reasons.
Number one, the students need a caring teacher to guide their learning.
And CTA believes regular attendance plays a key role in the student's success.
And also, the students are not doing well in these resource centers.
The academic performance of these charter school students scored below county averages.
And lastly, most importantly, with the 2016 Anderson decision, we feel that this decision has already been decided in the courts.
Thank you.
Do I speak on 15 now or just come back up?
Sure.
Hi, good morning.
Leticia Garcia on behalf of Riverside County Superintendent of Schools, Dr. Judy White, and I am here also to speak on Waiver 16 in support of the staff recommendation to deny the request for the reasons mentioned when the prior speaker, especially around educational achievement.
The students served by these resource centers have consistently and historically performed lower than countywide averages.
and especially with the low-income student population.
So for these reasons, we also support staff recommendation.
Thank you.
Once again, Michael Flores Castaneda with CTA.
On item W15, I have a letter and I'll have to go back and get it and bring it back because like I said, I ran over here.
We, CTA, along with the Teachers, Turlock Teachers Association, are opposed to the request for the waiver for W15.
As a special ed teacher myself, I know all too well the burden that it puts on it.
My case load last year soared to the point where I really considered leaving my district.
And it's continually gotten worse through the years.
I started my first year in Arvin with six students and two instructional aides.
And last year, I had 15 with two and a half instructional aides.
So we are asking that you deny the waiver request.
But if not, the request also is that you would have conditions on the approval with more oversight and monitoring, excuse me, including a monthly report to the special ed division of CDE.
Thank you.
And I'll bring the letter back.
Right.
That concludes the public testimony.
So the motion ought to be worded to approve the CDE recommendations on all of the waivers.
And because some are for denial and some are from approval under the CDE.
So I'm ready for a motion for W1 through W17.
To approve.
the staff recommendations on all of the waivers as listed.
Second.
Any board member discussion?
If not, all those raise your hands.
Approved unanimously.
Okay, we're now ready then for the proposed consent calendar items.
Items 11 through 14.
These are items on consent.
Yes, and we have several recusals on item 11.
We have Karen Valdez and Ting Sun recusing.
These are numbers 653 and 1030.
And these were item recusals on those two numbers.
are by Karen Valdez and Ting Sun.
So we will take three consent votes.
This is the first consent vote.
Are there any public comments on these consent items?
There is no one signed up for public comment.
Okay, then I'm ready for a motion on item on these two waivers.
6531030 is the second one.
Move the staff, move the recommendation for approval of these CONAPs.
All right.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
So we have those.
Then the second consent vote, which is Feliza and Eileen Strauss must refuse for the rest of the schools and the attachment of these consolidated applications.
And this is item 11 only.
Move approval of the CONAPS in item 11.
With the remaining CONAPS, yeah.
Okay.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
And now we have consent items 12 through 14.
We have no recusals on that.
So we will get our members back who can vote on these.
Okay, ready for a motion on that.
Move those consent items.
All right, moved and seconded and all in favor raise your hands.
All right, that's fine.
Okay, before we take up the next item, let's take a 10-minute break.
Come back around 10 at 1015.
Okay, the board will reconvene and we're ready now for item 15 on the Perseverance Preparatory School Material Revision.
So Lisa will present to us and then we will take technical questions and then public comment and so on.
Yeah, this will be a public hearing when we get to it.
Item 15 is for Perseverance Preparatory School.
It is a request for material revision.
Perseverance Preparatory School was approved by the State Board back in January.
They were approved for a grade five through eight for a five-year term July 1st, 2018 through June 30th, 2023.
There were five conditions as part of that approval and four of those conditions have been met.
One of the conditions was regarding the facility and the facility lease agreement.
It stated that by May 15, 2018, Perseverance would provide the CDE with a fully executed facility lease agreement.
School must open by September 30th, 2018 to retain SBE authorization or be approved for a material revision.
So on May 29th, 2018, CDE received the request for material revision to delay the opening of school by one year due to the inability to secure a facility.
CDE is recommending that the State Board hold a public hearing to approve the request for perseverance for a material revision under the oversight of the State Board.
It will change the opening from 2018-19 to next year 2019-20, but it will continue the same five-year term.
It will not extend out the five-year term for another year.
Our recommendation is based on sound educational program that they are demonstratively likely to successfully implement the program and that they're reasonably comprehensive description of most of the charter elements.
So even with the material revision we do take a look at the petition again.
We do look at their finances again.
So we do a whole entire full review even though it is a material revision.
This item was before the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools on August 14th.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools moved staff's recommendation to approve the request for the material revision and the motion was passed unanimously.
As I mentioned, part of CDE's review, we also took a look at each of those conditions that I mentioned earlier.
So the four conditions, by January 30, 2018, they were to provide evidence that the board had accepted the SBE conditions of authorization.
That condition has been met.
By February 15th of 2018, they were to provide CDE with a revised charter petition containing the necessary changes needed to reflect the SBE as the authorizing entity.
By May 15th, they were to provide us with verifiable and substantive evidence that they had received the funding anticipated from the Silicon School Fund.
That condition has also been met.
By May 15th, they were to provide CDE with a fully executed facility lease agreement, and that is the condition that has not been met.
That is why we are here today.
By June 15th, 2018, provide CDE with a revised budget with complete narrative and assumptions, and that condition has been met.
So CDE did a full review, the sound educational program, and we took a look at the petition again.
We do feel the petition does provide a reasonably comprehensive description of most of the elements, and we've included that review, the A1 as we call it, as part of the attachments for this item.
And if the item, if the school is approved by SBE, the following charter elements do still need to be clarified.
So we will work with the school to clarify some issues we have with the measurable pupil outcomes.
And then as we have seen in a lot of our petitions about the suspension and expulsion procedures that we're still catching up to with the law.
So we'll continue to work with the petitioners on that.
In terms of ability to implement, we did review their multi-year financial plan.
And based on this first year being a planning year and opening in 19-20, we have reviewed it and feel that it is fiscally viable.
They do have positive ending fund balances and adequate reserves for the term from 19-20 to 21-22.
In summary, CDE staff is recommending approval of the material revision based on sound educational program and their fiscal viability and then the clarification of the charter elements in the petition that we will continue to work with the petitioner on.
I'm here and available for any questions that you may have and I know the petitioner is here as well to give a presentation.
Okay, do we have technical questions for
Lisa or not?
If not, then we will proceed to the public hearing.
So we're going to do the public hearing and then public comment and then public discussion.
So I now declare the public hearing open and we will hear from the charter school that's in support of the CDE recommendation.
Okay.
All right.
Sure.
Good morning, President Kirst and trustees of the board and the CDE staff.
Thank you for the work that you have done in the thorough review of our charter and petition again.
My name is Alexandria Lena Talley, and I am the executive director and lead founder of Perseverance Preparatory School.
I begin with our mission as it's our North Star and guides everything we do.
While we were only here a few short months ago, it is important to refocus on what Perseverance Prep strives to do.
Prepare students for a life of ethical leadership and scholarly success.
We were excited, our community was excited, but unfortunately the timeline proved too tight to launch in a private site for the 2018-2019 school year.
To give a brief overview of the progress we have made and the timeline since our approval, I direct your attention to the current slide.
As you know, we were approved on January 19th to open seven months later.
While it was a tight timeline, we were able to hold our lottery, we were fully hired by May, and we were on track to open.
However, despite this progress, our board voted to delay on June 27th.
Our major roadblock, as the CDE mentioned, was our facility.
Although we submitted a Prop 39 request, San Jose Unified declined the offer to offer us a Prop 39 facility, stating that we had too few signatures.
We began seeking private facilities in February after we were made aware of the denial of Prop 39.
However, the City of San Jose considers charter schools as private schools, and thus we must go through different zoning
zoning and permitting processes, which can take anywhere up to five to six months.
So while our facilities search was taking place, we were concurrently hiring.
We received an abundance of teacher applications despite the shortage in San Jose, receiving over 90 applications for six positions.
As previously stated, we were fully hired by May 18th, 2018, and that they were fully offered contracts and signed.
Actually today, as of today, as of yesterday, four of the six have signed on for the 2019-2020 school year, which I think is a testament to the belief in our mission and our vision for Perseverance Preparatory School.
As again, previously stated, we've already begun recruiting for the 2019-2020 school year.
Given our slow growth model, many of our families, all of our families actually will no longer be able to attend.
We were gonna begin with fifth grade and then do a slow growth model, adding on a grade every year after.
And so now that we have pushed back or are hoping to push back for the 2019-2020 school year, those families are no longer able to attend.
And so we've begun our recruiting over again.
Again, we thank the CDE very much for all their work that they have done with us over the past couple months.
We agree with their recommendation and are very eager to work with the State Board as well as the CDE to make any necessary technical amendments.
Any questions?
Right.
We'll have questions later, perhaps.
So this is a public hearing.
So we really do a presentation and that's it.
So if we need to, we'll call you back for questions.
Right.
OK.
Now the opponents to the charter school request will have 10 minutes.
Good morning, everyone.
Stephen McMahon, Deputy Superintendent for the San Jose Unified School District.
I appreciate the time you commit to this process.
I will open with a little bit of honesty.
I would much rather be in San Jose supporting the 30,000 students we have and the 3,000 families, but we do feel an obligation on behalf of the school district to make sure that the record accurately reflects the facts.
We're not in opposition to the revision, but we do want to make sure we're clear about the facility comments.
So you're receiving a packet with documented evidence showing how we reviewed the Prop 39 request.
We followed the law, all of the state boards implementing regulations, clear, consistent communication throughout.
It is absolutely true that facilities in the city of San Jose are incredibly difficult to acquire.
not just for schools, but for people.
If you know Silicon Valley is one of the most expensive places to live in the world, that is to raise the prices of everything.
So it is a challenge for anyone trying to locate a business, a school, housing in Silicon Valley, period.
But San Jose Unified has a pretty successful track record working with charter schools.
We have five leases now.
None of them are officially under Prop 39.
We've worked really collaboratively with charter school partners to find them facilities.
Discovery, Ace Middle School, DCP Middle School, DCP High School, Sunrise, all have multi-year lease agreements in San Jose Unified facilities for charter schools.
We offered to work with Perseverance.
You can see in the documented communications that we went back and forth on what was possible.
They do not have 80 students, which is the Ed Code requirement for in-district numbers for Prop 39.
So what we said is we'll do an in lieu of Prop 39 agreement.
We offered a facility on February 16 in an in-person meeting.
It is expensive, but that's Silicon Valley.
We heard a reply on March 1 and no communication since.
So we do want to make sure that the record accurately reflects that from February 16th when we met in person to March 1st when we received a written response, there was no subsequent communication.
We would have been able to make facilities work on the district side.
We do have classrooms available for 5th, 6th, 7th, 8th grade program.
We just never heard back from the petitioners at all from March 1st until today.
So, happy to answer any questions you have.
We wanted to make sure you had factual evidence in front of you.
All of the documentation is, of course, a public record, so you can independently verify it.
And on behalf of the school district and the families we represent, here to support you in your decision making.
Okay, that now closes that portion of the public hearing, and we're ready for public comment.
Would the following speakers please line up?
At the podium, Ona Keller, Eric Premack, and Romel Anton.
Hi, Ona Keller with the California Teachers Association.
I'm here with a letter from a coalition of labor, community, and civil rights groups in San Jose who came before you in January asking you to deny both this petition and the next one, Promise, which is also asking for material revision.
So I'm going to hand that out.
But I'd just like to make a couple of points.
You know, as the Deputy Superintendent mentioned, Perseverance did not even have enough enrollment to have a Prop 39 request be granted.
And as the petitioner said, she now has zero students who are prepared to enroll.
She's broken a promise to families for this school year and not being able to open.
And it's really kind of unfair to continue to string families along.
and forced them to wait another year for a school that again might not open.
You've actually approved two petitions in the past couple of years that have come back for material revisions and asked to open a year later and then those schools ultimately never opened.
ISLA actually then came back and asked for another petition, a new petition, and you finally rejected them because you saw that the petitioner was really unlikely to succeed.
So I urge you to deny this material revision, thank you.
Good morning again board.
My name is Ramel Antoine, California Charter Schools Association speaking in support of Perseverance.
We worked with Perseverance throughout the process.
They have made every effort to open this year.
They have set out an action plan and have been really in communication with both the department and with CCSA to get any support possible to ensure that they will be able to open this year.
Unfortunately facilities as the Deputy Superintendent talked about are really hard for the school.
They have set out in their submission a plan for what they expect they'll be able to do.
And with support of Silicon Schools Fund and other funders, they'll be able to get a facility.
So we ask you to support.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter School Center, also in support for the same reason.
I'll bring up, though, my broken record, which is material revisions to change a start date are unnecessary.
I'm wasting your time.
You're wasting your time.
Start date is not a required charter element and requiring schools to go through this process is just gives a bad incentive and really, again, encourage you to lance this boil.
Thank you.
OK, that concludes the public comment and the public hearing.
So we're now ready for comment from our charter liaison.
Bruce Holliday Thanks, we have been down this road in the past and It is as we all know always difficult for Charter school to find facilities.
I appreciate deputy superintendent McMahon information that he's provided us does
Appear as though The district was trying to to help and that's that's great.
And that's wonderful.
And As he said they don't have a conflict with this material revision, but I certainly hope that the charter school and the district continue to try to work together and work out a solution so that the school can start up next next fall
So of course there may be other questions and all, but I would move the CDE recommendation.
Board member comment.
I just.
Go ahead.
I just have a comment.
I would support the recommendation.
However, I do worry about some of these charters that start a little bit later.
And we talked about the having enough time before their renewal.
So I would say four years.
We're kind of pushing it by three years.
If they were to come back here again next year, I think it would be very, very difficult.
Okay, Board Member Rucker.
I have a question for the charter itself for the person who made the presentation on their charter.
Okay.
So, I want to be clear.
I want to make sure I understand about the conversations you've had with the district.
I heard from the superintendent that the reason, when you gave your presentation, you said that the district would not give you a Prop 39 facility.
So, I heard the district's explanation about why they wouldn't give you a facility.
I don't believe I heard your explanation about why the district didn't give you the facility.
Could you... And you had a great deal of time to give that explanation, so I'd like to hear that now.
Sure.
So, I believe I stated that they did state that we had less than 80 signatures.
we went back and forth multiple times around what specifically the law requires.
We did believe that we had 80 signatures and I know another, the other charter school did litigate and ultimately won around what they qualify as being proper signatures.
At the end of the day, we didn't, our charter did not want to litigate.
We did try and have a meeting on February with the district to figure out if we could work out an in-lieu agreement.
It turns out that it was exponentially more
Costly to do an in-lieu agreement then prop 39 and the facility that they offered was about 25 minutes away from where we had recruited many of our parents and so without transportation or without having kind of the the length of time needed and we chose also to not move forward with an in-lieu agreement with them and
Okay, so I want to make, I'm going to repeat the essence of what I thought you said.
And because I missed a couple of things, I know I'm going to say something wrong.
So, I want you to correct me.
Okay.
So, what I heard was you had done the work to recruit your students and you believed that you had the adequate number of students to make the Prop 39 request to the district.
The district reviewed your submission or the evidence you gave them concerning your enrollment and they disagreed with what you, with the information you presented.
And so you didn't, so you guys had a back and forth about whether you had 80 or as the district asserts 62.
And you did that for a little bit of time.
And then you ultimately decided to take a look at their secondary offer to do an in-lieu agreement.
Okay.
So on the in lieu agreement, I heard both of you say that property in San Jose is very expensive.
And so it was going to be probably prohibitively more expensive than what you were looking at or what your budget that you submitted for your petition was going to be.
Is that right?
And so, when did you stop?
So, in this timeline, the district is saying they didn't hear from you anymore after March.
When did you all decide to stop with the work to look at another facility?
We were concurrently looking at private facilities.
So,
beginning probably as soon as we were approved, we began looking into both private facility options as well as continuing conversation with the district around both the Prop 39 and then once we were denied, having a follow-up conversation around in-lieu agreements.
So concurrently, I guess.
All right.
So at some point, so in the early spring, I'm going to say March is early spring.
You became aware that there was going to be a facilities concern.
What were your conversations about this concern, about having a site to open in the fall?
What conversations did you have with the parents or the families that you had signed up, who had made the commitment?
And whether it's 62 or 80, what was the conversation you had had with them?
about the concern about whether or not you would actually be able to open up.
When did you have that conversation with them?
We held our lottery in March.
We had 152 applications for 128 spots.
We began holding information sessions in April and then another information session in May.
We were meeting with, we do home visits with each of our families and our students.
So we were meeting with our families and very transparently saying we're really looking into a private facility because we knew that it would be quite prohibitive for not only for the cost of an in-lieu agreement but the fact that the site was 25 minutes away from where our families were and in San Jose morning traffic more around 45 minutes and they just wouldn't be able to do that.
And so we had multiple conversations both through April and May and then ultimately our board voted in June.
And then we spent most of the summer trying to re-enroll our students in other schools.
Okay.
And so, it was 128 families you spoke with, not 80?
Yes.
So when we turn in Prop 39, it's due November 1st.
So we were not actually approved as a charter when we turned in our Prop 39.
Got it.
Very interesting how these timelines line up.
So unfortunately, yes, we did turn those in November 1st.
And then we held our lottery in March, three months after we had been officially approved.
And so then during the summer, you spent the time getting the students placed because you knew you weren't going to be able to open.
And so the last thing that I heard in your presentation is that you're going to have to go back and restart recruitment again.
And what is that going to look like?
So we've already begun re-recruiting students for the 2019-2020 school year.
Frankly, a lot of our students had siblings.
And so we've begun, we have 32 students who have signed on as meaningfully interested so far and are going to continue to recruit throughout the rest of the year.
The reason why I'm asking that is given the conversations that you said were quite in depth with the district this year, what do you believe is going to change on your Prop 39 request for next year that you believe will actually result in you getting a facility?
I think two things.
One, now that we know the facility that they're likely going to offer at Steinbeck, we've begun recruiting more in that area as opposed to our initial original downtown area.
We also, now that we are an officially approved charter, have frankly a lot more clout than when we were recruiting and collecting signatures after when we had no charter and had not been officially approved.
Okay, so I'm going to be really frank with you.
I wish when you made your presentation that you actually had taken the time to explain this.
Because the way, one of the problems with the process we have with doing these appeals is that rather than it being a collaborative conversation, which the district clearly said that there is no antipathy toward your application or your petition, that's not the way or that's not the tone
of the interaction with the district that I actually got from you.
It would have been better for me for you to say what you just explained to me that I had to cross-examine you to get from you.
You don't need to apologize.
But coming here to this board on an appeal and setting up a presentation that suggests that there's great antipathy or even a conflict with the work that you need to do to get you to open your school.
You know, that creates a concern for me.
I'm not going to say you were not, you were dishonest, but you were not fully disclosing everything that was under consideration for that would support the reasons why you really believe you need to have this extension.
It helps me understand better why you believe having the extension gives you the time you need to do the work because you understand what your recruiting strategy needs to be and how the work will go forward.
So I understand that a little bit better.
So, for this facility, if you can get the Prop 39, that will maintain your fiscal concerns, and that will resolve the issue with looking for private facilities, and you would be able to go forward to do the work that you need to do with the district?
Yes.
Okay.
So, now I have a question with the district.
Thank you very much.
Yes.
And apologies again for... Oh, I didn't... I wasn't pointing that out to you to make you apologize.
I didn't mean to ask you to apologize.
It's not why I asked those questions.
Thank you.
I have a question for the district.
Hmm.
Okay, so what I heard from the presentation from the charter school is they believe that next year when they go back to do the work to part of the reason, okay, let me start over.
Part of the reason that was a problem for them with the facilities you were offering is that it was physically in an area or a location that was away from the central core of the student population and the neighborhood they recruited.
Did I misstate that?
That is also what I heard.
Okay.
So, a part of the reason that they are asking for this extension and this time to open is that they have an understanding from you about this facility.
Is the facility that she named the facility that you're offering to them for Prop 39?
Yes.
All right.
And so she believes that if she has the opportunity to do the recruiting because she did indicate she would have to start over with recruiting and they were responsible to make sure the students that they had were placed and started school this year appropriately.
She believes the opportunity to recruit students in that community will bear fruit and they'll be able to open their school at the school site.
Is that your understanding that you would be able to next year also offer her that school site?
So a little bit longer answer on this one.
San Jose is a complicated city.
There's 19 school districts in one city.
There are many charter schools in the county.
Very few of them enroll by boundary.
So it's very common that a charter school would have 60% in district, 40% out of district.
So it's always going to be expensive.
One of my obligations being in charge of the finances is these are not my facilities nor are they Santa's Unified's.
They're the taxpayers.
We have to ensure that we're using them the most efficient and effective way possible.
The school the petitioners are talking about out at Steinbeck formerly had a grade 6, 7, and 8 program.
It was upgraded facility-wise to accommodate middle school students.
It's ready to serve middle school students.
It was a small school model that families were not enrolling at a high rate at, so we routed them to different middle schools.
So we now have idle classrooms for grades 6, 7, and 8 ready to go.
And that's why this facility is being offered.
We understand it's not as close to their original desired outcome.
But again, that's one of the challenges of having a really big city, big county.
We feel like we shouldn't reconfigure other school sites when there are classrooms already available.
So the offer that it was available this fall is likely to be available, or sorry, the past fall is likely to be available again.
If they have the number of students necessary for Prop 39 request, this facility, we have been holding it for a charter school lease, anticipating that there'll be a requester.
Okay, so my other question is not related to an issue in the charter, but the issue she raised for the parents concerning transportation.
You said that you have open enrollment from most of the school sites in your district.
How are the transportation issues resolved?
For those students is their transportation provided by the school the LEA or how do parents resolve that issue on transportation?
And this is not material to the charter itself, but I want to understand what the concern was this year for her aside from And for the non for the for the offer you were making I want to make sure I understand the transportation issues They were considering when they made the decision not to go forward with this alternative offer
So from the district's experience on February 16th, we identified the site and said we're happy to work through all of the necessary logistics to make it happen.
We never heard a response.
Okay, what would be the, was transportation one of those necessary logistics?
It was not raised at the time we talked about it, but we've provided transportation to two of the charter schools, at least from us.
That's what I was waiting to hear.
So we, you know, we're a school district.
If they're in-district students, we're going to provide the full host of services.
Okay, so that's what I was waiting to hear.
Do you want to emphasize, though, in the same way we do that for the 30,000 families we already represent.
Okay.
We have board policies on what qualifies for transportation and what doesn't.
there are thousands of families that wish we had a different bus route.
We don't have the ability to redirect the taxpayer resources to accommodate every individual request.
One of the challenges the district faces with the charter request is you cannot pinpoint the sites
if they're not available.
Because no family has the ability to say, I want my neighborhood school located here.
I want it closer.
So we take the facilities we have, we take the needs of the requester, and we try to best match them.
Same as we do with a lease for the YMCA or any other partner that's using school facilities.
What are their needs?
What do we have?
Let's match them.
But with ACE, we provided bus transportation for ACE students.
We provided them for DCP.
Often when the facilities
were in flux or construction was going on and families were going to have to have a different challenge getting to school.
We transport about 2,000 non-special education students on a daily basis.
I mean, we have one of the bigger networks in the state of California.
We love it.
If you would
help push for some more transportation funding.
Having that block grant locked over time is pretty restrictive.
So if you could sweeten the transportation funding, we could even do more of that.
Okay.
Transportation is an option.
Student nutrition is an option.
All of those things are in the facility lease agreements we have with all five of the charters that have lease agreements already.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate your answers.
Karen Valdez.
If you wouldn't mind coming back up, I'm sorry, I have a quick question.
I have two questions.
So one, could you remind me on the Prop 39, it's due to you in November, is that correct?
Yes.
And so in November, then they will have a list of students.
You will verify whether or not they are residents of your district to be sure you get to that trigger number, correct?
Yes.
And so we're kind of in the same loop that we were last time.
So this is predicated on them having enough by November and that they're verified that they are residents of your district.
and the appropriate age.
And the appropriate age.
So a junior cannot petition to be at a fifth grade facility.
Correct.
And how do you do your verification?
So specific to this, it was just the form submitted.
So we looked at the addresses that were presented, put them in the standard website search that tells you the local school districts.
We look at the age of the students.
You can see in your packet, there's examples.
Each student we remove from the eligibility list, you can see why we did it.
One of the challenges in San Jose is the boundaries.
19 school districts with an address of San Jose.
Many of the parents aren't always sure
that they're in San Jose Unified or Alum Rock or Evergreen.
So the address check is complicated.
We do that, and then we do proof of age and match it to age.
So in the next hearing, process is a little bit different.
But for Perseverance, it was just we looked at the submissions, verified the accuracy of the information presented, and it was 62.
And there was no subsequent disagreement over our methodology when it came to the Perseverance review.
OK, thank you.
And then I have one question for the director, the executive director of the charter.
So if you don't qualify for Prop 39 this coming November, I know you said that it takes the city permits and all of those things.
My question is, can you afford the rent there now?
And why couldn't you afford it last spring if it's not Prop 39?
Sure.
So we had two church facilities that we were in lease negotiations with.
And while we were pretty far down the line with those lease negotiations, it just so happens that the certificate of occupancy is what's actually required.
And it's not the matter of money.
It's just the matter of time.
So the city of San Jose operates a little slower than one would like sometimes.
And so they said that it would take around six months.
And we had just submitted it in about
April or May.
OK.
And then finally in the district's letter where it said they needed notification by March 1st.
Why did you go silent after that.
So our lawyers and I'm happy to bring up.
one of them, Janelle.
We had back and forth, and I had back and forth with our lawyers on what is and is not required of Prop 39.
We knew we had, again, after those conversations with our teachers and our families, that they could not make that commute, that it was better to just go with these private sites.
And we actually didn't find out that the private sites wouldn't work and that the certificate of occupancy permitting process would take six to seven months until much later on.
So you made a decision to not engage and rather just wait it out.
We made a decision to move forward with private facilities instead of try and sign a lease.
That's three times what we initially had budgeted.
Board member Holliday is next.
Well, I appreciate the board members questions.
Thank you.
I appreciate the board members' questions to get down deeper and understand it.
Sometimes Member Williams and I, who know a lot of the background story, don't want to take too much of your time going through all the details.
But it's good to go through all the details, in particular because I think in this case, one thing that is very clear is how
thorough, professional, and helpful the district has been with this charter school and made good efforts at every step of the way to try to make this work, although their price is a little high, I guess, for the MOU.
But it also, I think, once again, because of this discussion, illustrates just how clearly and professionally, or how clearly the charter school has worked
through the process as best as they can with the right intentions, taking care of their families, making sure that their families were notified, making sure that the families were clear about the school not opening.
In addition to that, we have to remember that they have more options now than they had last year.
They have more time.
They have more facility options.
They're working through the private school process in San Jose.
My sense is that the deputy superintendent continues to want to work with this school very successfully.
And in addition to that, they have more time to recruit.
And they have a better idea of where they're going to recruit.
So with all those things in mind, I repeat my motion, the CDE recommendation.
And we have that seconded.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'd like to wind this up soon if we can.
Yes, but I do feel like I need to qualify my vote because I abstained originally when we voted for this the first time and I like to be consistent.
This does not speak, I acknowledge the challenges that charter schools have identifying facilities in mature cities, in particular in the area
in Northern California because everything's so expensive here as well as in LA, as well as California as a whole.
So I wanted to qualify why I'm abstaining from this vote simply because I want to be consistent with my vote with the original charter.
Okay, I think we're ready then for a vote on this.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, so we have one abstention.
One no.
Nose.
Two nos.
No.
Two abstentions.
Call the roll.
Yeah.
All right.
We'll call the roll.
Bruce Holliday.
Yes.
Hema.
Okay.
Nikki.
Yes.
Okay.
Trish.
Yes.
Ting.
Mike.
Yes.
Eileen.
Sue.
Yes.
Feliza.
Okay.
Karen and Patricia.
We have two no's and two abstentions.
Okay.
The motion carries.
So now we're ready for the Promise Academy.
Okay, item number 16 is for Promise Academy and this is a request for a material revision.
Promise Academy was approved by the State Board of Education on January 19, 2018 for grades TK through eight for a five-year term, July 2018 through June 2023.
There were three conditions as part of this approval.
Two conditions have been met and the one condition regarding the facility lease agreement has not been met.
By June 15, 2018, the Promise Academy Board will provide CDE with a fully executed facility lease agreement.
School must open by September 30th, 2018 to retain SBE authorization or be approved for a material revision.
So on May 29th, 2018, we received a request for a material revision to delay the opening by one year due to the inability to secure a facility.
CDE is recommending that the State Board hold a public hearing to approve the request for Promise Academy for the material revision under the oversight of the State Board.
It will change the opening from 18-19 this school year to next school year 19-20 for a five-year term and again not extending that five-year term.
The recommendation is based on the sound educational program that the petitioner is demonstratively likely to successfully implement the program and a reasonably comprehensive description of most of the charter elements.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools met on August 14, 2018 and the commission moved staff's recommendation to approve the request for a material revision and the motion passed unanimously.
As part of our review, we took a look at whether the petitioners met the condition.
So the conditions by June 15, 2018, they were to provide a revised budget with a positive three-year ending fund balance.
And this condition has been met.
By June 15, 2018, provide a revised charter petition containing the necessary changes needed to reflect the state board as the authorizer.
This condition has also been met.
And then by June 15th as well, they were to provide the CDE with a fully executed lease agreement and this condition has not been met.
We did a full review of the educational program.
The petition does provide a reasonably comprehensive description of most of the charter elements and that is included in attachment one of the item.
And if approved by the state board, there are some areas in the charter petition that will need to be clarified.
Those include a description of the educational program, measurable pupil outcomes, governance structure and again suspension and expulsion procedures.
In terms of the ability to implement, we did do a review of the multi-year financial plan based on 18-19 being a planning year and opening 19-20.
Initially, the multi-year financial plan is not fiscally viable without the silicon funds.
We have received commitment letters that have stated that those funds are definitely coming forward for the school.
So with the inclusion of those funds and the confirmation we received in the commitment letters, the school does have positive ending fund balances and adequate reserves for the 19-20 through 21-22 fiscal years provided those funds are secured.
In summary, CDE staff is recommending approval of the material revision based on a sound educational program, fiscal viability provided the funds are secured, and clarification of the charter elements in the petition.
And I'm available here for any questions that you may have.
Okay, do we have any technical questions on this?
If not, then I declare the public hearing open and we'll first take the petitioners for the charter school.
There you go.
Morning.
I think it's morning.
Good morning, members of the board, city staff, guests, and on behalf of the families of Promise Academy, my name is Dr. Anthony Johnson.
I'm the school founder.
I'd like to talk about a few things today that kind of chronicle our journey to this point.
A little bit about Promise Academy, as a reminder, milestones we've met,
our timeline to get to this point, the CDE recommendation, and then our next steps for our August 2019 opening, provided that we approve today.
So Promise Academy is a small K-8 school founded by a group of parents who live and work in and near downtown San Jose.
We present a unique option for all families but especially low-income families and families of color who traditionally wouldn't have a school option of this nature.
Our option focuses on personalized education.
We use methods of small group instruction and hands-on applied math, science, and engineering in partnership with the Tech Museum of Innovation.
So I just want to highlight a couple of the milestones that are relevant to today's hearing.
We were awarded two additional large grants that are going to help us to continue to engage families and refine our instructional model over our extended planning year.
Parent engagement has been tremendous.
We have received about 180 applications.
We have a consistent core group of about 40 to 50 parents who we meet with frequently to keep our momentum going.
So this is really important.
This is our timeline.
So in November, just as the charter school before us, we submitted our Prop 39 application for facilities.
We submitted more than 300 meaningful interest forms that were verified on the San Jose Unified website.
We punched in the addresses.
They were of age.
And so all of these we felt qualified.
About two days after we were approved here in January, we received a notice that we would be denied facilities under Prop 39.
We pushed forward.
We reached out to the district to engage in talks.
We did meet in February with the district.
There were no formal offers made.
There were some requirements around an in-lieu-of lease agreement.
One of those was that they would have to kind of canvas the local school communities to decide whether or not the school wanted us to be at that site and also whereas the
Typical rate for a school our size would have been $120,000 to lease our pro rata share of space.
It was the lease agreement that they verbally talked about was over $500,000 annually for the same amount of space.
Also, we attended board meetings.
We reached out to board members, requested a meeting, and ultimately we had to take legal action in early March to attempt to have a judge to objectively look at the policy interpreted for us.
In the meantime, we were looking at private facilities.
We had a beat on a perfect private facility in our area.
However, when we met with the city and we sat down and we mapped out the timeline, it was clear that the timing of things wouldn't work out.
We should have received a facility offer on February 1st, which I truly believe if we had have, no matter where the location of the facility would have been, we would have been able to make it work.
But the process drug out.
Even after our lawsuit, there were multiple motions filed by the local school district.
And all were eventually struck down.
And then in June, the judge issued a mandate that we be offered space in the amount that we originally requested.
He also ruled that the efforts to delay us and to prevent us from opening were subjective, arbitrary, and capricious.
On July 23rd, we received a final facilities offer.
And although we requested any six of the downtown school sites, all of which have between 200 and 400 empty seats, we replaced that.
And to put it in context, there are over 40 school sites within the local school district.
We were put at the one school site that was furthest away from our families, the same site that was offered to the previous charter school, which was Allen at Steinbeck, which constitutes approximately a two-hour round-trip commute for families in San Jose traffic, both for drop-off and pickup.
So, first of all, I just want to thank the CDU staff for the recommendation to approve and also the ACCS Commission.
We've been working closely with CDU staff.
We have our monthly check-ins, and they've been extremely helpful.
And we look forward to continuing to work with them.
Our next steps are we've put together a facilities team.
We've actually been working with a broker for the past 10 months.
We are now entertaining three private facilities that we look to make an offer on here within the next few weeks.
Our team consists of myself, two of our board members, one of which is a commercial real estate agent, and our two brokers.
We also recognize that Prop 39 is our legal right, and we're hoping that the law is followed in this upcoming year.
We will submit our
our request by November 1st with the adequate number of signatures again.
And seeing that we receive our offer on February 1st, we are planning to offer transportation anticipating that it may be at the same school site that was previously offered.
As far as families are concerned, right now, we started about two weeks ago offering free tutoring to all of our families who have applied with us and registered with us.
It doubles as piloting our instructional model and we're able to really work out kinks and report out to families on what kids are learning and stay engaged with our families.
We had our registration kickoff this past August 26, so about a weekend ago, and it was well attended.
We also continue to have semi-monthly parent leader meetings.
We've been doing that for the past two years, and those efforts have continued.
We had a number of applicants to apply to our school, and so we're staying in relationship with those current applicants.
We're holding, starting next week, monthly socials for educators where we're kind of vetting and talking through our school model and hopefully bringing on some rock star teachers here.
Our internal goal is to be fully staffed by December of this year, and our immediate goal is to hire two lead teachers so that we can begin training the trainer model.
So as we bring on staff, we'll be ready to go here in the spring.
Lastly, here are some pictures on the left side of our last parent meeting a couple of weeks ago.
You can see that our kids are present and we're also working through small intricate details of the school, like our school motto, our school chant, our uniform policy.
So we want our parents to be intricately involved in every part of the school.
We do span multiple grade levels and so we're not starting from scratch with our enrollment.
We have a core group of families who are still engaged and who are still eligible for our school.
In fact, in the middle, you'll see the flyer that we use to promote our kickoff event.
And that baby that you see right now, there now, is about two and a half years old walking around.
So that's how long we've been in this journey.
And on the right side, you'll see pictures from the event.
And on the bottom of that, you'll see some of our kiddos working in our app school tutorial program, where they're in our innovation lab, and they're doing science and engineering projects.
So in closing, we continue to have great momentum.
We're physically stable and viable.
And while the delay was definitely not the plan, it may prove to have positive effects on helping us to engage even more families and start our school with an even stronger academic program.
Thank you.
Good morning, Steve McMahon, Deputy Superintendent for the Santa Fe School District.
Really appreciate the questions from the earlier agenda item and hopefully we can get a little bit more in depth on this one as well.
Very different process between perseverance and promise.
Much more disputes regarding the signatures and the verification.
I am a bureaucrat.
I don't think there's anything negative in that term.
I'm a steward of other people's money.
It is my job to make sure we use it the most efficiently and to the best uses possible.
They're taxpayer investments, public school facilities.
They're the anchors of many neighborhoods, and we take this work incredibly seriously.
As a bureaucrat, I live in the land of laws, regulations, court orders.
I don't make PowerPoints without documentation to support it.
So in your packet, you'll see evidence of an overview of this process.
It is a very challenging one.
There are some ambiguities in what we think is the Prop 39 process and verifying residency and age and all those pieces.
Specific to Promise, we did have a dispute regarding the meaningful interest.
Promise sought judicial relief, and they were granted that judicial relief.
The district made a facility offer exactly as Promise requested, 20,000 square feet for 197 in-district students at a K-8 facility because you approved a K-8 charter school.
The district only has two K-8 schools in the entire 41 school inventory.
There are only two TK-8 schools in our inventory.
We offered the one that had available classrooms.
in complete compliance with the judge's order.
Again, we're not here before you today disputing or recommending or supporting your material vision.
We just want to make sure the record accurately reflects they had a facility exactly as requested.
Needing a material revision because the district didn't give them the facility is not accurate.
Under the court order, they were offered exactly what they requested to the letter.
It is expensive.
It's not in the location they preferred.
But I would welcome you to visit San Jose with me and visit all the families that in 2000 and 2002 had neighborhood schools closed.
None of the 30,000 families have the school exactly where they want.
You often have to adjudicate boundary disputes with districts.
Part of the democracy is it's tough to know where to draw the boundary, where to locate the neighborhood school.
If San Jose Unified has the facilities available and we offer them, we've done the best we can.
We were not going to go into a downtown school and reconfigure a K-5 elementary to be a K-8 school.
nor we were going to disrupt the learning environments of existing schools when we had available space somewhere else.
So we're happy to answer any questions.
Superintendent is here.
She wants to add some comments regarding the verification process.
We really do think it's important that there's a better understanding of what happened through this process.
But for my part, as a bureaucrat, we got a court order.
We followed it.
The material revision is unnecessary because the facilities exactly as requested were delivered.
Good morning.
I'm Nancy Albrot.
I'm the superintendent of San Jose Unified.
Thank you for the opportunity to address this particular issue.
So I am here today because it's really important for me that we have on the public record our concern about this particular school when it comes to the students attending this school.
So I don't dispute that there was legal action and that we were required to provide facilities.
In that process, we determined that we needed to go out and talk to the families to confirm some of the statements that have been made by Promise about how the district has harassed parents or intimidated parents.
And I want to give you some context around that.
I am a Latina leader.
I have led in this community.
I've taught in this community.
I've been a principal in the downtown area.
I've been a bilingual director.
And I grew up in a home of immigrants.
My parents are both immigrants.
So I believe that I have the cultural competency and the respect and professionalism to dialogue with parents face to face.
So I, with my bilingual assistant, went to the homes of the families that Promise Academy alleges we harassed on the telephone and intimidated.
I took the enrollment forms that they gave us.
I showed them the enrollment forms.
Story after story, parents told me that they were approached in a parking lot.
outside of Safeway in a church.
A table was set up at a neighboring charter school, and they were being told that they needed to sign these forms, that it was a form of support.
Those are all declarations and depositions that are in the court papers.
So you can see those.
I think about that as a leader of this district.
I would be appalled if any of my principals
sold a program to families in a parking lot, at a table, or outside a church.
I would expect what I expect for all my community, my very diverse community, from my most privileged families to my families that are living in the most distress.
Every family deserves an overall comprehensive program description, a place to come together to review and answer questions.
I believe that parents need to be, you know, asking questions and engaged.
I don't think that these parents particularly, they did not believe that they had a comprehensive overview.
They thought they were signing forms in support of a school opening.
So I confirm that.
I understand what the court, what the judge says, but I know and my board knows and the community knows that the school is an opening because there's not interest.
There are some families that want this school, but there is not the 80 that are required.
And so I will gladly, as a superintendent, go into a school and have a dialogue with a community about interest and needing to co-locate when there are the 80 required.
I don't believe that disrupting some of my communities that are already in distress because there's a handful of people that would like the school in their neighborhood.
I don't believe that that's the fair way of doing this.
And so I just want you to be aware of that and really hold some of these schools that are being authorized accountable for treating and engaging with parents in a respectful and professional manner.
The same standard that we have for our regular public schools.
Because I don't believe that the way these engagement conversations happened are reflecting that.
So with that, if you have any questions, I'd be happy to answer any of them.
Okay, thank you.
I declare the public hearing closed in that phase and now we're ready for public comment.
With the following speakers, please come to the podium.
Eric Premack, Ramel Antoine, Justin Choi, Tanita Plattementier, Julie Chae Kim, Maria Guadalupe, and Dean Elias.
May I begin?
Hello, my name is Justin Choi.
I am a student volunteer and a firm believer in the importance of our public education system.
In the San Jose Unified School District, approximately only 36% of our low income Latino students met requirements to apply for our state universities.
36%.
Our schools should be doing a better job.
Waiting for schools to improve on a district level could take decades.
Promise Academy is one of the best options we have in order to address the needs of the students of low-income families in San Jose.
The school model involves deep engagement of student learning through small group practice, which is exactly what many of our students need to break the cycle of educational inequity and poverty.
I'm here because I believe in Promise's mission.
Please approve their delay.
Eric Premack, Charter School Center.
We think highly of this group as well and would urge you to approve the extension.
We do, though, as I noted earlier, think that these are unnecessary and you've heard my song and dance on that.
Thank you.
Good morning, board members.
My name is Tanita Palaman.
I have a current sixth grader and a kindergartner.
I am deeply disappointed that we have to meet this way again.
I live in San Jose.
I commute to Concord for work.
I am well aware of traffic in the Bay Area.
In order for me to drop my child off at Allen, I would have to drive south, sit in traffic and drop them off, then sit in traffic on my way to work.
This is the same for most of our families.
It would take other families and myself at least an extra hour round trip to drop them off at Allen.
If San Jose Unified School District had given us a fair location in downtown San Jose, it would be on my way to work making the commute a lot easier.
It's ridiculous that what San Jose Unified School District has put us through to delay Promise Academy.
My son and daughter started school last month.
Because of this delay, my daughter and other current sixth graders will not be able to attend Promise Academy.
I feel hurt, upset, and very emotional.
I had dreamed of my kids being able to attend the same school.
I am still hopeful my son and his peers will be able to attend Promise Academy.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Julie Chacom and I'm a parent to a kindergarten at Rocketship.
I've been working to bring Promise Academy to downtown San Jose since 2016.
You're with Rocketship?
I'm sorry.
because there are no good schools in downtown San Jose.
So I've been involved for about two years and
So I've gone through both the verification of the phone call with the superintendent, Nancy Alvaron, and as well as I've also toured the high school or the school, Allen and Stanbeck.
So I just wanted to clarify on the phone verification for our parents, for the families who lives in downtown.
I think that some of the conversation that confused our family because the questions were asked if the family going to Promise Academy and then when the family asked where is Promise Academy because at the moment we didn't have a location and the staff said I don't know.
Time.
And so, and also with the school, Allen Stanback, it's very far too far for us.
And that is not possible and that's not really, really solving the problem of the people in our downtown areas who have, does not have good schools.
So please approve the delay for Promise Academy for our children.
Thank you.
Good morning, board.
Romel Antoine again with the Charter Schools Association speaking in support of the material revision.
It is clear through their presentation that they have thought through all the scenarios.
They will have more time this time around.
They have assembled a facilities team to look at several private facilities.
They've gone through the legal process for Prop 39.
They've made their case.
If you look through the documents that they submitted, they actually provided a bunch of different options to the school district.
trying to work with them to be collaborative, to say, here's where our families are.
Let's work together to make this a reality.
And the district chose not to do that.
In fact, to offer them something that was much more expensive than any school should have to pay, private or public charter or public.
So there's that.
And then it's, you know, normally what we see when schools get approved by anybody and they take some time, they usually are taking their time away from the community.
Promise is actually dialing down and doubling down in the community, providing tutoring services and keeping engaged with those families, keeping them involved in Promise Academy.
We urge you to approve.
Thank you.
Ona Keller, California Teachers Association.
I just refer back again to the letter that I passed out earlier about both Perseverance and Promise.
This board recognized that Promise's petition, especially in its high school, was actually illegal, which is why you took the high school portion off.
We're back here again asking for more changes to their petition.
San Jose Real Estate is getting, if anything, more expensive.
Google is about to come into downtown and open up a number of office buildings.
And so it's unclear to me how giving this school another year will allow them to actually have facilities that will work for them.
The district offered them Prop 39 facilities.
they met their requirements and it's unclear why you should be able to give them another year when they did have facilities available.
That's what this material revision is about.
They weren't able to meet it because they didn't want to.
Thank you.
Hola, mi nombre es Maria Guadalupe Garcia.
Para mi la escuela de Promise Academy
Es diferente en la comunidad de San Jose porque vamos a crear una nueva familia unida.
Tengo a dos hijos de edades separadas que requieren apoyo diferente.
Un modelo pequeo es necesario.
Promise nos saca de la batalla que
Enfrentamos en la educacin comunitaria.
Estamos ansiosos para que nuestra escuela, por fin ahora, el prximo ao, se abra.
Por favor, aydenos con esto.
Gracias.
Hello, my name is Maria Guadalupe Garcia.
For me, Promise Academy is different in the community of San Jose because it is creating a unified family.
I have two children in separate age groups that require different support.
A smaller model is necessary.
Promise gets us out of the battle that we face in the educational community.
We are anxious to finally open our school next year.
Please help us with this.
Thank you.
Good morning.
I'm Dean Elias.
I'm the chair of the board for Promise Academy.
I just want to affirm, as I've done in the past, that this is an extraordinarily brilliant proposal for a school.
And among the things that has made it brilliant is the way that parents have been actively involved at each step of the way.
And the way the dealing with parents was referenced by the district, I think, is disrespectful for the reality that the parents have experienced.
Among the things that I think is extraordinary is the quality of the school leadership and the quality of the parent participation, all of which augurs well with the success of Promise Academy.
Thank you.
I hope you'll choose to approve the request.
Okay, that concludes the public comments.
So now we're ready for board member discussion.
Board member Holliday will make first comments.
Thanks.
I'm sure a number of board members have a number of questions.
I'm not going to try to go through all of the details now.
I'll let you all filter those out.
Unfortunately, this relationship between this charter school and the same district has not been quite as smooth.
And there have been some definitely
Bitter moments.
I do sincerely appreciate once again that the district and the superintendent have deputy superintendent and superintendent of the district have shown up to clarify from their perspective what happened and to make sure that their voice is clearly heard and I suspect that
Once again, their approach to the situation has been for the best intent of children, and that is great.
And that's what we're all here for, and that's what we're all spending our time doing.
this Prop 39 situation is that it is incredibly difficult for both a charter school in a Prop 39 situation as well as a district in a Prop 39 situation.
It's terribly difficult to suddenly think about, first of all, back up
100 years when I was running a charter school in Oakland, and we were being kicked out of a facility, and we were considering Prop 39 through the Oakland district.
The idea of co-locating with another school is tremendously difficult to begin with.
But then suddenly, the offer is 10 miles away, 5 miles away, or even 1 mile away from where
the families who began the process, who were part of the process, are located.
That's terribly difficult.
At the same time,
I can't imagine how painful it would be for a district to have a full school in the desired location for the charter school and say, well, we're going to have to move some of our students out so these charter kids can come in here.
That's terrible.
No, no.
It's a really tough situation.
I don't fault the district in this situation at all.
And I don't fault the charter school in this situation.
And that's the reality of Prop 39 situations.
That being said, once again, I do believe that not only did this board vote to approve this charter in January, whenever it was, the ACCS voted unanimously to provide this extension of time.
And the department agrees to give them this extension of time.
I know it's been a difficult and rocky time between the district and this charter school.
And I'm hoping that they will come together, find common ground again.
And once again, I do believe with this extension of time that the charter school has more options now for facilities.
It may not work out.
That could, you know, if it doesn't, then we need to rethink perhaps.
But there's more options now.
There's more time now.
And I think we ought to give them that opportunity based upon our vote, ACCS vote, and the CDE's recommendation.
Thank you.
Board Member Williams.
If I haven't told you this recently, Member Holliday, this is one of the reasons I so respect and am grateful to have you as a partner in this tough charter school stuff.
The fact that you've run a charter school, a couple of charter schools before, and you know from experience what it's like, what all the relationships are like.
That's not a background or experience that I come from.
And you always have a way of just cutting right down to what's important and doing it in a way that respects everybody that's involved.
I really appreciate that.
I agree with you.
I was a, I read the promise petition
pretty carefully.
I don't read every petition.
That's why we have staff.
But with Promise, I was very, very intrigued with the petition, with what they plan to do, how they plan to do it, the intensity of their focus on low-income kids of color, and the research-based way that they went about putting together their instructional model.
the compelling personal story of the school director operator.
And that's one of the reasons I voted to approve it in the first place.
And I frankly would have approved the high school part of it.
I think having all of the students on individual education plans takes care of most concerns about, you know, what they would be doing and how they would be advancing.
But
agree with you that we agreed, we approve them.
The ACCS has recommend giving them an extension for the reasons that you cite.
The CDE is recommending it as well and I second your motion to move the CDE's recommendation.
I know there's more comment, but as I understand, we're not here to again reconsider the whole charter.
So, I mean, we spent two and a half hours on that.
And, you know, this is a different kind of request.
So I would like us to speak to the particular issue, which is the facility issue.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
I'm going to speak to that.
So I also have been on both sides working within a district, reading charter proposals, working with charters.
So I understand how difficult this is.
And I do agree.
I think both of you are right.
You know, on one end, there is a lot of hustle with getting those signatures needed.
And you are approaching parents in parking lots, in churches.
But I do commend the Promise Academy for engaging, authentically engaging parents now during this gap year.
So my question has to do, maybe Lisa you can answer this, because this is about facilities and it says that the CDE notes that the PA petition did not include a plan for acquiring and securing facilities during the 2018-2019 planning year.
So if this is about facilities and there is no plan,
Do you know what the plan is?
Lisa, if you want to come forward and maybe answer this question because we're here specifically to entertain the facilities plan, but that's what's missing from this petition.
Right.
We didn't have an actual plan of how they were going to move forward.
We knew that they were from what they had told us about the litigation and how they were moving forward with San Jose, that they were going to try again for Prop 39.
But there wasn't anything formally submitted to us for that.
So this would allow give them obviously some more time to then determine how they would move forward before the November 1st deadline.
But we didn't actually have anything concrete written out, I would say.
So what happens now if they are given the extension, if we approve it, then how do you work with them?
How do you monitor that they're actually keeping to a timeline, that there's a facility, that there's going to be an opening?
Because I agree with Member Sun, if it doesn't open next year, I think it would be really hard for them to actually open.
We will, we can, we check in with them monthly and we had, since they opened in January, we do these monthly calls so that we just, just to check in to see if they're on task, if there's anything, guidance they may need from us.
We'll continue to do that.
We would, from this point forward, continue to check in with them monthly, find out what status they may, where, if they've made any progress on checking in with the district.
Are they going the private, private facility route?
So we check in with them monthly to see where they are.
And then we will continue to provide any guidance that we see fit at that point.
And that would include fiscal as well.
We'll continue to check in with them on a monthly basis.
So, as we see whether they're progressing or not, they'll have until September 30th to open.
If we start to see that there are concerns again about the facility, we will engage with them again and work with state board staff on, you know, how best we can help them.
So.
Board member comments?
Board member Burr.
I don't know if this is for you Lisa or for Deputy Superintendent McMahon, but I was intrigued in the earlier conversation on our other item about the possibility of transportation being provided by the district, but I didn't hear that conversation in this item.
Was that part of the conversation?
And I guess as you're coming up, could it be part of the conversation going forward?
So again, we're representatives of the public education system.
Any service the district offers is available to anyone using the facilities.
We never had the conversation because immediately it was we need a facility downtown.
And we kept trying to say we have available facilities.
Let's look at the possibility of making it work there.
In all honesty, there just was not authentic dialogue.
It was downtown or nothing.
And we kept saying, I would agree that the laws are not written.
either clearly or in a way that's efficient.
We don't feel as a school district we can move facilities when we have them available.
I mean, imagine the taxpayers having ten times the number of schools necessary.
That's just not what they're investing in.
Eighty percent of the people who pay taxes in our boundaries do not have kids in the school.
They do not want to pay taxes for idle facilities.
So we felt like if the request is for 20,000 square feet, TK to 8, and we have that ready to go, that was the offer.
Transportation to that facility is available.
It's a reverse commute.
You could talk to many.
We're a 19-mile long school district that's very narrow.
We have families go from downtown to Castellero Middle School because they want to participate in the Visual Performing Arts program.
We provide transportation.
Many of the families do it themselves.
Anything the school district does is an option.
don't want to mislead anybody.
It's all costly.
I mean, serving meals is costly in San Jose.
Everything you do in San Jose is expensive, but it's all available and running the business side of it, if we had a charter school contract for four more bus routes, as good for San Jose Unified, hopefully we can find the bus drivers, but we are open to any service the district provides with anyone using the facilities.
So I would just hope that in the upcoming conversations that that issue is addressed in a collaborative way on both sides of the conversation.
Okay.
Yeah.
We have a motion.
No, I'm sorry.
I did not make a motion.
Go ahead.
Yeah, because I thought there would be plenty of conversation.
So anyway, I would move the CD recommendation.
Okay.
Clerk will call the roll.
Patricia.
No.
Karen.
Feliza.
Yes.
Sue.
Eileen.
Yes.
Mike.
Ting.
Yes.
Trish.
Hema?
Okay, and Bruce?
Okay, the motion carries.
We need to break for about five minutes or so.
We'll have a longer break for the lunch to set up a PowerPoint.
So we'll come back at 20 of 12.
Okay, the board will reconvene.
I haven't signed it yet.
We're now ready for item 17, the rocket ship, San Pablo Elementary.
And Lisa Constanzo is here to present for the department.
Item number 17 is the rocket ship.
Hello?
Yeah, go ahead.
Better?
Okay.
I just wasn't close enough.
All right.
The timeline.
November 15, 2017, the West Contra Costa Unified School District voted to deny the petition by a vote of 3 to 2.
On May 25, 2018, Contra Costa County Office of Education voted to deny the petition by a vote of 3 to 2.
And the petitioner submitted a petition on appeal to the state board on May 29, 2018.
The CDE recommendation is that the State Board hold a public hearing to deny the request to establish Rocketship San Pablo, a TK to grade five charter school under the oversight of the State Board.
The recommendation is based on the following findings, demonstratively unlikely to successfully implement the program, we are concerned about an over-reliance on startup loans, and past history of State Board authorized school and currently authorized Rocketship Futuro Academy.
I added this slide just because I know we've been talking a lot about what is required in the Education Code with each of the petitions that is before you.
So with an establishment of a charter school, Education Code 47605B states that we shall not deny a petition for establishment of a charter school unless we make written findings setting forth facts to support one of the following conditions.
So number one is the charter school presents an unsound educational program for pupils to be enrolled in the charter school.
Number two is the petitioners are demonstratively unlikely to successfully implement the program set forth in the petition.
Number three is that the petition does not contain the number of signatures required by subdivision A. The petition does not contain an affirmation of each of the petitions described in subdivision D. And number five is that the petition does not contain reasonably comprehensive descriptions of all of the charter elements.
And those are the ones you will find in our attachment 1A with each of the items.
that we go through at the ACCS meeting, but we've also included as an attachment to the board items now so that you have it readily accessible to you if you'd like to refer to it.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools met on August 14, 2018, and the Advisory Commission moved to approve the petition.
The motion passed by a vote of 7 to 2.
A little bit of background, Rocketship San Pablo Elementary is proposing to open for the 19-20 school year to enroll 386 pupils in grades TK to 5, and they plan to grow to 600 pupils by 2023-24.
They plan to locate in close proximity to community colleges and public transportation central to serve the families of the Iron Triangle in San Pablo and Central Richmond.
Rocketship's mission is to eliminate the achievement gap by graduating all students at or above grade level.
Their model is built on three foundational pillars, teachers and leadership, Rocketeer students, and parents.
And the petitioners here, I'm sure they'll speak more to their model.
The CD findings, so we have made a finding in terms of the ability to implement.
The initial review multi-year financial plan was not fiscally viable.
Negative fund balances and there are no reserves for the first three fiscal years.
This was due to the revenues including startup loans, the intercompany loans and a charter school revolving loan.
The total of those two, about a million dollars, which is one of our main concerns, is about how much startup loans are needed for the school to actually open.
Continuing with our findings, right before the ACCS meeting actually, we received a revised budget.
The school will be fiscally viable if it includes a grant that has been received by the federal government and also only with the inclusion of these startup loans.
CDE still remains concerned about the heavy reliance on startup loans to open the school.
Past history, so there has been two Rocketship schools, one currently authorized by the state board and one previously that we wanted to just bring to the board's attention.
Rocketship San Francisco was approved by the board in January 11, 2012 to open the 13-14 school year.
On June 3rd, they requested a material revision to delay opening until 2015.
And in 2013, they wrote to CDE to withdraw the request for material revision, saying they would not be able to open.
We confirmed that they understood that this decision would result in the termination of their authorization and their charter petition at that time.
So that school did not open.
Now this is the current school that is currently under state board authorization, Rocketship Futuro Academy.
They were approved by the state board on March 10th, 2016 for a five-year term from July 1st, 2016 through June 30th, 2021.
There was a material revision that was approved by the board during that first year of operation to reduce enrollment.
And since their opening, we have had, CDE has sent six letters of concern to the school during the 17-18 school year.
Those letters of concern have been regarding, two of them were regarding fiscal issues.
One was sent in October of 2017 and another in June of this year.
Concerns about English language development instruction and teacher credentialing, two letters in November and February.
There was an additional letter regarding EL instruction and English learner advisory committee.
And then an additional letter regarding teacher credentialing.
So this is a summary of the six letters that we issued during the 17-18 school year.
And I can go into more detail in those if board members have questions of those later on.
The most recent letter of concern was June 13, 2018, and we highlighted the negative ending fund balances and declining enrollment at that time.
And the school's response was that they would be using intercompany loans and the deferral of management fees to balance the budget and to help with the issues of cash flow.
But there was no timeline specified on when these loans would need to be paid back and the deferral management fees in that response.
In the August 2018 fiscal memorandum to the state board, this is our annual report that we let you know how the state board schools are doing fiscally.
Rocketship Futura was in a poor financial condition, again for the same reasons, the negative ending fund balance and the no reserves.
And it was based on the second interim report that we reviewed on behalf of the board at that time.
We have been in communications with with Rocketship actually since right before the ACCS meeting and again yesterday To talk about these the letters of concern and and they have provided some clarification to us about these letters of concern they have they've also stated they do not expect a positive fund balance for futuro until the 1920 school year and
And we have also talked about their approach to a modified or cruel approach moving forward when we look at their finances.
In essence, this would mean taking out the intercompany loans and some of the management fees out of basically the budget and what would be so that it basically brings the negative fund balances down lower to a lower amount because we don't see the payment back of those loans and those management fees have been deferred out into the future.
So a combination of lower than expected enrollment and again the heavy reliance on the startup loans is still an overall concern of CDEs.
Also, if the school is approved by the State Board, we do have some concerns about the petition that we'll be working with the petitioner on to clarify.
One of those is a plan for English learners.
We have some concerns about the measurable pupil outcomes and a description of those outcomes, employee qualifications, health and safety procedures, and again, expulsion and suspension procedures.
I know I keep saying those like a broken record, but those will need to be updated as well.
In summary, CDE is recommending denial in terms of we have some concerns about the fiscal concerns, about the startup loans, past history of the state board authorized school and the currently authorized Futuro Academy, and we will also need clarification of the charter elements in the petition.
That's the end of my presentation, but I am here and available for any questions that you may have.
Okay, technical questions.
Hearing none, then I think we're ready for the public hearing.
So we'll open the public hearing.
Each side will have 10 minutes and we'll take first the petitioners for the charter.
Okay.
Like me, yeah.
Is this as far as it opens?
Or does it open?
It should open more, right?
This is a PDF.
Do we have the slides?
Because that's just a PDF.
Okay.
Yeah, it does.
Is that enough?
Okay, all right.
Good afternoon President Kirst, Vice President Strauss and distinguished members of the board.
I am Marisa Gill, Bay Area Regional Director for Rocketship Public Schools and I'm proud to be here with our educators and families representing San Pablo and asking for your support to bring a high public elementary charter school to the community in West Contra Costa Unified School District.
Contra Costa County is home to some of the best public schools in our state, but there are still communities across the East Bay that don't get the same opportunity to attend a great public school.
This is what the achievement gap looks like in the East Bay.
We see exemplars of excellence across the region, separated by pockets of crotically underperforming schools in historically low-income communities.
The City of San Pablo is one of those communities.
There are five public elementary schools serving San Pablo, and not one of them exceeded the state average for proficiency in math or ELA on the 2016-2017 state standards.
On average, only one in five students in San Pablo elementary schools are on grade level.
Over 2,000 students are enrolled in these schools.
These students and families deserve the opportunity to attend a high quality public school.
And that is why over 500 families signed the petition to open a rocket ship public school in San Pablo.
Rocketship Public Schools is a nonprofit network of public elementary charter schools.
Since our founding 12 years ago, we've opened 13 schools across the Bay Area serving over 14,000 students.
The vast majority of the students we serve come from disadvantaged communities that lack access to high quality schools.
As we've consistently demonstrated, Rocketship schools provide disadvantaged communities with a high-quality education that continues to grow stronger year after year.
Our network has improved performance every year since the Common Core state standards were first introduced.
Our students, classified as disadvantaged, have consistently outperformed all California students in math and are quickly closing the gap on ELA.
This is what it looks like to narrow and eventually eliminate the achievement gap.
We still have much more work to do to ensure that every Rocketeer is college and career ready, but we are proud of the extraordinary progress that our Rocketeers are making.
I would now like to turn to Josh Drake, our Senior Director of Achievement, to share a bit about our model that underlines our student academic progress.
Thank you.
At Rocketship, we believe transformational schools are built on three pillars.
One, personalized learning that tailors instruction, content, and pace to the individual needs of each student.
Two, investing in and developing the talent of all team members to unleash their full potential.
And three, harnessing the extraordinary power of our parents who are champions of their child's education and leaders in our schools and our communities.
Unlike many elementary schools, students at Rocketship rotate between four content blocks every day, humanities, STEM, enrichment, and the learning lab.
This model allows us to improve student outcomes by supporting our teachers to develop deep content expertise in either STEM or humanities.
Our teachers lead the learning process for every student we serve in both whole group grade level instruction as well as differentiated instruction to meet students' individual needs.
Independent learning, small group tutoring, and adaptive online learning programs augment teacher-led instruction and support students to take ownership of their learning.
This carefully orchestrated combination of instructional methods is made possible by robust and regular data streams so that we can map precisely what our students' support needs are.
This is how we ensure we are maximizing our teacher talent and their instructional time.
We are proud to serve all students in our classrooms, including a full continuum of students with special needs.
Our approach to this is through meaningful inclusion.
Students with disabilities spend a majority of their school day in our general education classrooms.
And our special education teachers prioritize being in those classrooms to co-teach with their general education peers.
As a result, we see strong academic growth for our students with disabilities.
Over 50% of our Bay Area students are classified as English learners.
English learners are vibrant members of our school community, and we prioritize and celebrate their culture and language as strengths to build upon.
As a result, as a network, English language learners at Rocketship have outperformed their peers in California for every year since Rocketship's been founded.
And this most recent spring, we saw continued improvement for English language learners, where they increased by seven points in ELA and math proficiency.
As we know, many of our students have experienced some form of trauma, witnessing violence in their communities, the loss of a parent, or racially charged threats.
That's why our schools feature robust systems of support for social-emotional learning as well as positive school-wide culture to support our students and help make sure they stay in our classrooms.
To that end, in the 11 years Rocketship has been teaching students, we have never expelled a single student.
And in our 17-18 school year, our suspension rate was 1.4% for all students, lower than both our neighboring districts as well as the state.
With that, I would love to turn it to our chief program officer, Lin Liao, to talk more about the achievement results for our students.
Hello.
Our mission is to eliminate the achievement gap in the communities we serve.
And that's why we pay particular attention to the performance of students classified as socioeconomically disadvantaged.
We are very proud that our Rocketeers significantly outperform their peers in math across every local school district where we operate.
The same is true for ELA, where, as we noted earlier, our students have made remarkable gains since Common Core State Standards were first introduced.
We increased the percent of our students who are proficient in ELA by 14 percentage points over the last four years.
What's even more encouraging, the gains our racketeers make in elementary school extended to middle school.
SRI International, an independent nonprofit research center, conducted a three-year study on the performance of our graduates in middle school.
The study followed nearly 2,000 students and showed that Rocketship graduates are a year ahead of their middle school classmates in both math and reading.
and continue to demonstrate the key character skills associated with long-term success, including self-efficacy, motivation, and grit.
I would now like to introduce Keisha Bailey, Art Chief Financial Officer, to highlight a few aspects of our financial model.
Financial sustainability is a core tenet of the Rocketship model.
On average, our schools break even in three to five years.
Our projections for our San Pablo campus put us on track to break even in year three with healthy cash reserves in every year of operation.
As is typical with large established nonprofit school networks like Rocketship, our national network provides financial support in the startup years as our new school grows enrollment and reaches full sustainability.
This chart looks at the five most recent school openings in our South Bay region where we operate 10 schools.
As you can see, while many of our schools start with a deficit in year one, they all grow to become fully sustainable on public funding and maintain healthy cash reserves.
This demonstrates the strength of our network in both starting and sustaining schools.
At Rocketship Futuro Academy, our state board authorized school in Concord, we ended last fiscal year with a healthy cash reserve and are on track to break even in year four.
Futuro Academy is a Prop 39 campus that was relocated in year two.
Despite the challenges of our location in year one and move in year two, enrollment is continuing to increase significantly year over year.
Due to our Prop 39 placement this year, we limited enrollment to 441 students, but have another 73 on the wait list.
Futuro Academy has grown from a small school housed in a Prop 39 modular buildings on a dirt lot to a vibrant campus serving nearly 450 students.
Our second East Bay school, Rocketship Delta Prep, just opened in its own state-of-the-art facility, the first net zero charter in the nation serving 459 students.
Both schools have already a long wait list.
There is a strong demand for great schools in underserved communities across the East Bay.
The City of San Pablo is one of those communities.
Hundreds of families have already completed intent to enroll forms for the 19-20 school year.
They have seen the results of our schools across the Bay Area and rightly want the same choice for their own children.
Help us build a more just and equitable future for the children of San Pablo by please approving Rocketship San Pablo.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you.
And now we'll have 10 minutes for the opposed to the petition.
Board President Kirst, Vice President Strauss and distinguished members of the board, my name is Valerie Cuevas.
I currently serve in many capacities in education and today I come wearing one specific hat and that is as a public servant elected and serving as the current school board president for West Contra Costa Unified.
I'm here with my colleague, Trustee Madeline Cronenberg as well.
And we come before you to talk about how we are well aware that we want to give opportunities to every student to succeed.
We strive to do that and it breaks our heart that the achievement gap exists.
And so we want partners to come with us who can deliver the promise that they will in fact help us close the achievement gap.
And every petition that comes before us amongst our board
We know and are very well aware of what are the guidelines by which we can make a factual determination.
Can we count on that individual petition to be a true partner with us?
And we don't go beyond that.
The state is very clear on what we should consider.
as your staff recommended that there are very specific reasons with which you can deny a petition and nothing else.
And for us, we have many times as a board approved charters that are able to demonstrate that they can be that partner.
And unfortunately we come in this instance to say the facts demonstrate a pattern to us that this is not a partner that we can count on.
And the reason that we have those findings will be presented by our district staff.
We didn't manufacture this evidence.
It just surfaced on its own.
And in fact you all provided much of it.
So we're going to ask you to please hear what our staff has to say and then we ask and wait to see what you think about your determination on what your facts say on whether this will be a good partner for us.
Thank you for your time and we appreciate your humble consideration.
Good afternoon.
My name is Dr. Linda Delgado and I am here to represent the West Contra Costa Unified staff.
I appreciate this opportunity to address you.
We are here to talk today about the rocket ship petition.
This is briefly the timeline which I think my colleague has amply covered.
Before I go too much further, I would like to say that as the president of our board mentioned, we do have a robust charter school community in our district.
We have 10 district-sponsored schools, four county-sponsored schools, and at this point we're serving approximately 5,500 students in our charter schools.
The reasons for West Contra Costa denial are these two.
And as we go through this overview, I will give you the rationale and the evidence to support these two claims.
Here we go.
I am a Luddite.
These things terrify me.
Of the 12 approved petitions, Rocketship has failed to open 30%, raising concerns about preparation and the speed of their growth.
There is a lengthy multiple step process for special education that was of high concern for our special education staff because we are worried that this would slow service to students that need special ed support.
We were concerned about measurable student outcomes.
Most current Rocketship schools were not able to meet school-wide and subgroup state targets, and nearly all Rocketship schools show significant achievement gaps between their own dominant ethnic subgroups.
This chart shows SBAC scores for nine Rocketship schools in the Bay Area, and it measures student achievement for at or above grade level.
ELA is the column on the left, the chart on the left, and math is on the right.
Orange and blue bars represent the two dominant demographics at Rocketship schools.
Of these, Rocketship schools have large gaps.
For example, Rocketship Mosaic, where the achievement gap is more than double, 33 percent in one ethnic group and 85 in another.
In all but one Rocketship school, there were too few of African-American students to report data.
That was also a high concern for our board.
Now to take a different tact at looking at the data, we wanted to look at who was being served in the rocket ship schools.
So we looked at the various data of the four districts that have rocket ship schools and we honed in on Alum Rock in particular.
There were two reasons for this.
One, they have similar demographics to our district.
And two, they have similar demographics.
What's my second reason?
Oh, a good sample size.
There are four rocket ship schools in that district.
So in these two charts, you begin to see a picture of who is currently attending the rocket ship schools.
On the left, you have socioeconomically disadvantaged.
The gray or blue bars are the rocket ship schools and the orange bars are all of the other schools in Alum Rock that serve elementary students.
As you see for socially disadvantaged, Alum Rock is clustered toward the left or low end of provision.
Special education most decidedly serving fewer students than the typical Alum Rock schools, again, clustered on the left-hand side.
Here we have migrant students, not a concern necessarily in our district, but again trying to get a picture of who are in, who are the students in Rocketship schools.
None of the Rocketship schools have migrant students.
And in English language learners, we totally acknowledge that there is about equal provision in Alum Rock between the traditional public schools and Rocketship.
So our reasons focused on demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement, and I'm continuing that trend here.
Using glasses.
OK.
The district staff were concerned about the cash flow as were our colleagues here at the state level.
We were concerned about possible failure to secure funding from the sources stated in the budget and on whether or not the 15 percent fee due to each rocket ship school from to the central office would actually benefit the students of our area.
The rocket ship staff have been consistently pleasant to work with, but concerns did arise focusing on transparency and bond issues.
When asked for more information on this issue, rocket ship responded that they had no such documents.
Like other charter management organizations, Rocketship is supported by a second organization, Launchpad, that handles their growing real estate portfolios.
Rocketship did not offer guidance or seek to provide the documents that would have answered our concerns and questions on the bond.
Finally, Rocketship's grade spans offer a poor fit with the district, and their anticipated enrollment shows concerning patterns in attrition.
The grade span runs through fifth grade, forcing students to transfer twice, first to a neighborhood elementary school, and finally to a middle school.
Rocketship staff have suggested that students will simply transfer to another charter school, and that's an option I'm going to discuss shortly.
This is the anticipated enrollment that was supplied to us from the Rocketship staff.
If you'll note that first grade in 2019 begins with 56 students over the course of time drops down to 30 students.
This is puzzling and concerning to our district.
It illuminates or suggests some sort of issue, perhaps, within the school.
We won't speculate as to what that might be.
Rocketship has offered explanations of this exodus, including that the parents choose to leave for other charter schools to secure enrollment in a middle school level charter.
Yet a recent inquiry from district staff has found that the charters in our district have wait lists of approximately 200 students for example making waves has 218 students on their wait list.
So this is I think disingenuous to parents to suggest that there will be transfer opportunities when in fact it doesn't appear that there will.
The petition does not contain reasonably comprehensive descriptions of certain required elements set forth.
The TK program did not identify criteria for eligible students or provide adequate descriptions of the program, such as targeted curriculum and resources or the number of instructional minutes.
The EL instruction provided problems in that there appeared to be no protected time in the schedule, although that claim was made within the petition.
The rotational model lacks detail and oversight explained by the assertion that it will be developed once enrollment numbers are known.
The district cannot approve what it has not seen and making changes to the educational program would, of course, require a time revision.
I think I'll jump over those others.
Your time is up.
So yes.
All right.
So I'll leave you with this, which is one of the signature pages for your review that may point some concerns around local enthusiasm for the school.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
OK, that closes that portion of the public hearing.
We're now ready for public comment.
With the following 20 speakers, please line up.
Heather Best, Gabriella Massetti, Angela Hennessy, William McGee, Angle Galarvo, Angelina Galarvo, I'm sorry, Lavaro, Madeline Krumberg, Consuelo Lara, Anthony Caro,
Francisco Ortiz, Ashley Vector-Moros, Stephanie Savarro, Maria Rendez, Deborah Bayer, Patricia Ponce, Guadalupe Calvaro, Eric Premack, Valerie Jamison, and Romel Anton.
Good morning, board.
My name is Heather Best.
I'm the principal of Lupine Hills Elementary in West Contra Costa Unified.
I'm here today simply to speak on our neighborhood public schools so that you are aware of what's happening in West Contra, the changes that have occurred in recent years, and the amazing hard work that our staff members, students, and families are putting in.
We have a fairly new superintendent just a couple years in, a brand new chief academic officer this year.
And through their leadership, under their leadership, we're making changes such as teachers college reading and writing projects, and much more focus on workshop and student choice and voice.
At schools like mine, where nearly 20% of the students have special needs, we've made tremendous changes toward not making anyone feel separate or apart, and really embracing true inclusiveness and true diversity.
Across the communities of San Pablo, we're seeing investment into that same effort, and we're asking you to support those neighborhood community schools today, please.
Hello, my name is Gabrielle Micheletti.
I teach first grade in the San Pablo family of schools.
I am here today because I am concerned that Rocketship serves a far lower percentage of students with disabilities than actually exist in their districts.
About 10% of students in WCCUSD are students with disabilities.
In my personal classroom of 20 first graders, four are already diagnosed with disabilities, and in first grade, many are not yet diagnosed.
Rocketship consistently has fewer than 10% of such students and denies entrance to students with disabilities.
The students with disabilities Rocketship takes get suspended at extreme rates, over 25%.
The students in need of extra support are instead removed from their classrooms and learning communities.
These high suspension rates demonstrate that Rocketship is neither willing nor able to honestly serve the community of students with all their individual needs as they are in San Pablo.
And they must not be allowed to force themselves on the San Pablo community to the detriment of the existing schools there.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Consuelo Lara, and I am a retired teacher from the district.
I have taught there since 1998.
I also have 38 years of teaching experience.
I taught English learners.
I was the department chair, research teacher, coach, trainer, and also coordinate ELAC.
I'm concerned about the EL program, and it's not a comprehensive description.
There's not a comprehensive description of their educational program.
It also does not include the process by which ELs who are reclassified as English proficient will be monitored to a minimum of four years.
And I used to do that monitoring in our district.
We have a rigorous English learner program to the extent that when I would go and monitor those kids who are now in regular English, they would be excelling
at very high level academically.
So this is a great concern of ours that the English learners are not being provided the kind of rigorous academic program that we have in our district.
Thank you.
I've been asked to close this.
You're welcome.
Good morning.
My name is Madeline Cronenberg.
I serve on the West Contra Costa School Board.
I've served for 12 years.
During that time, I've voted on many charter schools.
I voted for them.
I voted against them.
I voted against this one in agreement with all three staffs that have
independently evaluated this petition.
It's been evaluated at our, at the district level, at the county level, and at your own state level and found to be lacking.
I'm just going to reiterate, it lacked in financial and operational plans, it lacked in its description of its educational plan, it lacked in measurable pupil outcomes, it lacked in employee qualifications, and in health and safety.
It's been opposed by the Richmond NAACP and opposed also by Senator Skinner and others who have sent you letters.
I ask you to agree with your staff the independent analysis that has been given all throughout the entire process and deny the petition.
Hello.
My name is Anthony Gatto, and I'm a community member here in West Contra Costa Unified.
A common argument that charter schools like to use is that parents and community members should have the choice of where to send their students.
Well, I'm here to tell you that we do not choose rocket ship.
Democracy is a critical part of our public education system.
We residents tell you, our government officials, what we'd like to see in our communities.
When Rocketship submitted their petition to our school board, we showed up against them and they voted them down.
When they tried to bypass our school board and appeal to the county board, we showed up again and they voted them down.
Now they're here before you, the State Board of Education, and all we residents ask is that you uphold the decisions made by our local elected officials that came from us local residents and that you deny the Rocketship petition.
We do not want them in our communities, we do not need them in our community, and we would like you to deny the petition.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board members.
My name is Francisco Ortiz, and I'm a teacher at Ford Elementary, which serves students in Richmond and San Pablo.
I'm also a proud product of Dover Elementary and Middle College High School in San Pablo.
When I reunited with my parents here in the US, I could not speak English.
As an English learner, I was overjoyed when our board of education voted unanimously to adopt the historic EL roadmap, which values the diverse funds of knowledge our students bring to our classrooms throughout the state.
As an advocate for English learners, I am here to urge you to honor our community's linguistic needs and deny Rocketship San Pablo's petition due to their record
of noncompliance concerning ELs.
Rocketshift received multiple letters of concern from the CDE which cite a lack of appropriate ELD instruction and the same letters cited a lack of credentialed teachers to support academic and linguistic needs.
Our local and county board denied Rocketshift's petition because of a history of noncompliance and strong community opposition.
Please honor the promise this board made to California's English learners through the EL roadmap and respect our community, deny Rocketshift's petition,
Our English learners are counting on you.
Thank you.
Good afternoon my name is Ashley Verbeckmos and as a kindergarten teacher at Ford Elementary social emotional development is a huge component of our schools and our community.
When researching Rocketship I found several articles on bathroom policies leading to not developmentally appropriate bathroom accidents and you know in cases infections as well.
The theory behind this is to teach children to use their time wisely.
Students at the primary level often begin showing regression if they are denied or taught not to respond to their basic needs.
Along with this, Rocketship has been known to provide inadequate supervision, often leaving students and teachers with a 60 to 1 ratio in the learning lab and oftentimes with lack of supervision being 90 to 1.
In this setting, students are unable to practice their socialization, community building, and project-based learning.
Added to the fact that they are not supposed to speak during lunch and have a discipline policy for students to spend hours in silence.
If this is what will be happening to our community, the social emotional needs will not be addressed and our community will lack the problem solving and communication they need to navigate our society.
We are essentially setting them up for failure with this model.
Time.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, my name is Stephanie Sequeira, and I am a parent of three children within WCCUSD.
I am the current chair of our district, DLCAP, and the co-chair of our district, DLAC.
I also serve on the SSC and ELAC of both of my children's school at the middle school level and elementary school level.
I also work at Dover Elementary, which is in San Pablo.
I believe in authentic and meaningful parental involvement and engagement.
My hope is that you deny Rocketship petition because it makes it almost impossible for parents to participate in the governance of its organization.
There are zero parents in the Rocketship board meetings that take place only four times a year in San Jose during the work day.
And while parents can satisfy their non-mandatory 30 partnerships hours through attending hearings like this one today, Rocketship's structure does not allow for authentic stakeholder engagement in its governance.
Therefore, you must deny the Rocketship petitions.
Qu nos esconde?
Qu creen que nuestras familias son ignorantes?
We deserve the right to have the governance committee where parents can participate, especially when there is no one there to participate in their LCAPs.
Thank you.
Okay.
Hello, my name is Guadalupe Calvario, and today I'm here because I urge you to deny the Rocketship petition.
I am a West Contra Costa County parent and advocate here supporting parents and caregivers in the education sector.
Over the last couple of years, it has been very troublesome.
and overwhelming because of all the charters now coming into our district offering better, more innovative ways of educating our children.
Innovative to me has been the way that they profit off the families and children.
Now what's the need of charter schools continuing to open if the last school who petitioned to open offered greatness in high education for our children?
12 charter schools later and endless promises still our children are in a place where they are equivalent to our local public schools, not in a place where they are exceeding in their education.
Because as a parent you want what's best for your children is education.
If that means losing your dignity, then you're robbing your child of their childhood and yourself as a person.
You have been
You are here to decide whether we open a rocket ship or not.
And if our community is here deciding and it has been decided, why are we still here?
Thank you very much.
So I will be translating for Ms.
Ana.
Muy buenas tardes.
Mi nombre es Anne Enriquez y soy madre de dos nios que asisten a la Escuela Alimentaria Dover en San Pablo.
Estoy aqu para dar una razn ms porque no tenemos que abrir Rocketship en nuestra comunidad.
Rocketship tiene una pliza de llamar la polica si los alumnos pertenecen despus de una hora de la salida escolar.
Rocketship asume que la familia ha tenido una emergencia.
Les da derecho de llamar y entregar los nios a la autoridad o a la polica.
Nuestra comunidad no necesita mas razones de tener miedo a la policia.
Tenemos mas que recordar que no estamos en lugares como Mountain Diablo, San Ramon, Walnut Creek, o Antioch, sino en una comunidad familiar de color de estudiantes con familia inmigrantes.
El medio de la separacin de la familia y el abuso de autoridad est muy presente en nuestra comunidad.
Necesitamos una comunidad unida, no con miedo.
Recordemos, nuestro distrito ya ha apoyado la policia de Santuario.
Good afternoon.
My name is Sana Enriquez and I'm a mother of students who attend Dover Elementary in San Pablo.
I am here to let you know about a policy that Rocketship has about calling police if the students are not picked up on time.
Rocketship assumes that any family could not have an emergency.
This gives them the right to call authorities or call the police.
Our community does not need more reasons to be afraid of the police.
We have to remember that we are not in places like Mount Diablo, San Ramon, Walnut Creek, or Antioch.
If not, in a community where families of color, immigrant families, and the fear of separation in our families is very present.
The abuse of this authority, we don't need it.
Remember that we don't need, we need a community that is united and that is not afraid.
Our district already adopted the policy of being a sanctuary district.
What is Rocketship going to do to protect our families and our students?
They're just going to be using us for their benefits or their interests.
So I am here to please say no to rocketship.
Good afternoon.
My name is Maria Resendiz.
I'm a parent.
I'm a parent and resident of San Pablo in Richmond for more than 30 years.
I have four students who are already college graduates who graduated from the West Contra Costa Unified School District.
And I am here to please listen to what the community has already voiced through the denial of our school board and our county board.
My experience with charter schools has been very personal.
After my oldest attended one of their high schools for a semester on the year that they lost their accreditation, leaving my daughter with a lost year in credits and families and students left to fend for themselves.
Thankfully, one of our public schools had a program where she could make up her credits and be able to graduate with her class.
I would also ask you as representatives making decisions for our schools to start making decisions about limiting the number of charter schools in our local districts.
It is plain logic that the more ways that the money is split, the less services for the students who need them.
It is time to start making responsible financial decisions.
These are impacting our children and families for generations and right now you are an instrument to this impact.
Thank you very much.
Will the remaining speakers please line up.
Eric Premack, Valerie Jamieson, Rommel Antone, Juliet, I'm sorry, Jim Hede, Fred Farrell, Ezra Kerr, Kim Murray, Demetrio Gonzalez, Alyssa Hahn, Anna Keller, Janelle Rooley, Sonia Ramos, Era Rodriguez, Andrea LeBron,
Kim Murray, Brenda Rios, Olivia Garcia, Lydia Patricio, Sylvia Anguirus, Rosa Acosta, Liz Grayson, Carlos Talari, Lorraine Richards, Steve Zelter, and Bill Delucci.
Hello, my name is Patricia Ponce.
I am a parent.
I am a city of Sao Paulo resident for over 30 years.
I am a former Lake School student.
I am here representing Lake School.
It is a wonderful community school and our
City has adopted a resolution in 2011 to be inclusive of all of our community schools.
That's a great partnership that is working.
I'm also here to give a personal statement.
Recently my cousin had to move to ENIAC.
She went to Rocketship to request her son to be enrolled in that school.
He has a special IEP service.
My cousin spoke to the principal.
He said that he could not accommodate her request for my nephew and was not able to enroll her student there, her son there.
She couldn't be here today to give her personal testimony, but she wanted me to bring this up.
So Rocketship, you lie.
You lie to students.
You're not inclusive.
Your website says that you're totally inclusive of students.
So why is my nephew so different from everybody else?
This is a lie of a charter school.
Please do not approve of him.
Thank you very much.
Hi, my name is Debbie Bayer.
I am a Richmond resident and a community member.
I am not a parent.
I am not a teacher.
But I really do care about public education.
And I am a taxpayer.
And I've always voted for school bonds.
But I don't want to waste my money.
I support the recommendation of the WCCUSD board and the county board and your own staff here to deny the petition.
Rocketship has had
ambitious growth plans, but it has consistently, their ambition has consistently exceeded their abilities.
In 2013, it projected serving 25,000 people, 25,000 students by 2018.
In 2017, last year, it projected serving 11,000 students by 2018.
But this year, they're enrolling fewer than 11,000 students.
It's clear that families don't want the kind of programs Rocketship is presenting.
We in our district, we don't want the no excuses discipline, the high teacher turnover, and the hours of computer instruction for our children.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon.
Appreciative of you guys' time.
My name is William McGee.
I'm a principal in West Contra Costa Unified at a middle school.
And so one of the things that I would ask you guys to do is just to really uphold the staff's recommendation on what they're asking you to do for the
approval of this charter school.
You've heard also about suspension rates, and so as a practitioner, a lot of times we get students who come back from the charter schools after the C-BEDS date, and so that is something to pay attention to when they talk about no suspensions and expulsions.
And then just really understanding the local control aspect.
That's what LCFF is about.
That's what the state is recognizing that we should have local control.
And our school board denied as well as the county denied.
So I ask you guys to also consider that.
And the last thing is just the opportunity gap or what's been referred to as the achievement gap.
Our district has taken a lot of steps to really decrease that.
And you can see that with what's happening with our student academic results, as well as people selecting our district.
Thanks again for your time.
Good afternoon.
My name is Argentina Davila-Luevano, and I am a product of the U.S.
public school systems, receiving a BSW in social work and child welfare at the University of Texas at El Paso.
My career consists of having worked 25 years in nonprofits, working with families and children.
including emergency response and foster placement at Department of Social Services.
Today I'm wearing my civil rights hat because the landmark cases of Mendez versus Westminster and Brown versus the Board of Education have established that a child's right to a quality education is paramount.
I therefore ask that our parents be given the choice and option in the schools they would like for their children to attend because it is their fundamental right.
Because kids need Rocketship to expand their learning and close the achievement gap.
I ask that you vote Rocketship.
Time.
Approving a premier educational public charter school.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, my name is Angel Godinez-Luevano, and I am the Executive Director for Todos Unidos, also the trustee-elect for Kiwanis for Region 9, which includes Contra Costa County.
I've been a longtime civil rights advocate for over 50 years.
I've marched with Dolores Huerta and taken food caravans to Cesar Chavez when he was alive.
Education is the premier civil rights issue of the 21st century, and a quality education is the great equalizer.
I strongly urge you to vote yes for the rocket ship petition for the children of San Pablo, that they have a choice and a better option for a quality public charter school education.
When you look at what's going on there right now, with all those failing elementary schools, the grades are dismal.
We need the charter school and we need Rocketship.
Thank you so very much.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center.
We've known the Rocketship organization to run very sound schools for a long time and support the ACCS recommendation to grant this charter and hope that you will too.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Valerie Jameson.
I'm a proud WCCUSD alumni, active community member, and incoming Ford Elementary school parent where I also attended as a child.
This school sits on the San Pablo-Richmond border and is down the street from a location Rocketship is interested in leasing.
I know the community well.
And I'm here to tell you that there is not enough community demand for Rocketship to be a fiscally or operationally viable organization in school in San Pablo.
The handout that was distributed shows you that in Santa Clara County and other areas where Rocketship is well established, they are experiencing steep declines.
At Rocketship Alma, they experienced double digit declines despite adding grade levels each year.
Those schools are rejecting Rocketship and we are too.
I am confident that San Pablo and West County residents as a whole, such as myself, parents will continue to choose our traditional district schools for their full service programming, established city and school partnerships, and both seasoned and qualified educators.
Please vote against this petition for Rocketship in West Contra Costa Unified School District.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Juliet Jamsheet.
I'm a Richmond resident and a sixth grade teacher in West Contra Costa Unified.
I'm here to talk about the problems at the Rocketship Mount Diablo site that was already talked about in your introduction.
The State Board currently oversees Rocketship Futuro in the Mount Diablo Unified School District.
When the Mount Diablo community came to the State Board two years ago, they expressed deep concern about Rocketship's finances, teacher credentialing, and English learner programs and asked you to deny the petition.
It turns out these concerns were well-founded.
CDE staff have sent six letters in less than two years that raised concerns about the exact same issues that the Mount Diablo community warned this board about two years ago.
Please do not make the same mistake with Rocketship San Pablo.
Please do not ignore the concerns of our community and the clear evidence that this petition is unlikely to succeed.
Given the problems with Rocketship, I would urge you to vote against it.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Kim Murray and I'd like to share a parent leader's statement expressing their feelings about Rocketship.
My husband and I chose Rocketship for our youngest due to the experience he had in school and the experience our older child had in traditional district schools.
We could not afford to continue to wait for our education system to improve.
So we chose a school with high quality rigorous academics to prepare our daughter for college and beyond.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon, board members.
My name is Demetrio Gonzalez, and I'm the president of the United Teachers of Richmond, representing all five cities and close to 2,000 teachers.
I'm a bilingual teacher and have worked in San Pablo schools since I began my education career.
I'm presenting to you letters from elected officials in our district, the NAACP chapter in Richmond, Senator Nancy Skinner,
County School Board President, Fatima Allen, and a co-written letter with school board members in our district, the mayor of San Pablo, the mayor of Osorito, and our superintendent of schools.
I ask that you please stand with our community and vote no on this appeal.
In our local meetings, we had over 800 community members opposing this petition.
They had two parents.
We do not want this school to open in our school district.
and we hope that you stand with us and this community.
Thank you.
Hello, good afternoon.
My name is Alyssa Hoy, and I am a teacher at Bayview Elementary in San Pablo, California.
I'm here on behalf of Bayview staff, teachers, students, and parents to ask that you do not approve the Rocketship appeal.
Rocketship does not have the support of families in San Pablo, and as an educator, I do not believe their petition will offer a high quality education to all children.
From their inadequate English language instruction to their lack of support for special education students, this petition does not show the community they are truly invested in our students.
The opening of Rocketship will only hurt schools like my own, disrupting and possibly dismantling existing sites.
Bayview and the surrounding schools are working to provide students with a high quality education regardless of who they are and what they need.
Students and families are at the heart of our work.
Through Rocketship's deceptive actions with this appeal, it's clear that the success for all students is not at the center of their work.
Please vote no for our families, for our communities, and most importantly, for the future of our students.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Sonia Ramos.
I am a bilingual school psychologist working currently at Baby Elementary in San Pablo.
I am here on behalf of myself, my administration, my parents, staff, and above all, my students.
As a school psychologist, I work tirelessly with a dedicated team to provide special education assessment supports to his students.
At our school, we provide academic, behavior, and mental health supports on many levels, not only for myself, but we also have two community health agencies supporting the needs of our students at our school.
I'm worried that the Rocketship model does not reflect or provide the individualized support for our students.
As a school psychologist, I disagree with the fact that students spend so much time on computers and not with credentialed teachers like the model implies.
Working in our school is a labor of passion and commitment, not business.
Thank you.
Lorraine Richards, California Teachers Association.
California teachers strongly oppose
the overturning of the decisions of the local district and county office of education.
Many concerns are pointed out in the letter that CTA has given you.
Most troubling is first FCMAT, which focuses on the financial points.
Conflict of interest, lack of transparency, misuse of public funds, and outright fraud.
Secondly, Rocketship has a very high suspension rate for African-American students and students with disability when compared with other Santa Clara County schools.
Other areas that were included are qualifications of staff that are working with students, lack of comprehensive description of educational program, unclear parent involvement, and access to governing board.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Carlos Taboada, and I'm a retired teacher with 21 years experience in West Contra Costa USD schools as a teacher and a school counselor.
And I am here to ask you to deny this petition, to deny this petition and to stand by the community, the six cities that constitute the West Contra Costa Unified School District.
We do not want and we do not need yet another charter school.
You already know the reasons why our school board and the county board denied their petition, because the charter was demonstrably unsuccessful to implement the program set forth in their petition.
I also want to ask you to stand by participatory democracy.
I'm asking you to stand by local control at the district level.
Let's start there.
Our authorities have already examined the issue and they voted against this petition.
Time.
Thank you very much.
I just want to say no to rocket ship and s a la verdadera educacin pblica.
Muchas gracias.
Good afternoon.
My name is Andrea LeBron, and I'm a single mom.
I was eight years old.
My daughter is in Futuro Academy in Concord.
And we decided to choose Rocketship because my daughter was so below in reading, was not learning.
And I was worried.
And I spent six months searching about Rocketship, what it's bringing to Concord community.
And then I realized that was my school for my daughter.
Now at third grade, now she reads level almost 11, and it's been amazing.
And I decided to start advocating for the education Contra Costa and West Contra Costa as well.
I've been working with the parents in San Pablo, Richmond, El Cerrito, door knocking, talking to the parent.
What do you guys exactly want for your child?
And they want Rocketship.
So I'm here to please vote yes for Rocketship.
It's for our children.
It's not for money or anything else.
It's just for the great education that they are bringing to us.
Thank you.
Just a minute, we can't hear you, so can you turn it on?
Thanks.
Mi nombre es Eva y soy residente de San Pablo, madre de dos nios.
Mi nio estuvo en lista de espera en las escuelas Charters.
Me han gustado, me han interesado.
Yo solamente busco a nivel acadmico y me ha tocado ver que tambin son buenas.
Solo como madre busco una oportunidad para una mejor educacin tambin y para ayudar a algunos nios que, o madres que piensan como yo.
Las escuelas todas son muy buenas, pero yo hablo a mi personal, solo busco un nivel acadmico que a mi me guste.
Good afternoon.
My name is Eva Rodriguez and I'm a resident in San Pablo.
I am a mom of two children.
My child is being on the waiting list of a charter in Richmond for a few years.
I'm here to support Rocketship because I believe that we deserve a better education and options.
And I'm here, like as a mom, I'm only looking for the better opportunity on my children's education.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Olivia Garcia, and I am reading this on behalf of a Rocketship national team member.
Every morning I wake up and I know that there are more children who are capable of fulfilling their dreams today than yesterday because of Rocketship schools.
It is a profound responsibility to provide an excellent
education to all our students, and I am proud to work alongside every single of my talented and dedicated colleagues to make this possible.
Thank you very much.
My name is Silvina Arguelles, and I'm reading this on behalf of the Rocketship Education Organizer.
I love doing this work because there is something to be said and felt when you do work that changes other people's lives for the better, even if they are not completely aware of it.
Our work impacts the lives of so many people and not just the students.
And that is such an amazing feeling that even though our work can be exhausting, that feeling of helping others make it all worth it.
Education organizer.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Lydia Patricio.
I am here at the request of Rocketship to give you the opportunity to open the school.
I come to recognize that as parents we have the right to ask for the education of our children to open other schools.
Tambin nosotros trabajamos, pagamos taxes y queremos el bien para nuestros hijos.
Este, mejores oportunidades.
Quiero pedir que voten por Rocketship porque ellos son el futuro de maana, las siguientes generaciones.
Nosotros ya vamos pasando, nuestros hijos van quedando.
Denles la oportunidad de estudiar.
Les pido de favor que voten por Rocketship porque ellos son la nueva generacin del da de maana.
Y pues nuestros nios merecen tambin la oportunidad.
Y este, pues, les agradecera mucho que votaran, s, por Rocketship.
Hi, my name is Patricia, and I live in San Pablo.
And I am here to provide support for Rocketship so that they could open their doors.
The reason I offer my support is so that my children and the children in the neighborhood could have a better access to education.
Please help our community in San Pablo.
Please vote in favor of Rocketship.
Thank you very much.
Can you get closer to the microphone?
I forgot to say one more thing.
Thank you for your time and for the opportunity you gave me to speak.
The most important thing I recognize is the education of the children so that tomorrow they are not a burden for the government.
Thank you.
Our last statement is thank you so much for giving me the opportunity to come speak before you.
And children are the most important thing, and she doesn't want them to be a burden on the state.
Thanks.
Good afternoon, my name is Liz Grayson Slater and I serve as the East Bay Regional Manager for Rocketship Public Schools.
It has been a pleasure working with the San Pablo families throughout this process.
We've hosted several house meetings, information sessions, literacy workshops, and even partnered with local organizations such as the San Pablo Cowboys Youth Association, Church of Christ, the New Life Movement, San Pablo Baseball Association as well.
and many more.
I wanted to present to you guys 28 letters that we have in support from community leaders and civic leaders throughout San Pablo.
If you get a chance, please review it.
There's also a letter from a West Contra Costa Unified School District alumni who is also a West Contra Costa Unified School District parent, but chose to drive 13 years to Berkeley for a better option for her child.
And that included both private and charter schools.
So if you guys could please review these, that would be amazing.
Thank you.
Board members, Ramel Antoine with the California Charter Schools Association, speaking in support of this petition.
CCSA has worked deeply with this petitioner on this petition.
We make sure that schools are working, connected with their communities, meeting the express needs that they're looking for.
Rocketship has a very specific community that they work with, and I think that they continue to show a track record of success in the communities that they work in.
I think one thing that's important to notice, so in the findings there was talk about the levels of concern about Futura Academy, specifically around finances and letters that were issued back in October.
And initially the department said that Rocketship did not respond, and actually Rocketship did, and there was no response back from the department for quite a while.
And there's been sort of a relationship that we've been trying to work on together to ensure that the school is working to address all the concerns that the department has and is able to continue moving forward to show the department its ability to successfully implement the program.
So I hope through questioning, much more of this will start to come out so we can see that Rocketship is able to implement this program.
Thank you.
Hello, good afternoon, everybody.
Thank you for your time.
My name is Rosa Costa, and I work for the community, and also I'm president for Kiwanis Club.
I'm here to support Rocketship.
Please, we vote on the Rocketship San Pablo petition, and we need your help.
to start to give good education to our children in San Pablo.
And also, I'm here for more parents that are coming.
Please.
Soy la voz de muchos padres que nos apoyan.
Que no pudieron venir por X razones.
Trabajo o por los nios que estn en la escuela o nios que estn en casa porque estn en una lista de espera del distrito escolar.
I am the voice of many parents that are here, could not be here today.
They could not be here for various reasons, for work or because they could not find childcare for their children.
Children in this city are on long waiting lists that are at the district level.
There is no access to school to schools at the district.
Opening this school would provide an opportunity and our children would not be faced with many problems.
Please vote yes for a rocket ship.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board.
My name is Bill Delucchi.
I started my public education in San Francisco in 1950.
And I've become active because in East Oakland, where I live, there are probably 15 charter schools.
We just removed a principal
down the street from where I live, who was appointed by OUSD.
Now, OUSD has allowed the poor schools to do poorly in the neighborhoods that have a lot of non-whites.
And our local schools, even though there's white people moving into Oakland, have very few of their students going to the schools because they're poor.
And so the charters move in and have
limited success.
And so the new principal that we just got this year is going to turn our little local school around, the elementary school.
And that's what we need, the public, to support the public schools.
Please deny this petition.
We need to keep public schools strong.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Board President Kirst and board members.
My name is Janelle Rooley.
I'm an attorney with the Law Offices of Young, Mini, and Core here today in strong support of Rocketship.
And I hope that we can refocus our discussion to the actual charter petition that's at issue.
In fact, that's the only thing that we get to vote on today.
The law requires approval, as you know, of a charter petition as the default position, and Rocketship's charter certainly meets or exceeds those legal requirements.
To address a couple of the findings, first on monitoring reclassified English learners, Rocketship does monitor student performance for four years after reclassification in accordance with both federal and state law.
In order to monitor these reclassified student performance, teachers regularly review student academic data on a scheduled basis.
If teachers identify a reclassified student to be struggling academically, they will determine what additional supports need to be made.
In accordance with these regulations, the school also, Rockichip will also report on the number and the percentage of EL students meeting state standards.
Thank you very much.
My name is Steve Zeltser.
I'm with Defend Public Education Now.
And I urge you to reject, and we urge you to reject, this application.
Rocketship has a long history of falsification, of fraud, of corruption.
They've lied to the public.
They've lied to the community.
And unfortunately, this board, because you have been appointed by a governor who is a charter school supporter, like King's son, who runs an autonomous school and the Gulen-controlled Magnolia school chain, you people actually are working for the charters.
And you should not vote on this vote.
You should not have a vote on this because you're working for the charters.
You actually have a vested interest with this California Charter School Association.
Now, the fact of the matter is, charters are a cancer.
In fact, Rocketship actually meets at the Gap Foundation, owned by John Fisher and Doris Fisher.
Now, why would a charter school, a public school, meet at the foundation, the Gap Foundation?
Because they're controlled by these corporations.
They're a scam.
These corporations don't pay taxes, and they want our money, the taxpayers' money, to pay for that.
Time.
I think that's outrageous.
It's got to stop.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, my name is Easter Cowher.
I am a first generation Sikh American, Harvard graduate and Columbia graduate, and perhaps most importantly today, a Rocketeer.
I joined Rocketship in 2013 because I deeply believe in our mission and ability to close the achievement gap.
In fact, our teachers and school leaders are working towards that very mission today as we speak by utilizing this day to teach.
Since joining, I have served as Principal of Rocketship Discovery Prep, Principal of Rocketship Mateo Shidi, and today I serve as the Director of Schools for our Bay Area campuses, as well as the Director of Humanities, overseeing the creation, implementation, and coaching of our humanities model.
I urge you to approve the Rocketship San Pablo petition and am available to answer any questions during the Q&A.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Chairman Kearse.
My name is Frederick Ferrer.
I'm the chair of the board of Rocketship.
I'm a 30-year faculty member at De Anza College in the area of child development.
And I'm here today in support of the petition, but I'm also here to answer the questions you have about governance.
I've been on the board at Rocketship for 11 years, and I've been having the honor of chairing the board for the last three.
I visited all of our schools.
I've met with parents, certainly faculty and principals.
And so I'm really excited to hear a conversation of the questions you might have about governance or the work that we've done in professional development with our staff or with our parent engagement.
I've also had the privilege of doing early professional development with our new faculty as a faculty member, being able to train our new faculty around parent engagement.
And I look forward to our conversation.
And I thank you for your consideration of this petition.
Ona Keller with the California Teachers Association.
For once, I am in agreement with one of the YMC attorneys.
Let's return to the petition and to the record of this CMO.
Three different staff reports have found that this petitioner is unlikely to succeed and has inadequate educational, financial, and operational programs as evidenced by a school that you currently authorize and by the testimony you've heard today.
Rocketship suspended over 25% of its students with disabilities in one year at Los Sueos.
Is this high enough for the board to realize that Rocketship does not have an adequate plan to serve students with disabilities?
Or is this a suspension rate that is acceptable and that is worth replicating in a different school?
Rocketship schools in San Jose are experiencing declining enrollment.
This is where they started, this is their base, and they're not having upward enrollment.
Parents don't want these schools, that's clear.
Is this a school that's worth replicating?
Rocketship schools in Tennessee, which serve a higher number of African-American students, ranked in the bottom 3% of all schools in Tennessee.
Is this a program that serves African-American students well?
I don't think the record shows that.
Charters are supposed to be held to a higher standard of accountability.
This charter has not met it.
I urge you to deny.
Thank you.
That concludes the public testimony and the public hearing.
So we're now ready for board member comments.
Board member Cardenas, go ahead.
I have some questions for the petitioners, please.
Can they approach the petitioners?
Thank you for your presentation.
So, a big concern is like this is a really like pretty presentation, but frankly, it doesn't answer my questions when it comes to a really effective English language learner plan.
And so, I would really like you to explain to me what does that entail because I haven't really gotten an effective like explanation because you are planning to enter the West Contra Costa
you know, area.
And in that area, I know for a fact that it's one third English language learners.
And so you're expecting a lot of English language learners.
So what is your plan to support them effectively?
So with the time allotted here, we'll give you a brief response, but I'm going to invite our Senior Director of Achievement to answer your questions in detail.
Yeah, very important question.
Since Rocketship's been founded, a majority of our students have been English language learners.
That was our original school.
And from our founding, it was about how do we serve those students well.
We've also had a partnership with Project GLAD from the very beginning, where all of our new teachers get trained and become GLAD certified.
Our model for serving English language learners first starts with the ELD standards, the 2012 ELD standards, and how do we effectively address those ELD standards.
And then how we do that is both through integrated instruction throughout the course of the day.
How are we both addressing the Common Core State Standards for Humanities and STEM and concurrently addressing the ELD standards.
And then of course we also have protected time during the day to provide designated instruction.
where we focus on the ELD standards as a primary, and how do we support students' language development.
But our real focus is an inclusive approach, and how do we do that into and from the content.
And that's why I think we've seen the results we have, both strong language proficiency growth,
but also really strong academic results where every year we've been in existence, our English language learners have consistently and significantly outperformed their peers in California.
So it's about the model and it's about the execution to effectively serve our English language learners.
And I have another question.
So how do you plan to engage families in the process whose students are English language learners to make sure that they can be able to reclassify?
Because family engagement is very important in that process.
Yeah, so they're deeply involved in that process.
I think also, and happy to have ESER and others talk about family engagement more broadly, because that's a core part of what we do.
But they're deeply involved in the process of regular, how is your student progressing?
And in addition, obviously, we have those reclassification conversations at the end of the year, and just in the same manner, they're deeply involved.
And because we're constantly talking with families about how their students are progressing academically, as well as where they are in their language proficiency, those conversations aren't a one-time conversation, but an ongoing conversation throughout the year, so that they and us both understand deeply where their students are and where they need to be and how they're progressing.
Go ahead if you want to speak.
Yes, come on.
Yeah, I can shed some additional context on the ongoing involvement.
So we've got family conferences that take place and instead of just checking the box and saying that we are reclassifying students and connecting with families at the end of the year, what we really do is have a process throughout the year where we're able to sit down with families, create goals with families that are in alignment with what they would hope to see their child accomplish over the course of the year.
And we also share step levels, which is the guided reading program that we use, LLI levels, and any additional supports and resources with families as a way to ensure that when we have those end-of-year conversations for reclassification, families feel really confident and can engage in that conversation and advocate for their child's needs.
Board Member Strauss.
I have a couple of clarifying questions for you all as a team.
So I'm familiar with Rocketship over time, and I believe that your model, I have two questions, so this first one, your model may have changed.
There used to be, at least I remember, a ratio where the students spent a lot of time in screen time, and then the ratio of teacher to student was higher than normal based on the original model, and I believe the model has changed.
I'd just like you to clarify that for me.
Sure, I can talk a little bit about what the model looks like.
So students spend about approximately 60 minutes in the learning lab, and I feel like the learning lab is actually misunderstood quite often.
So during this time, those 60 minutes are typically broken down into 20-minute chunks.
where students have a specific online learning program that is tailored and customized to their needs and students engage in that online learning platform.
And then they also then rotate into different activities.
So for example, a student might engage in Lexia and then move into a step group for guided reading.
with their tutor and then they would move into an enrichment activity.
So either art or science or Zumba or whatever the school has elected to do.
And so that way students receive a pretty comprehensive plan of support during those 60 minutes.
Is that with teacher direction or support or aid or classified support?
That is with our individualized learning specialists who provide the tutoring support to students during that time.
And just to build off of Iser's comments, when you look at our day, our students receive more instructional minutes with certified teachers than at traditional schools because of the length of our humanities block and our STEM block.
Essentially, what we've done with the learning lab is bring in the after school activities that some schools have into a regular part of our school day.
And so that tutoring that a student might get after the school day or other activities that they might enjoy,
We've brought that into and made a regular part of our school day.
And so, students are getting the same, if not more, access to certified teachers in terms of humanities and STEM.
In addition, we built the school day so they get these additional activities as well.
I really appreciate the team clarifying.
I have another question which we heard as part of the hearing, which is that 30% of petitions that have been approved, you've not opened those programs.
That's a concern, obviously.
So I'd just like some clarification.
First of all, if you believe that data to be true, and if so, what's the large number of petitions where you're not opening?
Yeah, so we do believe that data to be incorrect.
So we have never closed a school in California.
No, not opening one that was authorized to open.
Oh, the San Francisco school?
The statement was that you had 30% of petitions approved, at least the way I understood it, where the school was authorized open and it didn't open.
Yes, so I believe that statement is incorrect, the 30%.
I don't have the percentage, but I know that there was specific reference, particularly in the CD staff report, to a San Francisco school that was authorized by the state that did not open.
Okay, so I think we have from Contra Costa Unified.
Could you share at least your understanding of that?
I'm just trying to understand this data.
Is that a concern to authorize and then not open?
A large number is obviously a concern.
Yes, the data is available on the CDE website.
Our staff did a, sorry?
Yeah, our staff did a search and found that there were four charter schools authorized by Rocketship that were not opened.
It's there.
It's on the CDE website.
Can CDE confirm this?
Somebody can look it up, maybe.
Maybe we could go on.
All right, so that was just one of my questions.
I know my other colleagues have clarifying questions.
Ortiz-Lacombe.
You know, it is right that it, I don't have a question.
Well, I will.
It is right that education is a civil rights issue of our day, and I think that maybe we're seeing it here because tempers are flaring a bit, and this is a very personal issue.
But before I ask my question, I want to start with a statement.
I was born in 1975 as a Mexicana, not an appointee.
So I don't appreciate somebody mansplaining what my role is on this board.
I'm a critical thinker.
I stand by myself.
And I've always have been deliberate about each of the charters that come to us.
So while others may be classy enough not to react to that comment, I will not.
OK, so that is my comment.
Now, my question for you.
I was looking at the California Data Dashboard, and while your mission is to narrow achievement gaps, I noticed that there is actually achievement gaps within your own network.
I know that a lot of CMOs have aggressive strategic growth plans, and sometimes in our rush to open schools, we forget to look at the ones we already have in operation.
And I think that when you show your data, it's at an aggregate, and this should not be the case, because each of your schools are actually performing at different levels.
But at an aggregate, you look really good, and I do commend you on your math results.
But instead of petitioning for another school, why not focus on your internal achievement gaps within your CMO?
And what are you hoping to do with what you currently have?
Because you also have achievement gaps.
And that is the nature of growing too fast, too soon.
When you have CMOs, you essentially begin to replicate some of the challenges that districts have.
There is a reason why districts also struggle with narrowing achievement gaps.
And now you're facing those challenges.
So can you tell me what your plan is to narrow achievement gaps within your current CMO?
There was a couple pieces in your question, trustee, so I will answer your first question.
We have been looking at the California dashboards very closely and looking at how do we approach the achievement gap even within our own network.
So for that, I do want to invite our director of programs to go more into the specifics.
And then I also want to just kind of end your last question with parent demand.
We have over 2,000 families that are demanding quality education in their schools.
So it's not a question of rapid growth for us, but the demand is exceeding the needs of the school.
But let me invite Ms.
Lindley all up to answer your question fully.
Okay.
And then you may also want to answer why the San Francisco school didn't open if you have rapid or demand from parents.
I'll answer the San Francisco school while she's getting up here.
So we wanted to make sure that we did address the issue around the San Francisco school.
And in short, we were not able to open that school due to location feasibilities.
So we did come here in 2013, and we knew that we were not able to open the school.
The staff was correct in our conversations with them.
As you know,
Real estate costs, fatalities is a big issue and we learned that lesson with the San Francisco school.
And we want to make sure that we are able to provide schools of excellence.
And if we have a charter where we're not able to provide schools of excellence, then we would not fulfill that.
As to the other schools that were out alleged in that 30% rocket ship number nine, that is a school that we opted for local control.
It was a school that was approved at the county level on a block of countywide petitions.
and it was then withdrawn and resubmitted at the local control with Franklin-McKinley School District and is operating today and doing quite well.
Rocketship 14, that was one that in addition to Rocketship 9 was submitted under that countywide petition block and we went back through to submit that through the local district
Which was then denied at the local district and then was approved at the county.
So Rocketship 14 opened as Rocketship 4 sub-community prep However, it was changed to Rocketship 9 in the name of the charters under that approval So the fact that the allegation that schools didn't open is incorrect.
There is explanation for each one of those four and
I'll start and then pass it to my colleagues too.
So we agree strongly with the need to disaggregate data in a couple ways.
Definitely across the range of schools in our network.
So every school is unique, every grade and group of students is unique that we're really looking at what the differences of performance are.
So for these purposes we did roll up
To overall look at performance.
So when we look at the performance of our schools across California we're looking for every single school to improve each year and Last year the majority of the schools improved there were a couple that didn't improve at the levels that we need to and then what
comes into play more is the level of support we are providing those individual schools through our school support teams.
So both our achievement and our director of schools teams provide coaching and guidance to the individual leaders and teachers in that school so that the following year, and even within the year, we're looking within each data cycle to make improvement so we can start improving performance.
The other way you were kind of referencing the achievement gap might have been around the differences of performance between racial or ethnic groups within a school.
Absolutely.
So we are looking both at that for economically disadvantaged and non-economically disadvantaged students and then between racial and ethnic groups.
And for that, we think about it in two ways.
One is, how are students doing in each of those ethnic groups compared to the alternative school that they could go to?
And in both of those cases, when I think of the chart that the West Contra Costa put up around
Asian American students and Latino students.
In both of those cases, both groups were far outperforming their peers in neighborhood schools and were improving faster than the state.
So, we would love to see a smaller gap between those groups within our own schools.
We agree with that need.
That said, they were absolutely, by coming to a rocketship school, doing better than they would have done in the local alternatives.
I'll turn it over to my colleagues to comment more.
And on a school-based level, we have intensified, so as Lynn was speaking, we've intensified supports for campuses that show a wider gap between the different subgroups.
And what that looks like is director of school support is intensified to two to three times a week where we're on the ground coaching alongside our principals.
Our principals and assistant principals actually, instead of being administrators, spend about 80 to 90% of their day
inside of classrooms, co-coaching, co-teaching, modeling alongside their teachers.
And there's a whole host and amalgamation of resources that we provide to our teams to ensure that we are tackling those needs.
In addition to that, we've also begun to work more closely and collaboratively with some other partnerships, such as GLAD, to ensure that we are tackling the needs of our ELL students.
And actually, in fact, on September 24th, GLAD will be partnering with all of our schools to provide hands-on training to all of our teachers and school leaders where they will be modeling lessons, school leaders will be observing, then school leaders will be teaching, and they'll be receiving feedback, and then teachers will be teaching.
And so we've got a pretty robust cycle to ensure that we're constantly keeping our eye on different subgroups so as not to leave them behind.
Okay, who's next?
I'm sorry, Patricia.
Board member Rucker.
Okay, so I have several questions for the petitioner as well.
I'm going to start with the fact that, first of all, I want to thank all of the people who came here today to participate in this hearing.
And anytime you make the decision to take the time to leave your home and leave your work and community to come,
to these meetings.
I appreciate it.
It's another opportunity to meet somebody, to hear about what's going on in your communities, and to understand what's real and what's important to you.
I have become accustomed in the time I've spent on the board during these particular charter school appeals
that the passions are high and the issues are personal.
So I'm accustomed to that.
I'm also accustomed to the hyperbole that's often attached to the conversation and the presentations that are made.
So I have a lot of questions and
Unfortunately, I didn't communicate it with the previous charter school.
When I ask you these questions, it's not so that I can point out something you did wrong and you begin by saying, I'm sorry.
I'm not asking you the question so that you begin your response with, I'm sorry.
So, I just want to make sure I'm clear on that.
So, I heard you say in response to some earlier questions from this panel that part of the reason why you are trying to grow and trying to continue creating new charters
is because of parent demand.
And I'm aware that you seem to be very comfortable with the demand or support that you've gotten from many of the communities where your schools have started.
That doesn't seem to be the case here today.
I'm hearing an equal amount of concern as well as support as it relates to this particular charter.
And you have chosen to make parents' support and demand material to the reasons why this charter should be approved.
So for that reason, the opposition that we heard here today is also material.
Can you explain to me what you have learned from what you heard today from this opposition?
I've learned quite a bit.
I've learned that this is definitely an emotional issue and that the community is very passionate about public education, community at different layers, educators, families, students, our elected officials, and we see ourselves as part of that community and we share the passion.
I would disagree with all due respect on parent demand.
We have nearly 500 intent to enroll forms today for families that are ready to come to the school for 2019-2020.
I think looking into the audience, I do also have a lot of respect for the teachers that came here today instead of being in the schools because they are passionate about this issue.
And I wish all of our families could be here as well.
However, that was not the case for today.
So I'm learning that issues that are important to the community, that people are passionate about, that time, energy, and commitment is definitely valuable in coming forward to either defend or speak against something that you believe in.
Okay.
So I have a few, I have several questions about your petition itself.
As a charter management organization, you do have other charters that are in place and you do have some internal issues concerning the performance of those schools.
So my question again is about your learnings.
Based on the performances, and I'm going to use the word performance, not failure, so that I don't hear you say, I'm sorry.
Based on the performances of those schools that are not doing as well as they should, one of the things you are charged to do is address the issue of implementing a successful academic program.
What is written into this charter that is different that shows you clearly understand the issues of the performance of your other schools that you believe you can address in this program that's qualitatively different about what you wrote in the description?
I believe you started the question with what have we learned.
I want to know what's different in this application that addresses the concern that has been raised about the likelihood of implementing a successful academic program.
That's based on the fact that you currently have some schools whose performance is not what your goals are and not what you would like to see.
The reason I chose to ask it that way is at a previous hearing in July,
I didn't mean to, but the CEO fell back into a corner and said she was embarrassed by the performance of her schools.
I'm not asking you to admit your schools are performing badly.
We know that.
I want to know what are you going to, what did you do differently in this application to address what apparently happened that led to that performance?
So I think overall we're very proud of the success of our Rocketeers.
We do learn as we as we see areas that we can improve and I'm going to invite Mr. Josh Drake to talk specifically about those areas.
I will say what's different about this petition.
About two and a half years ago we had another petition come forward to this board that was approved
for Rocketship Futuro.
I will say the petition in front of you today has gone through vast revisions and remarkable edits, not only in our presentation of the petition, but also in the design of our program.
So I'm going to let Josh Drake talk a little bit about what we've done differently to address some of those issues.
I mean, it's a process of continuous improvement, and I'm happy to talk about that.
But I just want to start off by clarifying.
We shared, and West Contra Costa shared, our school-by-school performance, where the schools consistently outperformed their neighboring districts.
And so we are not embarrassed of any of our schools, and our schools are performing well.
And when you look at the combined performance of our schools, you see we consistently outperform similar schools across the state.
Now with that, in our petition, it reflects the best practices we see across our schools and how do we support them on execution.
Everything from the humanities curriculum, the STEM curriculum, to supporting teacher development, to supporting a range of students, whether it's students with disabilities, English language learners.
How do we meet the needs of all the individual students?
And I think, just as we discussed, when West Contra Costa decided to focus on two specific groups, Asian and
Latino, you saw our students are outperforming their students, and that's also what we see in the South Bay.
So we are not here to apologize for our schools.
We are very proud of our schools and their performance.
Every school has room to grow and improve because we haven't closed the achievement gap.
And that's the continuing work that keeps us going day, night, and week by week, and every year.
So, I just want clarity.
If there's a specific school that you saw low performance, would love to hear that specific school you're concerned about, but I don't understand the basis of the conversation of low-performing schools.
Okay, so that question is not going to get answered.
I'll move on to my next question.
The point was raised about the suspension rate, particularly for two student subgroups.
Was it English learners?
Students with disabilities and African-American students.
I don't have all of that information.
My computer has logged off again and won't let me get back on.
So I'm going to ask you, could you please explain to me, in your student, I did look at your student handbook in preparation for today and I looked at all of that information.
So even though your student handbook isn't actually evaluated,
as part of the consideration for approving the charter.
It does inform a lot of these issues about school climate and things related to this reasonable expectation about implementing an academic program.
So, do you have a number of suspensions of students in those two student subgroups that seems to be higher than it is for other student subgroups?
Let me talk in detail about what our suspension data is.
I think in somewhat of a similar fashion, this is an anecdote versus actually comprehensive data.
That's what I'm asking.
So what was shared was one particular school, and we're concerned about that school and trying to help that school serve all students well.
But when we look at our network-wide data, our suspension rate for all students last year was 1.4%.
When we look at what was our suspension rate last year across all schools for students with disabilities, it was 4.6%.
When we look across our network for our suspension rate for African-American students across our schools, it was 2.3%.
So those are good results, but not good enough, right?
Because there's still a difference.
And so how do we work on that?
I would say something else about suspension rate.
It's a metric, right?
And it tells you the number of students who were suspended.
But it's an indicator of much more with some of what you alluded to.
of how are we supporting students?
How are they engaged in the classroom?
What are our staff prepared to support our students and have them be successful in our classrooms?
And that's where I think we've made these deep investments for multiple years as well as continue to invest.
So we've done everything from training all staff on understanding behavior, the escalation cycle.
How do you respond to students at different points in the escalation cycle?
Trauma-informed care, how to support students with that.
and making sure our teachers build deep relationships with our students because that's where it starts as well as our families.
So we've made a number of investments and I think the result is what you see in our suspension rates across our schools.
Okay, so you were going down the road that I was going with the academic performance of those students.
Is there a significant difference in the performance of the students with disabilities at your school?
There is a significant difference and we're working to close it.
I think we see a difference similar to every school, unfortunately, that we see in the American education system.
But what we see is our students are performing stronger.
I think you saw on the deck the academic growth our students with disabilities had last year.
And so we are working hard and we're seeing those students close the gap.
Have they closed the gap yet?
No.
But are they working towards closing that gap?
Yes.
And in a way that we don't see in our neighboring school districts or at the state level.
Is there a difference in the performance of African-Americans as a subgroup in your schools as compared with the other subgroups of students in your schools?
And so that I'm not keeping a secret, I have a vested interest in how you answer that question.
I'm happy to answer that question.
I'll speak specifically about the California schools.
So according to the independent nonprofit study put out by Innovate Public Schools, Rocketship Mateo Sheedy is the only elementary school in the Bay Area where low-income African-American students beat the state average for all students in English language arts.
as called out by the 16-17 CASP results.
And so I want to call that out.
In our other schools, we will say that we actually don't have enough of a sample size of African-American students to be able to, for those students to be able to be reported in those reports.
So Rocketship Mateo Sheedy has the largest population of African-American students and is the only elementary school who is beating the odds for that subgroup of students.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
For the school that you reported, is that the school that you're the principal at?
So, I actually took over as the interim principal after Jason Promolitz passed away.
Were you at a different Rocketship school?
Prior to taking over in the passing of Jason Fomotes, yes.
Okay, so for the other Rocketship school where you at, I understand you just said that you don't have a significant subgroup size for them to be reported in the state accountability system, but you do know about the performance of the African-American students at the school where you were the administrative, the educational leader?
Yes.
Tell me about their performance.
I can't recall every single student off the top of my head.
I think we had approximately seven students, but they were on average either meeting or exceeding standards.
The other thing to add that was shared earlier that was incorrect, we do have schools that have a majority of African-American students in Tennessee as well as in D.C.
And in Tennessee, our school with the majority of African-American students is in the top tier of growth among schools in that state.
That's nice, but I'm in California.
So thank you for sharing that.
I do appreciate that.
The problem is I'm trying to understand what I've heard that's material to this review.
When you came to us two years ago for Futuro, I was not satisfied with what you wrote, especially as it relates to the program that you were going to implement concerning English language learners.
You had a question asked of you from one of my colleagues already and you didn't answer that question and I voted no against that school because you didn't have a clear academic program or concerning all of your students, particularly students of color, and you didn't clearly lay out what your program was going to be for English learners.
I still see the same deficiencies in what you wrote in this description.
Yes, it's better, but you still didn't address the deficiencies that were raised by me personally from your previous program.
So I have a concern that you're not just replicating what you're doing well, you're continuing to replicate what you don't do well because you don't understand it.
I'm done.
Okay.
All right, Ting Sun.
First of all, member Ortiz-Lacon, thank you very much for expressing very much what was on my mind.
I have faced bigotry and stereotyping all of my life, whether it's because of the way I speak, the way I look, and what I eat, and what profession I've chosen, and how I serve the children of California.
So my way of combating that is to actually model open-mindedness, critical thinking, and empathy.
Because, in the words of our former President Obama, if we get in the habit of bending the truth to suit political expediency or party orthodoxy, our democracy will not work.
It's always a shock when you're attacked in that way.
And even after all of these years, in the ripe old age of 52, to be attacked in that way still continues to shock me.
But as I said, I'm very proud of what I've done, and you're not going to take that away from me.
So first of all,
I do have actually questions for the petitioners, please.
One of the, one of my concerns is that when CMOs do expand, that they go into communities and it's not necessarily, what I want to get a better gauge of is was Rocketship invited into this community?
Was this something that,
Rockship said there's a need in here.
I'd like to find out a little bit more about that because one of the things that has really troubled me about looking at these charter petitions is how divisive it is in these local communities.
So can you tell me a little bit about your process for going into the community?
Was it an invitation?
Was it something you decided you want to do?
And then a little bit more I know you've talked a little bit about how you've engaged community and there's interest but a little bit more about that a little bit more so the the decision to go into San Pablo was was Took us a long time years before we made the decision to move in there and even with the
parents driving the demand, we still wanted to make sure that we were making the right decision and be able to bring a quality school to a community.
As you know, 10 of our schools are in San Jose, we have one in Redwood City, and then our first school in Contra Costa was the Futuro School that you all authorized.
So this was not a decision that was taken lightly.
We looked at all of West Contra Costa County as a possibility because we had many parents from different areas, from Richmond, from San Pablo, from Hercules, El Cerrito.
But what we saw with San Pablo is that it is a small community that serves like an island surrounded by other cities with the performance significantly below not only the district but also the surrounding schools.
So with our families in San Jose, you could probably understand that many of them are getting priced out of housing in San Jose and go into other communities.
And we do have a very robust parent advocacy program.
And so parents that have been part of Rocketship that have gone to other communities have reached out to us either on social media or through our parent leaders or through educators that they have relationships with even after their child leaves Rocketship.
And so San Pablo particularly came from parent demand from Rocketship parents that were already with the Rocketship school system.
We did conduct three different focus groups with community members and parents to really assess what was the need and what were some of the challenges before we dove in.
In addition to that, we spent three weeks going door to door in the living rooms with families having conversations before even making the decision to file the petition.
Because again, we wanted to hear from families what were some of their concerns.
I did many of those door knockings as well.
Putting my name on a petition, I wanted to make sure that I was able to answer this question and be able to face families and say this was the right decision.
And as we moved forward, as we grew in the community, working with local churches, working with local sports youth groups, to city council members in particular that have showed support, you know, this is a divisivist issue.
This is definitely something that brings out the emotion in everyone, me included.
But I stand by the decision that this was the right decision.
And with parents driving this charter and driving this decision, I feel good about that.
I feel great about the opportunity to represent them for now nearly two and a half years.
It's OK.
So I'm sorry.
The other question I had was around the fiscal pieces, too.
We heard that that there was there were other rocket ship schools that had financial issues in the documentation that the CDE provided, that there was not a response to that.
But then I'm hearing that there was a response to it.
Can you describe maybe this is a CDE question?
I don't know.
Yeah, I'll ask our Chief Financial Officer to talk a little bit about detailed finances, but I'll give you some context first on the calendaring.
So, I want to start with saying that our relationship with CDE staff has grown very close.
We definitely see each other as partners in ensuring that Puturo School and any other schools that are authorized, we have clear expectations, our communication is two-way and engaging, and we are working in partnership.
However, when we first kind of started with the CDE staff back at the inception of Futuro, things worked a little differently.
I think we can appreciate that with change in personnel comes different processes and different expectations.
So the CDE staff did undergo a change in staffing from October to about February.
And the first letter of concern came to us October 4th, and that was around fiscal concerns.
And we did respond on October 24th and got no response back from the CDE.
Inclusive, the first time we found out that we were being accused of not responding was in the the CDE staff report for a different charter petition.
So I was perplexed by that, but quickly was able to resolve that with CDE.
And we saw that it was an error.
It was sent to three CDE staff members that did not forward it to
It's the next group.
So we firmly believe that any concerns in that response on October 24th of 2017 could have been resolved in a timely matter.
So for example, the letter that was sent to us in June, we've been proactive and aggressive in working with the CDE staff to resolve that.
And as of yesterday, we had a great meeting with the CDE and made some agreements on how to resolve that.
And we were able to achieve that in three to four months.
So I'm confident in our ability to continue to partner.
It's unfortunate that we have this history of law of letters, but I will say that our responsiveness, I'm happy with that.
And as long as we continue to have clear, concise expectations, and we are also adhering to the standards of the MOU, which ask for a response to our letters or to site visits within a certain amount of days that we can respond adequately.
Thank you.
Okay, Chief.
Well, you were going to have, you still, that didn't address the financial question.
Yes, I was just giving context.
Let me amplify the financial, if I may, with a friendly amendment.
There seem to be reserves in the mothership or whatever we want to call it that help with the individual charters.
And that's the impression I get.
But we don't have any understanding of what is in the reserves of some central, of the more central office.
You're a CMO and it appears that the CMO headquarters feels responsible for helping financially.
And so, but we as a board, we've heard, well, they don't have enough money.
But then we don't know where the money is that is maybe coming to help you or how much it is.
So can you enlighten us on that?
Or do you plan to raise all the money yourself from your own charter?
Sure, and I'll answer it with a number of components.
First, specifically addressing the petition.
I would add that our original petition was very conservative in terms of the financials that were included.
For example, there are a number of supports that I want to highlight that were not included and that you should be aware of.
We originally had not included, for example, our charter school grant from the Department of Education, which will provide $700,000 of support for starting up the school.
And the revision that we shared this summer, we included that so that it would be more transparent and easy to understand.
We also have been very pleased to have philanthropy to support the startup of our schools.
We've had Silicon School support in our Futuro school, and we have also received a letter of support from Silicon Schools for the proposed San Pablo opening.
They would not have board approval for that until we would actually have an approved charter.
And so we did not include it.
We were very conservative in the estimations that we shared.
Their support has been at the $600,000 level.
Just specifically with the San Pablo petition, with those items included in our first year of operation, we would have a positive fund balance.
And so I want to make that clear that we would meet the requirement that the staff has clarified for us with just those additions to the financials.
Coming back to your bigger question, which is the network and asking about the financial reserves and the sustainability of the network.
We have finished the year with a very solid reserve network wide.
I know that we're only focused on our California schools.
Your question is about our network.
Our network reserves are over 15%.
across the network on a cash basis.
We were positive network-wide in terms of our change in net assets across all of our schools, so that would be the equivalent of the fund balance question.
That was positive this year across the network, so we are in a very strong position and work actively to support our schools that are being established.
I just want to communicate as dynamically as I can the superintendent's strong support for the CDE staff recommendation and for the recommendations and decisions of the democratically elected boards of West Contra Costa and Contra Costa County.
And a primary concern for us at the Department of Education and extension of the superintendent's recommendation is Rocketship's previous performance and particularly around Rocketship Futuro.
And I've got the item open in front of me and page four starts to detail the communications.
And we can debate back and forth around, you know, how those communications occurred and what had been the response or lack of response.
But just the fact that CD staff have had to issue six letters of concern with numerous site visits over the last year is of concern, if nothing more.
in my mind, that in the utilization of CDE staff resources, which are very precious, to be able to be engaging in this type of support.
There's other issues that are of concern for us, the lack of representation of students with disabilities, the English learner program, the suspension rates.
And looking at Rocketship Futuro and data on the California School Dashboard, it appears that there are three students with disabilities at Rocketship Futuro right now is what I count in the demographics.
So that's all concern.
Of concern to the superintendent as well is the governance model, particularly for those of us in Contra Costa County needing to somehow attend
even if by virtue of a virtual connection, a governing board that's meeting in San Jose is extremely difficult and is counter to all of our objectives around parent and stakeholder engagement.
So for all those reasons, and I'm happy to go into more detail if anyone would like, I just want to repeat our recommendation that we uphold the CDE staff recommendation.
A board member, Holiday, is next.
Yeah.
Okay, are we close to any more questions or we can... Board Member Valdez.
Thank you for your comments, Superintendent Price.
So staff did the six letters and I saw that one of the concerns was fiscal and then I'm looking at this document here and it shows that the school is claiming that they have 13 or 10 percent reserve this year and ending last year and then going into this coming year 13 percent and they're going to grow by over 200 students.
How can they make that claim?
I'm asking Lisa.
That part I can't attest to.
What I can tell you is that what we have seen is that just in for Futura alone, the June letter that we sent, they had negative ending fund balances and no reserve.
So that was from the second interim report.
So as we dug into that and we have had communications with them since then, as a petitioner did mention, we've been talking about why that is.
So we're
trying to relay to them that as an author, we are in the role of oversight on behalf of the State Board.
The MOU says 5% reserve.
And so we're not seeing that in their interim reports that they're submitting to us.
But that is including these intercompany loans and these deferral, these manager fees that they've included.
So,
The last we spoke to them just yesterday, if they do more of a modified accrual approach and they're talking about other ways of looking at their finances, that takes those payments out.
So that takes them having to pay back the loans and deferring those 15% fees.
It takes those things out and brings them to less of a negative fund balance.
So that's what we're seeing right now in the communications we've had with them.
That to us is still a concern, but at least now we're understanding better how they're looking at it versus how we're looking at it on behalf of the board.
Okay.
Can I ask, when you say less of a fund balance, it's still a negative fund balance?
It's still negative, but it's like $6,000 versus, I think we're at $3,000 or $4,000, right around that range.
So it's definitely less, but we're starting to better understand how they're looking at it versus how we're looking at it.
Board Member Ruckers next and then Board Member Williams.
I'm hoping we're getting close to a motion.
OK.
My question is for the charter manager.
Thank you for coming back to the podium.
I usually am not the one who asks questions about the finances because there are people who follow those budgets in far more minute detail than I do.
But there was something in the conversation that you had with Dr. Kirst, with Board President Kirst, that I just wanted to get some clarification on.
Again, I thought I understood what the concerns were on the fiscal issue till everybody started talking about it.
So, let me just ask a couple of questions to help me get clear on what is the, for me, what is the crux of the understanding about your process.
So, we have the site-based budgets for each of the school sites here, but we also have a network budget.
Can you tell me about where the funds for your network budget actually come from?
The funds for our network budget, if you mean as we, if you look at each individual school and consolidate, is that your question?
Just to be sure that I answer correctly.
I suppose I'm, for the operating budget for the CMO itself, where do those, do you sweep any funds from the site-based budgets as part of your budgeting for the CMO?
I see.
So our network or our national support
group essentially provides in terms of what the network support group does and then I'll express what the financials are to support that effort.
Okay, I'm not asking you what the funds pay for.
I want to know where the funds come from.
The funds are a combination of two sources.
We receive philanthropy and we also charge our schools a network support fee.
There are funds that come from state from from site based budgets in this state that go to your network budget based on a fee.
Is that correct?
That is correct.
But that is to provide services.
I understand.
And we only charge charge that service fee if a school is able to pay.
And I want to be very clear about that.
And that if our if a school is in a startup situation, if enrollment is still growing, enrollment is not reached.
It's projected total.
If the school does not have a positive fund balance, a positive cash reserve, then we do not ask that school to make that network service payment to the network.
We defer that until the time at which the school is healthy.
So we're very, very careful to be thoughtful about the health of the school and to be sure that the school is able to provide and to pay that fee.
We still provide the same support.
The support does not change.
It's still the full support, but there is no charge if the school is unable to pay.
All right.
So where I started getting confused was the conversation about the reserves and the differences in how the reserves were being calculated to identify whether or not we have a fiscal issue.
And given that there seems to be a fiscal issue, how large it is.
So there seems to be a reserve that you as the network, as the CMO has.
Is that correct?
That's correct.
How much is, what is, what is the percentage of your reserve over our required amount?
So there's a five percent requirement.
How much is your reserve actually?
I think it's appropriate to talk about the reserve on a school-by-school basis.
I don't think I can answer the question without further data about what you're saying.
What is that reserve on the network basis?
And I want to clarify, I think we were referring to the presentation at one point and looking at the reserve calculation in the presentation and asking what that was.
And I think this is something that we've had some good conversation with staff with over with the CD staff this week on.
The presentation we shared, our definition was the cash reserve specifically available to the school to support its operation.
And so when we look to having over 5% or having greater level of reserve for the school and what we showed in our presentation, it was related specifically to the cash available at the school.
So, I'm hoping that helps to answer your question.
Some, because I think it makes me believe the next question I'm about to ask you is not an appropriate question for me to ask.
So, when you have some school sites that seem to be in a revenue shortfall or in some kind of financial trouble,
What is your, do you have an obligation or do you believe you have a responsibility as the CMO to sweep funds from your budget over to that school site to assist in that financial or fiscal issue?
We do, and that's where our philanthropy comes in.
We look to philanthropy as being the source for helping to start up our schools.
We know that schools need to reach enrollment in order to be healthier, and we raise money to do that.
And when a school is in a deficit or still growing, we take the philanthropy that is raised, whether that be at the local level or philanthropy that is raised at the national level, and we use those funds to support the school.
Okay, so I guess that's why I'm confused.
If that's the work that you do as the umbrella organization, why is it that the schools where there is this question about the fiscal issues, how long do these problems remain in place before you
implement a plan to resolve or close the gap.
Because the reason I'm asking it, and again, based on your earlier explanation, it actually helped clarify something for me.
My concern is that as the CMO, in doing the work that you do either to charge a fee and receive state funds from California,
that you put into your budget for a reserve that you can't disclose to me because it's a complicated way of explaining how it's calculated.
My concern is those reserves go to the benefit of schools that are not in California and that's the reason why there seems to be this fiscal shortfall at these schools.
So,
correct me, feel free to correct me if I'm wrong, but based on what I'm trying to follow in this whole conversation between the two different budgeting processes and the difference in the way the CDE reviewed your budget and the way you explained they ought to review it, I'm just concerned that when you sweep state funds into the budget that you have total control over, that you allow these schools to continue to function in this with a fiscal crisis and you don't use the funds that you've taken from them to help restore or make them whole.
No, we don't do that.
We use philanthropy to support schools that have deficits.
And so, there isn't a situation as you described.
We are very careful and would not want to see that happen at schools.
We're using philanthropy if there is a deficit.
And in terms of coming back to I think the question about the fiscal, the differences in the fiscal information from staff and what we've discussed this week with staff to better make sure that we're on the same page going forward and that we're able to more clearly meet their requirements and to not have a miscommunication.
We with our philanthropy, the San Pablo School in year one would have a positive balance, positive fund balance and would be able to meet the requirements
as outlined by the staff.
We did not show that philanthropy in our budgets, but we do have a letter of that support in terms of our existing school, Futuro.
As we shared with the staff yesterday in a good conversation with the accounting that is
that we're able to use our modified accrual accounting which the staff agrees with as being appropriate and acceptable.
Our deficit this year from a fund balance will be nearly zero and we will be making going back to satisfy the staff's questions to turn that around this year to be have a positive balance.
And we want to be very responsive to the staff's concerns.
We hadn't had an opportunity to sit with them and really understand them clearly, as we described earlier, because of some of the communication in letters that we didn't have a chance to discuss with them.
But now that we have a really good line of communication, we want to make sure that they're very comfortable and we feel that we have a good path for doing that.
Okay, thank you.
Lisa, I have one question for you.
Let me see if I can express this in a single word.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
What I can say... I didn't mean for you to say I'm sorry.
I know.
Sorry, I caught myself.
I was just having a conversation with Nick about this also.
So, even though they may have cash reserves,
that doesn't mean they don't have debt.
So, in what we're looking at and when we went through the second interim report and looked through their finances, even like I mentioned, even by pulling out what they owed in these loans and deferral fees, management fees, they still had accounts receivable that hadn't been paid.
So, we're trying to balance that at school by school.
So, I mean, we're not looking at the network.
We're just looking at Futuro.
We're just looking at, you know, what their enrollment is and what their, what their budget looks like.
And so, we're just looking at that school without the, without Rocketship, the corporation, coming in to adding additional funds into that budget.
So, based on what we were seeing and based on what we reported to the board, they were in a poor financial situation and that's why we deemed them that and we're trying to treat all the schools the same to be consistent so that all of the state board authorized schools are being exactly looked at the same way.
So,
I hope that helps.
You read my mind.
I wanted to know is the way that you did the analysis and the review different than how you do it for any of the other state board authorized schools.
That was going to be my second question.
So thank you very much for going ahead and answering it.
Thank you.
OK, Board Member Williams, we're at the two hour mark here.
And so it's generally when I begin to think we could move to some kind of a motion.
And thank you.
Go ahead.
OK, I have a I have a couple of comments.
It has been a lengthy discussion and there's been a lot of passion on both sides.
And I'm going to align myself also with Feliza and Ting in terms of not appreciating the negative comments toward us.
I myself am first generation to go to college.
My mother was the first to graduate from high school.
So I'm not going to feel embarrassed about supporting schools that do really great things for kids that need those kinds of opportunities and extra support.
And I won't be put down for how I go about doing it.
That said, I have known Rocketship almost since the beginning.
I don't know them well and don't have an ongoing relationship with them, but I knew them when they first started.
I toured one of their San Jose schools and watched their creative way of using
personalized instruction combined with small groups, using the data daily to see where each student was and then regrouping and regrouping students to advance them more quickly through basic skills and then also enrichment and advanced thinking.
I know the CMO, again, I don't know it well.
I don't have a personal relationship with it or communicate on a regular basis with any of them, but I know that they are well-respected and well-funded.
I'm not worried about their finances one bit.
I'm not worried about their educational program.
I think they started with a focus on low-income English learners.
And they have kept that all the way through.
Yes, sometimes some of their schools also have African-American students, maybe some Asian students.
But their focus was, let's get this group of students and start closing the achievement gap that they have.
That's been a burning passion for them, and it's something that I admire.
And another thing I admire about them is that they're a learning organization.
They started out with an instructional model that was innovative and after a year or two or three, I can't remember, they modified it, modified the amount of screen time, modified the amount of outside time, modified the amount of teacher time, small group, large group, always looking for ways to improve.
So on those two bases, there's nothing about this CMO in particular that I have any kind of concerns about.
In fact, I have admiration and respect for them.
Now that said, I think we're, this is an unfortunate kind of time because as you can tell by this room, the tensions around charter and district issues are at fever pitch.
And they will certainly remain that way at least through the November election and maybe after.
And so it affects all of us.
And in fact, you know, people speaking up more often about charters than they normally would, they would have a year ago even.
And so some of that, a reminder to you all that the board, the law requires the board to do a de novo review of every charter petition.
We do not confirm the local control decision.
We don't confirm what the district did or what the county did.
The law requires us to look at it with fresh eyes and come to our own conclusion.
Now, that said, I think we've done that.
And I think we've done that with the petition and we've done that with the hearing and with all the questions that we've asked.
And so I'm in this awkward position of feeling like this is an outstanding CMO that does great things for students, but I am a little concerned about how fast you're replicating.
It feels like a pretty aggressive replication, and it's coming at a time when the political environment, which is not supposed to be a reason for denial, and I'm not going to give that as a reason for denial, but the political environment makes it more difficult for you to do that.
And given the Futura, that's unfortunate that that particular school, so many, the majority of your schools do outstanding, have no problems.
That school happened to be our state board school and it's, you know, had a few concerns.
So that context doesn't make it easy to make a decision.
So I'm going to surprise my colleagues and move the CDE recommendation to deny this petition.
Second.
Okay, any further discussion if that's the recommendation?
Okay, we're ready to vote.
Call the roll.
Okay.
Sue.
Aye.
Hema.
Bruce.
Mike.
It is on.
It's on.
Sue was yes.
Hema was yes.
Bruce was yes.
Now we're on Mike.
Okay.
No.
Feliza.
Aye.
Patricia.
Yes.
Nikki.
Eileen.
Yes.
Ting.
Karen.
Petition is denied
Okay, now I'm asking for us to take the public comment because we want to make sure we have a quorum.
We have 16 general public comment.
These are for issues not on our agenda, not on our agenda.
So would you call the roll please to have the public comment.
Will the following individuals please line up?
Justin Goodrich, Ed Haldago, Tamara Otero, David Maraschuto, Park Guthrie, Susan Lund, Alex Lund, Mike Hutchison, Justin Goodrich, Elaine Brown, Rob Senske, Charles Boyd,
Shelly Hamilton, Cyrus Morris, Barbara McAndrews, Camrina Ramirez.
Go ahead.
Good afternoon.
Thanks for having us back.
I was here yesterday to speak a little bit about curriculum frameworks and standards at the grade levels.
And I just wanted to have just a little bit more time to expand on those thoughts.
We're asking the board to take a look at the curriculum frameworks through a lens that is not building the content from grade level to grade level, but through the lens of what are we asking our students to learn at each grade level as a whole.
So for example, what are we asking a sixth grade student to learn throughout the duration of sixth grade?
And what we're asking the board to take a look at when you do that is where in those curriculum frameworks are the important life and workplace skills like social emotional awareness, presentation literacy, effective communication, collaboration, empathy, problem solving, critical thinking,
Where in the curriculum frameworks do we provide an opportunity for students to learn about their own strengths, interests, and values, as well as their own work?
Time.
Sorry, I didn't know I only had one minute.
Yeah, time, one minute.
Your time is up.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Thanks for having us back.
I'm Tamara Otero, president of San Diego County School Board Association and a trustee in Cajon Valley.
I want to thank you again to your commitment for education.
I greatly respect the work you're doing here and admire your dedication to the betterment of California through our youth.
Our current system continually adds tools to build equity in education, yet we haven't begun to break apart the system that supported the inequity in achievement and opportunity.
And it does concern me.
It concerns me as a trustee.
It concerns me as a parent.
I see our hours of influence in the classroom are often filled with rhetoric and repetitiveness that support the disengagement that we see that starts in third grade.
And we could be influencing tomorrow's leaders with an education with relevance, which drives the learning process through engagement.
It's really time for California to break apart the education system that we currently have and look to states like Ohio who have developed new education standards and a new system so that they can better support kids.
I would personally love to invite you to visit our classrooms in Cajon Valley and see what we're doing as an answer to that.
Thank you for your time.
You had a very long morning.
Rather than share my comments my comments are in the letter.
I will just thank you for the work this morning Trustee Sun with the Workforce Committee.
I would love to connect with you on that and simply say with the conversation on college or career, college and career how about just career?
Because any college pathway is going to hopefully result in a career.
And if we start with career development early on, then kids, when they go to invest $100,000 into a college degree, will get 100% return on their investment.
College isn't a place to figure it out.
It's a place to go with intention for a career.
And we have some resources to share, and we'll connect with you later.
Again, thank you for your service.
You're doing tremendous work, and I appreciate your volunteerism.
Good afternoon.
My name is Sarah Morris and I'm a second grade teacher from Imperial County.
I just wanted to let the board know that as a professional educator I'm becoming very concerned with some of the situations going on statewide with charter schools.
Charters have been given extreme latitude within the law for the purpose of innovation
Yet, what I'm seeing is less innovation and more problems involving financial misdealings.
I see schools that aren't adequately educating students within the current appeals process.
They seem to get chance after chance after chance.
I see that for-profit corporations are fleecing our tax dollars from California and they're being sent who knows where.
Maybe this conversation needs to take place across the street, but I just wanted to express my frustration and from a classroom teacher's perspective, I wanted to let you know kind of how we're feeling.
But I thank this board for asking those good probing questions and trying to get to the bottom of it and sort out this mess that it's become.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Barbara McAndrews and I'm a public school teacher in the Imperial Valley.
I'm pleased as a teacher and tax payer you are reviewing the petitions for renewal by charters very seriously.
Charter schools should be governed with the same rules and regulations as public schools are and I thank you for your time this afternoon.
Good afternoon.
My name is Carmina Ramirez.
And first, thank you for today's session.
I'm a teacher librarian in the Imperial Valley.
And I'm speaking as an educator and parent today who is very concerned about predatory charter schools.
In our community, they have taken advantage of the trust that parents have placed on them.
They have made promises that they just simply cannot keep.
Instead, they have neglected the well-being of our students.
They have denied access to special education resources and they spend money irresponsibly.
I ask the board to keep our kids as a priority always when school boards and county offices of education plead with you to deny renewal licenses.
Why do they get so many opportunities at messing up with what is most important to us, our kids?
Thank you.
Trustees, thank you for your important work and service to California kids.
My name is Park Guthrie.
I've been a California public school teacher for 17 years.
I teach sixth grade in Sonoma County.
I'm also the parent of three kids in California public schools.
I respectfully request that you follow the lead of 23 school boards across California, Colorado, and New York to pass nonpartisan climate action resolutions.
As you know, climate change is not a partisan issue.
It is a generational justice, a social justice, and a human rights issue.
Congress has failed to act, and by doing so has put our current and future students at significant risk.
We know the harm.
We are mandated reporters.
No educator or educational institution has to be a silent witness to the generational neglect that national inaction on climate constitutes.
You have an inspirational history of fighting for equity and justice for all California kids.
By passing a climate action resolution, you can clarify the moral imperative for Congress to act to protect our students.
If you do so, likely hundreds of school boards across the state and possibly thousands across the country will join you.
Together, the educational sector can help break the logjam on rational climate action in DC.
Thank you.
Hello my name is Alex Lund and I'm an eighth grade student from San Anselmo California.
I'm here today to ask the State Board of Education to end the charter appeal process to ensure the local control of our public schools.
I've been in the Ross Valley School District since the age of five when I started Wade Thomas Elementary School.
For six years I had an amazing learning experience with the Wade-Thomas community.
I am now a student at White Hill Middle School and the soft transitions they offered us helped diminish the majority of the stress around entering a new school that was much bigger than the environment that we were used to.
When I entered middle school the building where our classes were held was separate from the 7th and 8th grade buildings and we barely interacted with the other two grades.
By the end of the year I found out that the following year our school would be losing most of our sixth grade building, close to half of our blacktop, the library on Mondays and the gym on Fridays to a new K-5 charter school being opened on our campus.
At first I was confused about this happening because we already have three charter schools in the Marin County area and many great homeschool programs so why do we need another that would directly be taking resources from our school and its district.
Many classmates of mine are being taught in flex spaces with always whiteboards for walls.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Rob Sandusky.
I'm also from the Ross Valley School District.
I stand with Ross Valley Public Schools as well as with our friends here from Richmond today, Oakland, San Francisco, San Jose, and others.
And first off, I want to thank you for your deliberations today.
I really appreciate not just the outcome, because I am biased, but that you put so much time and effort and good questioning into it.
I would also like to encourage you as the governing body to return the ability to approve charters back to the local level.
We know these communities.
We are those communities.
We know all the nuances that the state, with the distance from where we live, can't possibly know.
So that's where that...
control should happen.
We've experienced some pretty nasty things in our community as a result of the charter school that was just mentioned.
And by removing that ability for us to decide whether that's right for our community, it's a form of taxation without representation.
So we encourage that you encourage the legislature to pass laws as you have the power to help do that, that will bring that back to the local level.
Thank you again.
Hello, my name is Charlie Bott and I'm also part of the Ross Valley School District.
The student that was speaking previously, the middle school she was at, they had an influx of students for her year, but we did the right thing a few years ago.
We passed a bond to build on that school so that they could house those students.
By the time that those kids got there, the charter, which didn't even exist when we passed that bond, moved into those spaces.
And those kids, they had no lockers.
The sixth graders were wearing backpacks around school all the time.
That's the environment that we're in.
Let's be clear.
Charters are private entities that are using public funds without public representation.
Thank you.
ACP moratorium on charter schools until you can go through the legislative process that I believe is going to be starting up with your task force.
And I really believe that this is an important point in time for reviewing charter law and looking at some reforms because it is a heated issue and what we've seen in our community is because of the inconsistencies and because of sometimes the internal contradictions in the law and some accountability issues, it's left up to neighbors to be fighting each other.
and it's left up to the courts.
We just had a recent lawsuit, and so there's a lot of public money that's being spent on lawsuits and a lot of school board time that's being taken up because there needs to be reform in our charter law.
So I really, really want to encourage you to take that seriously and to consider a moratorium.
I also have a letter here that I'd like to leave with you that I sent back in August of 2017 about the issue going on, and I never received a response, so I thought I'd bring it to you today.
With Pam right there.
Thank you all very much for the public comments and for the people who waited through our long hearing.
And just to share with you that we all will read those letters if we haven't already read them and take really into consideration what your comments were.
Thank you very much.
We have, we're going to do our board reports now and we're going to go alphabetically.
So Member Burr, would you go first?
Oh, we need to adopt the minutes.
I apologize.
The draft preliminary minutes from the July board meeting.
Do I have a motion to approve?
So moved.
Second by Bruce Holliday.
All those in favor?
Thank you.
Member Burr.
So briefly on the California collaborative, you heard yesterday during our system of support item about some of the work that we're doing.
I also want to let you know that at our last meeting, August 23rd, we began a fairly substantive planning conversation to set long term goals.
As I mentioned, Eileen mentioned as well, we have a new executive director.
We're very excited about Tom Armolino.
Tom led us through that process, obtained substantive input not only from the board, the collaborative board, but also our partners, including the department and county offices.
And those will be incorporated into final action steps at our October meeting so that when Tom comes here to the board meeting in November, you'll get to hear about that.
And I just wanted to underscore that one thing that the collaborative board especially is very interested in, I know this board is very interested in, is not only setting the goals but also establishing metrics by which we will judge our success and related specifically to how well our students are doing.
And I think that's a very important aspect.
The other thing I wanted to mention, I wanted to elaborate a little bit on what President Kirst touched on yesterday.
We are in our annual fall recruitment for our advisory committees.
So I want to just be more clear about the specific things we're recruiting for, the dates by which we're asking for applications, and encourage all of you who know folks who might be interested in these to ask them to apply.
So specifically we have applications due on October 5th for the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools.
We're looking, we need two appointments.
We're looking for a currently practicing teacher and a representative of a charter school.
Also for the October 5th deadline, we're seeking applications for a California Practitioners Advisory Group, CPAG.
We need two appointments there who have to meet one or more of the following categories.
A charter school leader, principals and other school leaders, and teachers from traditional public schools.
So again, encourage folks to apply for those.
On October 10th, we need applications are due for the Instructional Quality Commission.
We're seeking applications for three appointments and we're looking for expertise in history, social science, visual and performing arts, and world languages.
And finally, I always hate to do this on the very first meeting for our student board member, but we're recruiting for next year's student board member.
And so applications are due on October 11th for students who are interested in serving as our student board member.
There's some specific requirements for that, including participating in the California Student Advisory Committee meeting that comes up in November.
And I know Hema will help us out with that recruitment as well.
So please encourage folks to apply.
We need the best possible folks.
Thank you.
Thank you for having me here.
I appreciate it.
Even though it's like, you know, very long, I really enjoyed the conversation.
I'm excited to be working with you all.
Thank you.
Yes, so I'm officially the Zen master of this board as evident by today's performance.
So the health framework is it went out in March for a 60-day public comment.
We received public comment.
Our health framework is very comprehensive.
It's very progressive.
We can expect to have a little bit of pushback because we're actually
really addressing the needs of our students and whether that is compatible or not to our understanding or faith or moral values, whatever it may be, that is information that is needed in the field.
And we're getting some pretty dicey comments, but I encourage everyone to submit their comments because that is what this process really requires, right?
It requires all of us to be participatory and engaged stakeholders.
It will come to the IQC September 19th and then it will go back for another
60 days, another 60 days.
So please do provide your feedback.
I was at Stanford last year, last year, last week, presenting on ESSA and Latino students.
And I was able to present with Matt, I forget the last name, but he's from Bellwether.
So it was an interesting panel and with Dr. Carla Estrada.
And we spoke about the different components of our ESSA state plan and what that means for Latino students.
And lastly, I gave opening remarks at the EO Consortium in L.A., and it's a new consortium established by the California Community Foundation and some of the most active EO groups in L.A.
And we spoke about the EO roadmap and also discussed policies that relate to English learners.
and engage in a little bit of back and forth with community members from Los Angeles metropolitan area in terms of their feedback on the EO roadmap.
And it's something that people really like, really appreciate and have been waiting for.
Thank you.
Well, first of all, I'm going to begin, but if I hope you don't mind, I'm going to take a moment of personal privilege.
It's been my pleasure to sit on this board and to have started my tenure on this board with seven other people.
And I just want to say that the hallmark of the work that we've done has not been on the innovation.
that we have considered and implemented.
It's not been on creating the theme of the California Way, and it hasn't even been on how hard our conversation's been.
It's really more been on the leadership that I have been able to share, the conversations that I have been able to engage in, and the very deep and thoughtful disagreements as well as agreements that we have had.
It didn't matter how heightened or passionate the conversations were,
They were never personal and when the meeting was over, we smiled, we talked, we shared, we had great camaraderie.
And so for those who have gone on before us and are leaving and those who have already left us and for those like board member Cardenas who are joining us, I want to make sure it's clear that for us, it's about the work and it's about the leadership that we engage in to lead in this work.
And while it is personal because we derive great satisfaction from what we do and what we accomplish, at the center of what we do, it's not about us.
And so hearing, and I'm accustomed to being attacked just because that's what happens.
But when I see one of my colleagues attack, it hurts me very deeply.
So I'm very proud of not only who I work with, but who I work for and why I'm doing it.
And so I want to make sure all of us agree and can definitely tell the rest of the world we work together and we strive together, but we take those hurts together as well.
So having said that, having said that, the IQC is one of the agencies that I am a liaison for.
The IQC has been very busy since our July board meeting.
All the members of the IQC participated in facilitating the week-long science material review.
I'll let our liaisons talk more about that if they want to because I know there's been some subsequent work.
But when they came back for the subsequent IQC meeting at the end of July, they took a lot, they did a lot of deep study and made several actions, took action to approve several steps.
Of course, you know, today we did approve the draft computer science standards.
That was after a lot of work that was led by the IQC and my colleague, Trish Williams.
We also approved from the Subject Matter Committee, we approved the Draft World Language Standards for 60-day public comment, as well as the online survey for the Draft World Language Standards to support submission of comment during the public review and comment period.
They also approved the Visual and Performing Arts Standards for 60-day public review and comment period and approved the online survey form for the public review and comment period submission.
The Health Subject Matter Committee approved edits to the draft health framework, particularly focused on the access and equity chapter seven.
And then finally, we took individual time to recognize the fact that when we come back this fall for our last couple of meetings, we are going to be losing three members.
It's been a great pleasure to work with the IQC and I look forward to continue doing that work.
So thank you very much.
The Advisory Commission on Special Education met here just a few weeks ago, and it's always a rich couple of days with very passionate people who are leaders in the field, so I'm always delighted to join them.
One of the highlights of our meeting was a gallery walk in the Special Education Division.
And what we did is we actually toured various units and I have to say the personnel in this division are responsible for a really complex range of contacts, activities, and issues.
It was eye-opening.
I wish everyone could do that.
And one of the things that I came away with was this knowledge that every person is really dedicated on about
or focused on students, it's very student-centered.
And sometimes that can get lost.
We speak in this institutional language, but really it's all about the kids and making sure that we're doing the best we can by our kids.
I also appreciate the assessment development administration division talking about the individual student assessment accessibility profile process and what this is a consistent and effective system for providing appropriate accessibility resources to students based upon their needs.
And we talked about professional development options for educators to support their implementation of that process.
And there was an acknowledgement from the department that we need to build awareness in the field about accessibility resources to support our students.
And we always have visitors from the field and parent representatives.
And one of the things that I heard was that some educators are reporting that there is a direction from the districts to only use accessibility supports in the spring around assessment time.
But there is
more work around supporting educators to use these supports for the benefit of students.
And just another note, the English learner special education guidelines are being developed right now, so that's promising.
And there are also rollouts of dyslexia guidelines happening this year.
California State Summer School for the Arts.
More than 500 high school students completed four weeks in residence at the California State Summer School for the Arts at CalArts in Valencia.
And to share a quote from Michael Fields, who's the executive director, and I quote, it is four weeks of swimming in new realms of the work being challenged to transcend the status quo.
and to strongly exercise the imaginative and collaborative muscles.
The experience and daily practice will definitely serve each person who is a participant for the rest of their lives.
So it's just wonderful that it's been in existence for more than 31 years now and it's still going strong, making a profound impact on the lives of our students in California.
I'm going to be a grandmother tonight, so I'm leaving as soon as we're done.
Two things.
One is that for the world languages standards, the commission took action, the draft world language and an online survey is now out for 60 days, so we encourage you to go online to the CDE website.
to partake in that.
And then secondly, I just wanted to say, as school started and as Superintendent Torlakson shared about the fires, our district was involved in the fires.
We had a school up in the mountains, Idlewild, and the fire went all the way around the entire town, but did not burn down the town or the school.
We actually had a board meeting there the other night, so that was good news.
And I happen to have a husband who works in Lake Elsinore, and they had the holy fire, and that was quite
big event and it was a week later that they were able to start due to all the fire cleanup and so one of the things I think eventually we want to begin to look at with all of the fires is there is FEMA there's ADA recovery but there is no cleanup dollars if you will to do recovery so the 1.5 million that the district had to take to clean up all the smoke and ash is on the district right now so that's just something down the line I think we should look at.
Alphabetical, right?
Two points about environmental literacy.
First of all, Senate Bill 720, the environmental literacy bill, authored by Senator Ben Allen and Assemblymember Tony Thurmond, passed the California legislature on August 31st.
The bill is now moving on to the governor's desk and we hope that he will sign it.
The bill deepens the state's commitment to environmental literacy and in particular California's environmental principles and concepts.
The bill gives direction based on the core ideas in the blueprint for environmental literacy to future state superintendents of public instruction to facilitate bringing environmental literacy to students.
and encourage local school boards to be more active around environmental literacy.
And the bill also encourages Cal Recycle's Office of Education and the Environment to provide technical assistance to educational agencies wherever young people are being educated about the environment using the E, P, and Cs.
The members of the Environmental Literacy Steering Committee are very excited about this bill.
The other item has to do with the Global Climate Action Summit that takes place this month, and I'm sure you're aware of.
You may not be aware that there is an education affiliate event.
The California Environmental Protection Agency, the California Department of Education, the State Board of Education, the California Subject Matter Project, Strategic Energy Innovations, Ten Strands, and the University of California Office of the President are partnering to host
an education affiliate event as part of the Global Climate Action Summit in San Francisco on September 12, 2018, next Wednesday, right?
The event will focus on elevating education, community engagement, and workforce development as an important part of driving ambitious climate change action, and it's taking place on Wednesday, September 12 at the Exploratorium in San Francisco.
There's a large wait list of people and groups interested in participating.
And that's all I have.
So just to follow up on IQC.
So while member record I do the liaison work for the general IQC work then each of us have different assignments for frameworks and content area.
So just a support of the science the week of July 16th right after our board meeting there was a
intensive week of review of materials.
So I think it was 34 materials were submitted, five were not approved, and they have a whole hearing process, and it goes back to IQC for final decision.
But in November, we will be getting from IQC the recommended list of materials for K-8 science, and then that will be the day that we also kind of look at the history of five years, where we are in the implementation.
So just to let you know and remind you that we'll be doing that as well.
The credentialing commission met beginning of August.
I just want to highlight the special ed focus is still a highlight.
Kristen Wright, our director of special ed, and her team were there.
And we're looking at some updated kind of approach to special ed, pretty much generally a common core of training and what they call a common trunk for all teachers and then
branches out for special ed or for content areas that we need.
So with that, we have a new title for education specialist credentials, mild to moderate support and extensive support.
And the special ed department's been working really closely.
There'll be new program standards.
You'll hear more about this, but it's a real strong effort, particularly out of the task force that Dr. Lyndon Darling-Hammond and Mike Kurse actually supported when we had our state special ed task force.
There'll be a lot more about this, but
We all know the issue with special ed.
I'm just trying to kind of go fast.
CPAG was an intensive meeting and that affected our conversation for four hours yesterday morning.
So anyway, hold on just a minute.
So starting tomorrow, Saturday, Sunday, Monday, Glenn Price and I and some other CDE team
will be at the Atlantic Rim Collaboratory.
And this is actually delegations of states like California, Mexico, Oregon, Washington, and countries like Ireland, Scotland, Wales, Sweden, Nova Scotia, Saskatchewan, and Iceland, actually.
Anyway, so we're actually coming to a summit on dealing with kind of three areas, and I thought you'd be interested.
We'll give a report back first.
Tomorrow we're going to be on a dinner panel talking about the California way and what continuous improvement is and how we've approached it and what our philosophy is.
dealing with equity, well-being, and inclusion, and leading change, and kind of rethinking the difference between central and local control.
So that's coming up starting tomorrow in downtown L.A.
And then next week, there's a Standards Implementation Steering Committee.
That's a group of the State Board, CDE, and the county offices.
So that's trying to coordinate all the standards implementation across the state, what's going on, and what our next steps are.
It's really a good collaborative work.
And then I'll be joining Bruce in San Francisco for this.
And then the Concurrence Commission is actually working with CSU, UC, and K-12.
And next fall, we're going to have a sustainability conference.
We have our first planning meeting in October.
But it's all around environmental literacy, public and private schools.
What can all of our systems, K through higher ed, do to work on sustainability?
So it's definitely linking all of our levels of education together.
So I'll be reporting back on that.
Thank you.
Well, we had about an hour report this morning, so I won't go on about the workforce pathways.
However, I want to take this opportunity to bring something up with Member Sandoval around special education.
And we haven't heard about special ed in a little while.
I'm wondering if there's a possibility of getting a little report.
We had heard about SELPAs being part of the statewide system of support.
In my region, we're experiencing school districts leaving their SELPAs and trying to become their own SELPAs.
And what does that do with the SELPA system?
So I'm just kind of curious about that and any... What are we looking at with special education funding these days?
So it might be helpful to have some kind of an update on special ed.
Okay.
Is this set for January?
Oh, great.
Okay.
Very good.
July 24th and 22nd to the 24th, I went to Denver.
Code.org invited me to come to their teacher con.
They have two of them in the summer, one in different cities, one kind of west and one kind of east.
They provide professional
their curriculum and professional development for Computer Science Discoveries, which is a grade six to eight course that they've developed, and Computer Science Principals AP, the high school course that they developed, they provide that free of charge, including, this is, I think, the third year they've done that or the second year, including transportation and meals and accommodations.
And there were
550, no, there were hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of teachers there, of which 44 were from California, from the Sacramento area.
So Sacramento County Office of Ed is a regional partner to Code.org, and they're the ones that generated all of the teacher interest in going.
27 of them took the middle grades professional development.
17 took the computer science principles of the high school.
And I was invited for the first couple of days just to walk around and observe and hear the teachers talk about it and see what they were learning.
And then Code.org also arranged a special luncheon on day two of just the California group and me.
giving them an update on California state policy on computer science and answering their questions.
So that was fun.
And then at the end of this month, on September 27th, 28th, the National California Science, no, not National California, CSTA,
I've got two CSDAs.
Yeah, I always revert automatically to California Science, but it's the National Computer Science Teachers Association combined with Code.org is having their third state leaders policy convening.
This year it's in Denver.
That's for a 24-hour period plus the travel time.
And I'm invited to that, paying my own way to that.
But I might want to renegotiate that because they have asked me to do a presentation on some of the people there.
There's going to be hundreds of people there from almost every state, including some other state board members, but also people who want to talk, educators in other states and computer science advocates that want to talk.
to the state board members in other states about computer science.
And so they asked me if I would talk about how to get state board members engaged around computer science, what kind of messaging might work with that.
And last thing related to computer science, I mentioned earlier that we started this journey on computer science when Hadi Partovi came.
down, and he had only launched his nonprofit organization, Code.org, just for one year when he came down.
So while we were adopting our standards yesterday, he had been invited.
This is how big the movement has gone.
He had been invited by the G20 Summit in Argentina to come and speak to all the education ministers there, which represent over 70% of the students in the world, to talk with them about how the world is changing
and the importance of computer science education.
So he started with us, okay, and then that's a pretty big deal.
So I sent him a picture of the group of us outside holding the resolution and he sent me a picture of him at the G20 summit.
So that's what I've been doing and having lots of conversations, obviously, on charter stuff and ACCS and also talking a lot to the teachers, the California Teachers Association, who is very interested, of course, in that placeholder for the NGSS results on the dashboard and interested in hearing that we are likely to have a large segment of time devoted in November to NGSS and what's been happening.